GOOD AFTERNOON AND RESPONSE TO
THE COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE SEE HERE
IN THE CAPITAL TODAY WITH
DOCTOR PAN WITH US I AND ONE
OTHER MEMBER NOT ABLE TO JOIN
US REMOTELY. HOWEVER TO DATE
WILL NOT OF THE WE WILL NOT
HAVE ANY MEMBERS ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY.
THESE THOSE PROTECT PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. FOR OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. AND I SAID
EVERY TIME YOU WISH YOU
RECOGNIZE IT USE THE RAISE YOUR
HAND FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM
EACH TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR. ASKING IF YOU'D LIKE TO
UNMUTE PLEASE SELECT AND MUTE
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. OUR
IT PERSONNEL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE MUCH
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN. STATE YOUR NAME NAME
AND THEN YOUR BILL TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC. WITH ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS WILL
ALLOW AND THEY WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE OFFICES. FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON A COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE FOUR
ONE SEVEN SIX ZERO NINE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO MARKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
INDOOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY. OVER THE
PHONE IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
REMAIN BRING MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL.
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE HEARING
MEETING ROOM. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS AND IS
CLOSE TO MATTER. AS CUSTOMARY
THERE ARE NEW REMISSION TIME
LAGS. FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
ADJUSTING TO NEW USE OF ONLINE
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
IN TODAY'S HEARING WILL REVIEW
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS
RELATING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING AND ADULT PROGRAMS AND
COMMUNITY CARE LICENSING WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. I WILL NOTE THAT ALL
ITEMS IN THE AGENDA WILL BE UP
FOR DISCUSSION BUT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE WILL NOT BE VOTING
ON ANY ITEMS TODAY. WE WILL
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS AT THE END
OF THE HEARING AFTER ALL. ITEMS
HAVE BEEN HEARD. AND I WILL SAY
THAT WE HAVE A HARD STOP ON
THIS COMMITTEE FOR FIVE O'CLOCK
AGAIN IN ORDER TO TRY TO LIMIT
THE AMOUNT OF TIME PEOPLE ARE
INA ROOM TOGETHER- BUT WE- ARE
INTERESTED IN YOUR YOUR- INPUT
AND FEEDBACK AND IF WE DON'T
GET TO YOUR COMMENTS TODAY YOU
ARE. ALWAYS WELCOME TO EMAIL
THE COMMITTEE. AT NELLIS BEGIN
WITH OUR FIRST AGENDA ITEM CODE
NINETEEN RESPONSE IN THE HOME
BOUND SENIOR POPULATION.
WELCOME ADMINISTRATION- AND I
THINK WE'RE READY TO BEGIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU AYE
CHAIR EGGMAN- CAN ACQUIRE
WEIGHT ON THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING WOULD LIKE
ME TO BEGIN. I WOULD THINK
YOU'D MISS WAY. THANK YOU. BOB
WE- OF COURSE- SEEING SOME HOPE
ON THE HER BUT ARE SO GREAT FOR
THAT TO TALK ABOUT THE YEAR
THAT HAS COME BEFORE AND ALL
THE WORK THAT HAS BEEN DONE TO
MEET THE UNPRECEDENTED I NEED
BY ALSO MANY IN OUR STATE- I
WAS BE PRECLUDED THREE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE IN THE
AGENDA- AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE
WHOLE PANEL CONVERSATION. AS
WELL. SO ARE THE PART OF AGING
PROGRAM INTERNET. OF AGE
DISABILITY AND CARE GIVER
PROVIDERS. HIDDEN THREE WAYS TO
RESPOND. FIRST AND FOREMOST THE
VIRTUAL. OUR SENIOR CENTERS ARE
IN PERSON ADULT DAY HEALTH HAD
TO. GO TO REMOTE. ON MOST.
NOTABLY PROBABLY. ARE HUNDRED
MEALS WITH ALL HOME DELIVERY SO
THAT WAS A HUGE CHANGE IN
SERVICE TO MOVE FROM THE
FOLLOWING COURT AND FAILURE
COMING TOGETHER. TO BE ON THE
PHONE ONLINE DELIVERY DOORSTEP
IN OUR NETWORK MADE IT HAPPEN.
THE SECOND BIG CHANGE WAS THE
INCREASE. WITH MORE PEOPLE
STAYING HOME THERE WAS A HUGE
NEED FOR MORE INFORMATION. FOR
ASSISTANCE MORE PEOPLE WHO MAY
NOT HAVE NEEDED MEALS AT HOME
NEEDING AND PEOPLE WHO MAY NOT
A NEEDED LEGAL SERVICES BEFORE
NEEDING THEM. SO AN INCREASE IN
SERVICES. AND I WOULD SAY
THIRTY AREA OF COURSE ISN'T
GAPS. WERE EXPOSED- WHETHER IT
WAS IN. CERTAIN POPULATIONS
WHERE WE WERE NOT AS WELL-
SERVING THAT WE WANTED TO MEET
BETTER FOR EXAMPLE LANGUAGE
ACCESS. OR TYPE OF SERVICE SUCH
AS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. THAT WE
WANTED TO DO MORE ON. SO MOVING
ON ALL THREE OF THOSE AREAS TO
GO VIRTUAL TO SERVE MORE PEOPLE
AND TO SERVICE NEW AND EMERGING
NEEDS- WE'RE OUR TOP PRIORITIES.
MOVING TO QUESTION TO ME WERE A-
OF FORTUNE TO USE THOSE-
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL RELIEF FUNDS
IN A COUPLE OF WAYS. AS I
INDICATED I PRIMARILY ON
INCREASING SERVICES THE FIRST
OCULUS PACKAGE WAS FOR MEAL
SPECIFICALLY AND WE DID FINISH
THE YEAR WITH A RECORD NUMBER
OF HOME DELIVERED MEALS TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION. THAT'S IN
ADDITION TO GREAT PLATES AND
OTHER GREAT WORK OF NUTRITION
PROGRAMS BUT THAT'S THE OLDER
AMERICANS ACT- WE ALSO WERE
ABLE I'M VERY PROUD OF OUR
NETWORK- WE PULL TOGETHER WE
PULL TOGETHER AND PULL
TOGETHER. SOME OF OUR FEDERAL
FUNDS TO PROVIDE SOME STATEWIDE
RESPONSES FOR EXAMPLE. WORKING
WITH A. R. P. AND DMV WE MAILED
A POSTCARD OF INFORMATION
RESOURCES TO CALIFORNIA'S TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION PEOPLE OVER
EIGHTY. SO THAT PEOPLE HAD
INFORMATION AT HOME ABOUT WHERE
YOU CAN CALL WHETHER IT WAS THE
H. P. A. R. P. FRONTLINE FOR.
THE STATE ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES LINE FOR MY COLLEAGUES
THAT CDS CLASS- THAT THEY HAD-
THAT INFORMATION. AND PERHAPS
OUR OUR ONE OF OUR OUR OUR-
MOST PROUD ACCOMPLISHMENTS
TOGETHER IS EXPANDING THE
FRIENDSHIP LINE. WHICH
PREVIOUSLY IT ONLY SERVES OLDER
ADULTS IN THE BAY AREA WE TOOK
IT STATEWIDE. AND THE FRENCH
WINE AS THE NAME SUGGESTS IS A
TWENTY FOUR HOUR SEVEN. TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN A WARM LINE WHERE
YOU CAN CALL IT FEEL YOU WANT
TO CHAT. AND TALK TO SOMEONE
ANY TIME TO ADDRESS LONELINESS.
AND DEPRESSION ANXIETY AND MORE
AND SO WE'RE VERY PROUD OF
FRIENDSHIP LINE. CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO BE STATEWIDE. AND
WE ALSO TAKE IN CHANCE. TO LOOK
AT OURSELVES AND IF THERE ARE
SOME OPPORTUNITY TO MODERN AND
THREE. OR AT A MOVIE OUR
NETWORK INTO ONE- UNIFY CAN.
SYSTEM WHICH WILL HELP US WITH-
MINIMIZING ARE. AWESOME OF OUR
ADMIN- BURDEN AND ALSO THE MORE
REAL TIME DATA AND
RESPONSIVENESS. SO THOSE ARE
SOME OF THE WAYS WE PUT THE
MONEY TO USE. THE LESSONS THAT
WE LEARNED OUT OF THIS ARE
REALLY ARE DRIVING ARE PLANNING
IN SO MANY WAYS- FROM AGING
PLANNING TO MASTER PLANNING.
WHEN WE WERE TALKING A LOT
ABOUT IT IS THE UNIVERSE OF
NEED NOW COMING OUT OF THE
ENDEMIC. NEITHER WAS THERE
BEFORE NEED THAT IS NEW NEED
THAT MAY BE A RESULT OF THE
LOSSES EXPERIENCED DURING THE
PANDEMIC I JUST REALLY ON THE
WORLD THAT WERE MERGING INTO
AND WANT TO MAKE SURE WE REALLY
UNDERSTAND. THE CALIFORNIANS
WHO WE NEED TO SERVE. ON THE
EQUITY LINES AGAIN ARE GIVEN
THE DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT OF
BOTH THE HEALTH IMPACT OF CODE
AND THE ECONOMIC IMPACT OF
CODE. AND THE LINGERING LEGACY
OF RACISM IN OTHER
DISCRIMINATION REALLY- HOLDING
OUR SERVICES TO ACCOUNT FOR
BOTH MEETING THE NEED AND BEING
TOTALLY RESPONSIVE AND
CULTURALLY COMPETENT IN EVERY
WAY. AND THEN WE ALSO THINK
THERE'S SOME OPPORTUNITIES TO
LOOK AT THAT LESSONS A VIRTUAL
SERVICES WHAT CAN WE BRING
FORWARD WHERE OUR VIRTUAL
SERVICES. A WONDERFUL IN TERMS
OF SAVING TRANSPORTATION
INCREASING ACCESSIBILITY-
CONNECTING WITH NATIONAL
RESOURCES- AND WHERE ARE THE NO
SUBSTITUTE FOR THE IN PERSON
GATHERING AND CONTACT THAT WE
ALL MISSED SO MUCH. AND THEN
LASTLY WELL- ANOTHER LESSEN THE
PANDEMIC IS WHERE CAN WE
STREAMLINED ACROSS THAT WE WERE%
ABLE TO GET. THE STIMULUS
RESOURCES OUT TO OUR NETWORK
FASTER THAN EVER BEFORE AND WE
WANT TO MAKE THAT THE NEW NORM.
IN OUR ON GOING FUNDING AS WELL.
LAST I TOUCHED ON THE ALREADY
SENIOR. HAS BEEN ONE OF THE
MAJOR CHALLENGES AND
OPPORTUNITIES OF THE PANDEMIC.
EARLY ON AS WE TALKED ABOUT.
THE NEED TO PHYSICALLY ISOLATE
AND STAY HOME AND STAY JUST
INSTANCE A SEPARATE WE REALLY
WANTED TO MAKE SURE. THAT WE
WERE REACHING OUT WITH- DAY
INFORMATION AND SO MANY
CHANNELS ABOUT HOW TO STAY
CONNECTED. WITH THE FRENCH OF
LINES THAT YOU CAN ALWAYS REACH
OUT YOURSELF AND HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION. AND THEN MORE
RECENTLY WE'VE BEEN REALLY
WORKING ON THE DIGITAL DIVIDE-
OLDER ADULTS HAVE SOME OF THE
LEAST- PRESENCE ONLINE AND WE
KNOW THAT THAT TAKES A
COMBINATION OF STRATEGIES. ON
MAKING BROADBAND- ACCESSIBLE
AND AFFORDABLE DEVICES EASY AND
ACCESSIBLE TO USE AND
MEANINGFUL CONTENT IN SUPPORT
SO THAT PEOPLE CAN WHETHER IT'S
A TELEHEALTH VISIT FOR A VIDEO
CHAT WITH FAMILY OR RELIGIOUS
SERVICE FOR EXERCISE CLASS
ABOUT IS ALL AVAILABLE TO THEM
SO. BEGIN USING FEDERAL FUNDS
AND PLANTER P. PARTNERSHIPS WE
STARTED DISTRIBUTING THROUGH
OUR NETWORK IPADS AND SMART
SPEAKERS WITH PACKAGES SO THAT
WE CAN- YOU ARE PART. TO HELP
CLOSE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE WITH
OLDER ADULTS. WITHOUT STOPPING
HABITS. ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AT THE
FIRST CLASS THE FINANCE THANK.
HELLO. NOTHING OKAY AB AND I
THINK WE'LL JUST GO TO THE
PANEL NOW THOSE WHO WANT TO ASK
A QUESTION SPECIFICALLY HERE WE
HAVE A PANEL THAT'S RELATED TO
THE SAME. THE REST OF THE- FROM
SOCIAL SERVICES RIGHT YEAH
MAJOR. YEAH I THINK WILL MOVE
NOW TO THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES I SEE DIRECTOR JOHNSON
HERE JOINING US GOOD AFTERNOON
AFTERNOON STATEMENT AND SENATOR
PANEL BUT GLAD TO BE WITH YOU
THIS AFTERNOON- CAN JOHNSON
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES I JUST BUILDING
ON AGAIN YOUR GENDER DOES A
GREAT JOB OF OUTLINING SOME OF
THE FLEXIBILITY TO. BE PUT IN
PLACE WHERE THE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES WE PUT IN PLACE AND I
WILL SHORTLY TURN IT OVER TO
OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR AT DEVON
THOMPSON I JUST A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THAT BUT AGAIN JUST
TREMENDOUS EFFORTS AND ALL
FRIENDS. IT COURSE AT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS ALREADY HEARD A
BIT MORE ABOUT OUR SPECIFIC
SUPPORTS AROUND FOOD I JUST
WANT TO RE HIGHLIGHTS AT THAT
IN THIS SPACE IN ADDITION TO
ARE THE ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS
THAT HAVE BEEN OUTLINES AT IN
THE WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING OF COURSE WE HAVE OUR
CALFRESH PROGRAM IN THAT
EXPANSION. TOURIST SSI
RECIPIENTS OF OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND IN
THE PAST YEAR I ALSO JUST WANT
TO YOU TAKE ONE MOMENT IN TERMS
OF THE QUESTIONS THAT YOU.
RAISED RELATED TO HOW OUR
EXPERIENCE OVER THE COURSE OF
THE LAST YEAR I BRIDGES INTO
WHAT WE'RE THINKING FORWARD IN
SUPPORTING OUR POPULATIONS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND SO JUST
TO GIVE BRIDGING THE
CONVERSATION WE HAD LAST WEEK
RELATED TO HOMELESSNESS. IT'S
NOT ONLY- OUR ABILITY THROUGH
OUR IN HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
PROGRAM THAT ALLOWS OUR ELDERS
AND THOSE WITH DISABILITIES TO
STAY HOME AND GET THE SUPPORT
THEY NEED AT HOME BUT ALSO
THROUGH THE LONG TERM CARE
CONTINUUM AND OF COURSE THAT'S
CRITICAL- WHETHER WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE I JUST AS
PROGRAM OR OTHER SUPPORTS.
DON'T SEEM SENIOR CARE WHICH
WE'LL TALK ABOUT A LITTLE LATER
JUST WANTED TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY THAT THESE
RESOURCES. AND PROGRAMS ARE
PART AS A WHOLE COMPREHENSIVE
ARRAY OF RESOURCES AND MOVING
FORWARD SO I WILL BECAUSE THERE
AND TURN IT OVER TO A DEPUTY
DIRECTOR DEBBIE THOMPSON GETS
MORE SPECIFICS. THANK YOU. I
AFTERNOON THIS DEBBIE. DEPUTY
TO. FOR AT THE ADULT PROGRAMS
PERMITTED SOCIAL. AND WAS GOING
TO SHOW WITH YOU- SOME OF THIS
THINGS ACTIVITIES THAT WE'VE
DONE TO SUPPORT OUR PROGRAM IN
OUR RECIPIENTS THOSE THAT WE
SERVE AND THE PROVIDERS THAT
pCARE FOR THEM I DURING DURING
THIS TIME. SO ONE OF THE FIRST
THINGS THAT- WAS IMPLEMENTED IT
WAS WE DID IMPLEMENTED THAT
FEDERAL PAID SICK LEAVE I FOUR
FOUR CULMINATED TO CODED FOR
OUR PROVIDERS THAT BEGAN LAST
APRIL AND WILL CONTINUE TO RUN
THE THREE TWO THIS COMING MARCH
THE END OF THIS COMING MARCH-
IT ALLOWS. REUTERS THAT ARE IN
A SITUATION WHERE THEY HAVE TO
QUARANTINE OR TAKING CARE OF
SOMEONE OR IS L. OR L.
THEMSELVES OR WHOSE CHILDREN
ARE OUT OF SCHOOL AT SCHOOL AND
HAVE TO BE CARED FOR. TO TAKE
UP TO TWO WEEKS OF. AB HEATED
SICK LEAVE- RELATED TO THE-
AMOUNT OF AVERAGE HOURS THAT
THEY WORK IN THAT TWO WEEK
PERIOD. SO THAT WAS ONE
ACTIVITY. ANOTHER WAY AS WE
WORKED WITH THE COUNTIES AND
ALL OF THE COUNTIES IMPLEMENTED
UPBACK UP PROVIDER SYSTEM. FOR
TO SUPPORT RECIPIENTS WHOSE
PROVIDERS WORK OUT. DUE TO A CO
THAT RELATED SITUATION. THAT
THEY COULD. ASSIST THEM IN
GETTING UP BACK UP PROVIDER IN
PLACE TO ENSURE THERE'S HERE
NEEDS WERE MET. ANY PROVIDERS
THAT. WORKSHEET IN THE SIX.
WERE ALSO PAID A TWO DOLLAR AN
HOUR DIFFERENTIAL- TO THEIR
REGULAR WAGES AND THE COUNTY
THAT THEY WERE PROVIDING THAT
THE SERVICE. SO THEY GOT AN
ADDITIONAL. TWO DOLLARS AN HOUR
IN ORDER TO SUPPORT RECIPIENTS
IN THOSE TYPES OF SITUATIONS.
WE ALSO IMPLEMENTED SUPPORTING
OUR- PROVIDERS AND RECIPIENTS
IN ABLE AND BEING ABLE TO
ACCESS- ESSENTIAL PROTECTIVE
GEAR MASKS AND GLOVES- SO THAT
WE CAN. HELP SUPPORT YEAH.
PROVIDERS AND RECIPIENTS AND
NOT BEING EXPOSED TO KOBE AND-
AND THOSE WERE DISTRIBUTED AND
CLICK THE COORDINATION OF THEIR
DISTRIBUTION WAS DONE THROUGH
THE LOCAL PUBLIC AUTHORITIES IN
EACH COUNTY. ADDITIONALLY WE
HAD BOTH HSS AND APS WERE
PROVIDED FUNDS TO DO OUTREACH
TO RECIPIENTS ABOUT THE
RESOURCES THAT WERE AVAILABLE
TO THEM GET THEM CONNECTED TO
NEEDED RESOURCES FOR SITUATIONS
THEY MAY BE EXPERIENCING IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO STAY IN
THEIR OWN HOME- WE ALSO HAVE
PROVIDED FUNDING TO SUPPORT
OVER TIME FOR SOCIAL WORKERS.
DURING THAT PERIOD- TO ENSURE
THAT- THAT OUTREACH AND SUPPORT
HAPPENING FOR OUR RECIPIENTS.
ARE MEANT. SORRY. ONCE MY PAGE
THEN ALSO- WE DID OUT CREATES
WAIVERS FOR EXCEEDING OVER
TIME- RULES PROVIDERS ARE
ALLOWED TO WORK SIXTY SIX HOURS
A WEEK IN ADVANCE THAT- DATE
COULD BE SET UP. BUT RECEIVED
VIOLATIONS THOSE VIOLATIONS
WERE WERE REMOVED SENATE
PROVIDERS COULD WORK OVERTIME
DURING THAT PERIOD IT TO ENSURE
THAT SERVICES WERE GETTING TO
ARE RECIPIENTS. OF THE OTHER
FLEXIBILITY IS MORE FOCUSED ON
THE COUNTIES IN DOING THEIR
WORK AND ENSURING THAT THEIR
STAFF AS WELL AS THE RECIPIENTS
THAT THEY- THAT THEY WERE
SEEING WERE EXPOSED- TWO CODED.
AS LITTLE AS POSSIBLE- THE
ASSESSMENTS THAT ARE NORMALLY
DONE IN PERSON WERE ALLOWED TO
BE DONE THROUGH VIDEO
CONFERENCING AND ALL OUR-
THROUGH PHONE ASSESSMENTS IN
ORDER TO LIMIT THAT CONTACT
ALSO FORMS THAT WERE REQUIRED
TO BE SUBMITTED BY OUR
RECIPIENTS AND- TO. VERIFY
THEIR- THERE NEED OF THIS. WERE
ALLOWED TO BE- OUTPOST BY- IN
ORDER FOR THEM TO GET ON
SERVICES AS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE THEY WERE ALLOWED TO
DO SELF ATTESTATION IN LIEU OF-
SIGNATURES ON FORMS IN ORDER TO
PROCESS PAPER WORK AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE- ON THE PROVIDER
SIDE. THE ORIENTATIONS THAT
PROVIDERS ARE REQUIRED TO
ATTEND WERE TRANSITIONED INTO
REMOTE- TYPES OF OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THEM TO COMPLETE THE
PROCESS TO BE ABLE TO BECOME
ELIGIBLE AND ENROLLED AS
PROVIDERS. SO JUST LOTS OF-
SUPPORT AND FLEXIBILITIES A LOT
OF IT MOVING TO REMOTE- ARMY AT
IN ORDER TO SUPPORT- ARE
RECIPIENTS- DURING THIS TIME
THAT OUR PROVIDERS AND BEING
ABLE TO CONTINUE TO CARE FOR
THE RECIPIENTS AND ENSURE THAT
THEY GET THE SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED. I'M I'M GONNA STOP THERE
REGARDING WHAT WE DID FOR EIGHT
FOUR I JUST ASK AND HIM-
RUTLEDGE WAS WILL SHARE WITH
YOU THAT THAT THE FLEXIBILITIES
THAT WE DID PROVIDE TO OUR
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES-
THANKS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU DEBBIE- GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- JUST
BRIEFLY TOUCH ON OF WHAT WE
COVERED- FOR CONSIDER RESPONSE
REYES ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES
PROGRAM AND HISTORICALLY WE SEE
AN INCREASE IN REPORTS
RECEIVING CASES OPEN FROM ONE
YEAR TO THE FOLLOWING AT EIGHT
PM. HOWEVER DUE TO CO THAT
EIGHT PSI TEN POINT 5% DECREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF REPORTS
RECEIVED A SIX POINT 5%
DECREASE IN THE NUMBER OF CASES
OPEN FROM MARCH THROUGH JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY FOR THE FIRST
FOUR MONTHS OF THE CAN DOWN
THAT AND WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
DECREASE IN THE REPORTS WITH
BECAUSE- SENIOR THE VULNERABLE
ADULTS WE'RE NOT GOING TO
DOCTOR'S APPOINTMENTS-
POTENTIALLY TO OTHER SERVICES
THAT THEY RECEIVE IN THE
COMMUNITY. SO THEY WEREN'T
HAVING THAT SAME- INTERACTION
WITH MANDATED REPORTERS AND
OTHERS YOU MAY HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO FLAG CASES OF ABUSE OR
NEGLECT- SO IN RESPONSE TO ALL
OF THIS THERE WERE SEVERAL
THINGS THAT WE WERE ABLE TO DO
IN THE PROGRAM HE CONTINUED
OUTREACH TO THIS POPULATION-
FIRST OF ALL AND WE ALLOWED FOR
SOME FLEXIBILITY MUCH LIKE AN
ISIS US AS MY COLLEAGUE MATT
SOMETHING JUST MENTIONED- BUT
WE WERE ABLE TO GIVE- SOCIAL
WORKERS THE FLEXIBILITY TO DO
INITIAL AND FOLLOW UP. THAT ME
A PHONE OR VIDEO CHAT UNLESS
THEY WERE RESPONDING TO A CASE
OF PHYSICAL OR SEXUAL ABUSE IN
THOSE INSTANCES WE STILL
REQUIRED- ADDITION WORKER TO GO
DIRECTLY INTO THE HOME AND THAT
THE FORMER HOME DOES THAT THAT
FOR ALL OTHER CASES WE PIVOTED
OVER TO DELAY- AND IN. A WAY
FROM THE IN PERSON VISITS AND-
INTO DOING THE VIDEO OR PHONE
VISITS DURING THAT PERIOD OF
TIME- WE ALSO RECEIVED SPENDING
MUCH LIKE IHS DONE TO DO
OUTREACH CALLS TO EXISTING APS
CLIENT- WE DID OVER FORTY SIX
THOUSAND OF THOSE WELL MCCALL'S
APS CLIENTS BETWEEN APRIL AND
JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY WITHOUT.
SENDING THAT WE RECEIVE YOU
COULD DO THAT ACTIVITY- WE ALSO
WORK IN WITH THE OF A- AND WITH
AND HUMAN AGENCY TO A CENTRAL
EIGHT NINE THE REPORT ELDER IN
THE A ABUSE STATE- DAY PASSES
THAT ADMIN PROGRAM- OFF. THE
WAY REPORT COME IN VERY KEY-
SOMEBODY HAVE TO REPORT YOUR TO
THE K. ANY CASE TODAY ONE TO
HAVE AND THAT- DECREASE OF THE
DAY HUNDRED GIVE DEFENSE LINE
THAT CALLING TRUE WE COMES. WE
NEED TO INJURY YOUR ZIP IT
FUTURE TO THE COUNTY ONLINE AND
WE RECEIVED AVERAGE A LITTLE
OVER HUNDRED CALLS WEEK HE THAT
EIGHT HUNDRED- THAT THAT'D BEEN
REAL CRAZY AND PEOPLE
ADDITIONAL WEIGHTS REPORT ABUSE.
AND NEGLECT- ALL WE HAVE HAD
HAVE IT- ALL OF TRAINING FOR
API OCEAN. STATE WHY- FROM THAT
IN CLASS THREE OR INTO TRAIN
TO- AND ONLINE AND THE LEARNING
MY- AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE. O
TRAIN NUMBER SIX THOUSAND
SOCIAL. AND LEARN MODEL AND
SINCE PANDEMIC BEGAN- THE BIG
WAYS RIGHT NOW THAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO RESPOND TO CHO SAID.
THE OTHER THING THAT I WANT TO
MENTION WITH REGARD TO
COMMITTED RESPONSE IS THAT- IN
THE MINISTRY SAID- A
CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE IN
RELEASED- I'M ASK THAT WAS
AFTER THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY
FEDERALLY- ALL APS PROGRAMS
NATIONWIDE- WERE OFFERED AN
OPPORTUNITY TO APPLY FOR A
GRANT TO ENHANCE. APS RESPONDED
SO THAT NINETEEN- AND THIS IS A
FORMULA GRANTS TO ALL STATES
AUTOMATICALLY GET IT- WERE IN
THE PROCESS OF COMPLETING- ALL
AND THAT PEOPLE WORKS RECEIVED.
WHAT WILL AMOUNT TO AROUND NINE
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR
CALIFORNIA FOR APS PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY TO RESPOND TO
COVERAGE RELATED NEEDS- WE
SHOULD RECEIVE THAT MONEY- BY
EARLY APRIL. WERE CURRENTLY
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- AND HE W. D. A. TO.
PUT TOGETHER A FORMULA TO
DISSEMINATE THIS MONEY TO ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES. AND AT
THAT POINT WE WILL ALSO BE
PROVIDING THEM WITH GUIDANCE ON
HOW TO SPEND THE MONEY- THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
VERY CLEAR WITH US THAT IS. THE
FUNDS ARE USED. TO SUPPLEMENT-
APS WORKS SPECIFICALLY RELATED
TO CO THEY DO NOT JUSTIFY WHAT
IS ALREADY HAPPENING. SO WE ARE
GOING TO BE CREATING SOME
PARAMETERS THAT COUNTIES MUST
WORK AROUND WITH THE MONEY THAT
THEY RECEIVE- AND THEY WILL
HAVE ROUGHLY EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO
USE THAT MONEY- WE'RE LOOKING
FOR HONORABLY. AND DIRECT
SERVICES- EXPANSION AS HOUSING
PRO- MAKING SURE THAT CLIENTS
HAVE FOOD RESTORE. BEYOND MAY
BE A- REAL TIME FOR A SHORT
THROUGH GREAT- TRIPS.
ESPECIALLY MEDIC APPOINT ARE
BACK OF WHAT- ATS FINANCE- IN
PERTH- HOME THE FOR THE PUBLIC
NURSE. BECAUSE WE FOUND THAT
MANY EIGHT PLAN FROM NOW GONE
TO DOCTOR HAD ANY KIND OF I
WOULD IN OUR- WITH WITH. ARE
THE PAST YEARS- OPENING DRAFT-
WILL ALSO TO OUR THE CAN. AND
OPPORTUNITY DO AT. THE OTHER.
FOR ANY IN HERE THAT IS BEEN
YOUR IMPACT BY THAT DIFFICULTY
RIGHT NOW IT YOU ARE. IF
MANAGED LAUGHTER NINETY DAYS.
SO COUNTY WILL BE ABLE TO USE
AND I THAT TO. THAT AS WELL- SO
WE THAT. THOSE ARE- THE AT THE
FOR HOW OBJECT SERVICES FUNDS.
TO CO THE- AND OF THE ANY CLUB.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I THINK
NOW WILL GO THE PANEL. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AS BY PAN KATHY
WITH THE COUNTY WALKER THAT SHE
SENT NAY TO SEE IT TODAY. THANK
YOU FOR THE M. TO BE ON THE
TODAY WELL WE HAVE THREE
QUESTIONS AT ALL AFTER. FIRST
AND THINK ABOUT THE THAT COUNT
THE FACE THE NEXT IN PROVIDING.
TO OLDER AND DURING THE
CAMPAIGN AND- ISSUES. AS MANY
OR- THAT SERVE OLDER IN
VULNERABLE. CAN AND HAS.
VISITING THE END OF WE SERVE
ARE PRO SHOULD. ABUSE AND THE
CONDUCT I JUST THAT INTO AND
RIO SOUTH. FOR PRO ELIGIBILITY
HAS DEFINITELY BEEN A CHALLENGE
DURING THE PANDEMIC. AS THESE
ARE OFTEN THE MOST AT RISK FOR
COBIT EXPOSURE AND SERIOUS
ILLNESS. EARLY IN THE PANDA I'M
PRETTY WHERE WE RECEIVE REPORTS
FROM COUNTY IS THAT BOTH THE
APS. THAT'S CLIENTS WORD DOES
NOT COMFORTABLE ALLOWING
SOMEONE TO COME INTO THEIR
HOME. AND FOR THESE REASONS WE
APPRECIATE THE FLEXIBILITY THAT
THE VFF ACCRUE. SUCH AS
ALLOWING THE VIRTUAL IN HOME
ASSESSMENT THAT YOU HEARD
ABOUT- AND REASSESSMENTS- AS
WELL AS- I INITIAL
INVESTIGATIONS FOR THE LEFT THE
AREA- THE ALLEGATIONS AND APS.
IN ALLOWING COUNTIES. TO
PROCESS THE FORMS
ELECTRONICALLY. COUNTIES ALSO
HAVE FACED A ISSUE WITH OUR
STAY AT HOME ORDERS- WORK FROM
HOME AND ACCOMMODATING STAFF OR
AT RISK OR EXPOSURE DOES TO A
CHILD CARE OR OTHER CARE GIVING
DUTIES. THE ACCESS OF OUR STAFF
TO PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT WAS
ALSO INITIAL EARLIER ON THE
THAT IS LESS OF AN ISSUE NOW IT
WAS A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT ISSUE
EARLY AND THAT PANDEMIC- AND
WIDE AT BOTH LOCALLY AND- OUT
KIND OF. TALKING STATEWIDE WITH
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES AT A LOCAL- YES
OFFICERS WERE ARE COUNTY HUMAN
SERVICES STAFF WERE WIND OUT OF
YOU KNOW A NUMBER OF. GROUPS
AND COUNTY ORGANIZATIONS THAT
NEEDED THOSE EQUIPMENT AS FIRST
RESPONDERS. IN IN THE WAY THAT
FUNDS TO HELP SERVE OLDER
ADULTS. AS YOU KNOW COUNTIES
DID RECEIVE SOME OF THE FEDERAL
FUNDING THROUGH THE STATE TO DO
WELL IN THE ABSTRACT ON OLDER
ADULTS AND BOTH APS AND I JUST
BASS. SO WE WERE ABLE TO- GET
OUT EITHER- LITERALLY OR
VIRTUALLY TO BE ABLE TO CHECK
IN WITH OUR CLIENTS AND SEE HOW
THEY WERE DOING AND CONNECT
THEM AND ARRANGE SERVICES AS
THEY MAY BE NEEDED THOSE BUT
DIDN'T HAVE ANYONE ELSE LOOKING
AROUND THAT. MUCH OF THE-
FUNDING THAT WE RECEIVE DID
COME IN THE FORM OF FEDERAL
MATCH ON PROGRAMS SUCH AS
PROJECT ROOM HE- WHICH HELPS
LOCAL ENTITIES PROVIDE NON
CONGREGATE SHELTER. FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN
ORDER TO REDUCE THE SPREAD OF
IT. AS ALWAYS A GREAT PLACE
PROGRAM WHICH PARTNERED WITH
LOCAL RESTAURANTS. TO DELIVER
FOOD TO SENIORS WHICH OF MANY
OF OUR COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCIES ADMINISTER IN SOME
CAPACITY. WITH BOTH ROOM HE AND
GREAT PLAINS COUNTY FROM GREAT
SUCCESS AND WORKING WITH OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS. AND LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ALONE ALMOST
NINE THOUSAND MEALS WERE
DELIVERED THROUGH GREAT FAITH
AS JUST ONE EXAMPLE. AND THEN-
ADDRESSING THE FINAL QUESTION
ON THE AGENDA THINKING ABOUT
THE LONG TERM ISSUES THAT WE
MIGHT EXPECT TO FACE. AS A
RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC- WE
THINK THAT- THE SEVERAL THINGS
HAVE BEEN HITTING OUR CLIENT
POPULATION HARD ACROSS OUR
PROGRAMS OF COURSE BUT-
FOCUSING JUST FOR A MINUTE ON
OUR OLDER ADULTS. PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES ALL AND THE ELDER-
WHO ARE ARE RECEIVING SERVICES
TO OUR PROGRAM OR WHO MAY HAVE
BEEN ON THE EDGE OF NEEDING
THOSE SERVICES AT ONE TIME
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC. BUT
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC IN THE
AFFECT ON THE HOUSING CRISIS
THE WORSENING ECONOMIC
SITUATION MAY NOW NEED THOSE
SERVICES WERE AS THEY WERE.
STRUGGLING BUT MAKING IT IT
ABLE TO GET BY AND NOW IN NEED
OF OUR SERVICES. WE THINK THAT
THE IN PARTICULAR THE
POPULATIONS OF OLDER ADULTS
THAT WE SERVE WHAT THAT WE KNOW
HAVE BEEN GROWING OVER TIME AS
WELL AND WILL CONTINUE TO GROW
HAVE BEEN PARTICULARLY HAD
HEART. WE THINK THAT A NUMBER
OF A LARGER NUMBER OF THOSE WE
SERVE ARE GOING TO STRUGGLE
WITH HOUSING ISSUES AS WELL AS
AN INCREASED NEED FOR MORE
SERVICES AND CONNECTIONS TO BE
MADE RELATED TO FOOD SECURITY
HEALTH AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ESPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH AS WE
SPEAK- SO MUCH ATTENTION PAID
ON. THE TOLL THAT BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH OF THE TOLL THAT ARE FOR
INTERVENING AND- HOME SCHOOLING
HAVE TAKEN ON CHILDREN NOT
BEING ABLE TO SEE PEOPLE
FIFTEEN I THINK CAN BE TRUE FOR
ELDERS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES AND VULNERABLE
ADULTS YOU MAY HAVE HAD
PROGRAMS OR- YOU KNOW AS I
WEEKLY- VISIT WITH FRIENDS. WHO
NOW CAN NO LONGER DO THAT AND
SO THINKING ABOUT THEM AT THAT
END OF THE AGE SPECTRUM AND HOW
WE CAN PROVIDE SERVICES AND
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE NOT LEFT
OUT IT'S GOING TO BE REALLY
CRITICAL AS WE MOVE FORWARD
PASSED THE PANDEMIC. WE HAVE A
COUPLE FROM. THAT ARE ADDRESSED
LATER IN THE AGENDA THAT I JUST
WANNA TALK ABOUT BRIEFLY NOW
BECAUSE THEY DO FIT INTO THIS
CATEGORY OF ONGOING NEEDS.
FIRST OF ALL ARE EXPOSED- WE
HAVE A PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
SERVICES PROVIDED THROUGH ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES. INCLUDING
THE HOME SAFE PROGRAM WHICH IS
A HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM THAT
IS TARGETED DIRECTLY AT OUR
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES
POPULATION. LEAVES ARE INTO THE
GROWING POPULATION OF OLDER
ADULTS ARE AT RISK OF ABUSE AND
NEGLECT. AND IT WOULD PROVIDE
FOR EARLIER INTERVENTION BY
LOWERING THE AGE TO SIXTY. THAT
THESE- OLDER ADULTS CAN BE
ELIGIBLE FOR A PS THAT WILL
BRING IT ACTUALLY IN LINE WITH
OUR OLDER AMERICANS ACT
PROGRAM. AND ALSO PROVIDING
MORE FUNDING FOR CASE
MANAGEMENT AS YOU HEARD MISS
RUTLEDGE DAY TYPICALLY OUR
CASES ARE NOT QUITE OPEN AND
SHUT BUT THEY ARE NOT A LONG
TERM. CASE MANAGEMENT THIS WAS
NOT SOMETHING THE PROGRAM HAD
EVER BEEN FUNDED FOR. SO THE
FUNDING THAT WE'RE PROPOSING
WOULD HELP TO GO TOWARD THAT
FOR THOSE NEEDIEST CASES THE
ONES WITH THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
NEED. A LAST A MORE HANDS ON
CASE MANAGEMENT RATHER THAN
JUST MAKING REFERRALS TO
SERVICES. AND THEN RELATIVELY
QUICKLY CLOSING THE CASE FOR
THAT BOB THAT. IN ADDITION THE
HOME SAFE PROGRAM WHICH IS
AIMED AT PREVENTING
HOMELESSNESS AMONG OUR APS.
POPULATION WILL EXPIRE THIS
JUNE. IF WE DON'T TAKE ACTION
AND WE'VE HAD SUCCESS AT
ENSURING THAT OUR ELDERS AND
DEPENDENT ADULTS DO NOT BECOME
HOMELESS WITH THE PROGRAM. WHAT
WE LEARNED- OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS IS THAT OUR AGING
POPULATION IN PARTICULAR IS THE
FASTEST GROWING SEGMENT OF THE
HOMELESS POPULATION. AND THE
VAST VAST MAJORITY OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS HAD NEVER BEEN
HOMELESS BEFORE SO THEY'RE
ECONOMIC ISSUES THAT ARE
CAUSING THEM TO BE HOMELESSNESS
SO AT HOME STATE. DOES THAT
COME TO OUR ATTENTION FOR APS
WE'VE BEEN ABLE. TO HELP HER-
REMAIN HOUSE. SO WE'D LIKE TO
BILL OFF THE- SIX IN BOTH MAKE
IT PERMANENT AND EXPAND IT TO
ADDITIONAL. AND THEN- FINALLY
HAD TO WE HAVE A PROPOSED ALSO
NOTED ON LATER ON IN THE- FOR
FUNDING. BUT WOULD YOU CAN. TO
ALLOW AND BILL ON THE ELECTRON
FORMS THE MISSION THAT- M. AS
TOM. MENTIONED EARLIER THAT WE
HAVE APPRECIATED DURING A
PANDEMIC. THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
FORMS THAT BOTH ARE RECIPIENTS
AS LAWS ARE PROVIDERS OF HIGH
JUST THAT. NEED TO FILL OUT
EITHER INITIALLY OR AT TIMES ON
AN ONGOING BASIS. AND WE WERE
QUESTIONED FUNDING ALONG WITH
THAT- CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES. TO BE ABLE
TO AUTOMATE THOSE FORMS TO THE
GREATEST EXTENT POSSIBLE AND
ALLOW BOTH RECIPIENTS AND
PROVIDERS JUST SUBMIT THOSE
FORMS ELECTRONICALLY. WE THINK
THAT'S REALLY WILL TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF TECHNOLOGY AND
EFFICIENCIES BUT ALSO AVOID
UNNECESSARY FACE TO FACE
INTERACTION. WHICH IS GOING TO
CONTINUE WAITING TO BE A
CONCERN FOR SOME TIME EVEN AS
WE YEAH I'M INCREASE
VACCINATION. WE SAW QUITE KNOW
WHAT IS AROUND THE CORNER IT'S
GONNA TAKE AWHILE TO GET BACK
TO WHATEVER A NEW NORMAL LIVES
AND SO TRYING TO BUILD OFF THE
SUCCESS THAT WE'VE HAD WITH THE
SHORTER TERM FLEXIBILITIES AND
CONTINUAL. ADULT ON THIS ONE
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT. WHAT'S
THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. AS THE PANELS
COMPLETED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY. THE IF WE CAN TO- MISTER
CLAY CAN. THANK YOU I THINK
YOU'RE MUSICALLY AREA I AM
EXCUSE ME FOR THAT. HAPPENS SO
THANKS FOR HAVING ME HERE
GREATLY APPRECIATE IT- IN TERMS
OF THE THREE QUESTIONS I HAVE
THE FIRST ONE WAS COVERED QUITE
WELL BY KIM A QUITE WAY I'M
DIRECTOR WAY I DID A GREAT JOB
DESCRIBING HOW TRIPLE A STEP IF
IT'D IN PROVIDING SERVICES. ARE
FAIRLY INTUITIVE THAT YOU KNOW
SERVICES BECOME REMOTE RATHER
THAN FACE TO FACE AND I
SOMETIMES IT'S MORE EFFICIENT
AND OTHER TIMES IT CREATES
UNEXPECTED CHALLENGES
ESPECIALLY AROUND ISSUES
AROUND. SOCIAL ENGAGEMENT OR-
LEGAL SERVICES OR- JUST OTHER
WAYS WHERE THAT FACE TO FACE
CONNECTION IS REALLY IMPORTANT
I'M ONE THING THAT WE'VE SEEN
IS THE SHIFT TO ALL MEALS BEING
HOME DELIVERED I CREATED SOME
UNEXPECTED CHALLENGES BESIDES
THE OBVIOUS ONES I'M ONE OF
THEM WAS HOW DO YOU SERVE
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE
GOING TO CONGREGATE SITES TO
RECEIVE THEIR MEALS. THEY HAVE
NO HOME TO DELIVER THE MEALS TO
SO- WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT SOME
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS- CONTACTING
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WAS PART OF
THE TRICKY PART BUT YOU KNOW
JUST FIGURING OUT A CENTRAL
MEETING PLACE TO DROP OFF THE
MEALS FOR THEM AND THEN ALSO
CHANGING THE CONTENT OF THE
MEALS TO BE SHELF STABLE. SO WE
DID NOT HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
TEMPERATURE CONTROLLED
REFRIGERATION- SO YOU KNOW
THAT'S KIND OF AN EXAMPLE OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT THAT WE
WERE LOOKING AT THE BIG
SURPRISES I THINK WERE THE
INCREASE IN DEMAND. OUR WE KNEW
THERE WAS A LOT THERE BUT
PROBABLY EVEN GREATER THAN
ANTICIPATED AND I THINK THE
OTHER PIECE IS THAT VULNERABLE
SENIORS PREVIOUSLY VULNERABLE
SENIORS BECAME MORE VULNERABLE
THAN EVER SO THEY WERE KIND OF
HIT EXPONENTIALLY HARD- THAT'S
TRADITIONALLY THE HARDER TO
REACH HER MORE ISOLATED
INDIVIDUALS TO BEGIN WITH SO
HOW DO WE STAY CONNECTED IN
PROVIDE. SERVICES. ON SOME OF
THE- IT ALSO IS. THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OR LACK OF BATS.
AND UNTIL THIS COMMITTEE
STARTED TAKING THE LEAD AND
ADDRESSING THE GAP IN SERVICES.
SENIOR PROGRAMS WERE MOSTLY
IGNORED ON BOTH THE FEDERAL AND
STATE LEVEL SINCE SWEAT
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE NINETEEN
NINETY. SO WE HAD TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY FIVE YEARS TO CATCH UP
ON WHERE PROGRAMS WERE
UNFORTUNATELY FOCUSING AS THEY
SHOULD HAVE ON THE DELIVERY OF
SERVICE AND MAINTENANCE OF IT.
BUT NOT DOING REGULAR REPAIRS
OR EXPANSION TO. INFRASTRUCTURE
TO COLD STORAGE TO KITCHEN
CAPABILITIES ARE VEHICLES WERE
CONSTANTLY ARE EXCEEDING THEIR
USEFUL. LIFESPAN ARE EXPECTED
LIFESPAN SO WE HAD NOT ONLY
THIS HUGE INCREASE IN DEMAND
BUT ALSO A CRUMBLING SYSTEM BY
WHICH TO PROVIDE IT. SO I THINK
THAT IS- SOMETHING TO KEEP IN
MIND HOPEFULLY MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING. AND ARE SOME OF THE
BUDGET PROPOSALS THAT ARE BEING
CONSIDERED TODAY ARE PART OF
THE APPROACH OF RECOGNIZING
THAT THIS POPULATION HAS GROWN.
WAY FASTER THAN. WHO. GROUP.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE GROWING
OLDER. I'M SO YOU KNOW WHAT WE
DO TO PREVENT THAT AND MOVE IT
FORWARD ESTACION SEES LIKE
REMOTE SERVICE THEM SIGNIFICANT
ASKING YOU I DON'T REMEMBER
WHAT YOU SAID A COUPLE MINUTES
AGO BUT WE LOST YOU FOR MAYBE A
MINUTE OR TWO. I'M SORRY SIR
SO. I'M I WAS REALLY TRYING TO
FOCUS ON INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
HOW FLAT FUNDING FOR SEVERAL
DECADES. HAS LEFT US WITH
CRUMBLING SERVICES SO WHEN AN
INCREASED DEMAND COMES IF YOU
DON'T HAVE UPDATED KITCHENS OR
IF YOU HAVE OLD VEHICLES. THAT
CREATES A CRISIS AND SERVICE
DELIVERY AND I'M ASSUMING I'M
COMING THROUGH OKAY NOW YES YOU
ARE. RIGHT SO YOU KNOW THE
CHALLENGE OF HOW WE RESPOND TO
THIS WAS KIND OF. DOUBLED BY
THIS NEW CHALLENGER G. WE HAVE
TO SAY WE HAVE TO STORE TWICE
AS MANY MEALS AS WE USED TO
TWICE AS MUCH FRUIT THERE ISN'T
CAPACITY DID YOU TO DOTHAT
WERE HAVING TO RENT
REFRIGERATORS RENT FREEZERS ON
A SHORT TERM BASIS IT JUST
MEANS THAT. AND THEN SHORTAGE
OF JUST FOOD AVAILABILITY OR
OTHER SUPPLIES HAS BEEN PART OF
IT TOO. SO SOME OF THE YOU KNOW
GREAT THINGS IS LEARNING HOW TO
DO SERVICES IN A DIFFERENT
MANNER AND MORE REMOTELY BUT
WITH THAT COMES ITS OWN SET OF
CHALLENGE- AGAIN THE ALREADY
ISOLATED FOLKS ARE GOING TO BE
HIT HARDER. BECAUSE A LOT OF
THEM DON'T HAVE COMPUTERS OR
TABLETS TO CONNECT WITH. AND
EVEN ADVANCE PROVIDED THERE'S
TWO OTHER PROBLEMS THAT FALL
INTO THAT ONE IS AFFORDING YOUR
MONTHLY INTERNET CONNECTION. TO
IS IF YOU LIVE IN A WERE. IN A
REMOTE AREA YOU MIGHT NOT HAVE%
ACCESS TO STABLE INTERNET. I'M
PERSONALLY I HAD TO GET A
SATELLITE DISH CAPS STABLE
INTERNET IN MY HOUSE LUCKILY I
CAN AFFORD THAT. NOT EVERYBODY
CAN. AND THEN THE THIRD PIECE
OF THAT CONNECTIVITY IS JUST
LACK OF KNOWLEDGE ON HOW TO USE
THE TECHNOLOGY. SO REALLY
BRIDGING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE HAS
THREE PIECES IT'S NOT JUST.
HAVING THE DEVICE BUT IT'S ALSO
HAVING THE INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY AVAILABLE AND
HAVING IT AFFORDABLE. AND MAN
PROBABLY MORE THAN THE OTHER
TWO. AS KNOWING HOW TO USE IT.
THE OTHER SURPRISE WE HAD AND
IT SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN BUT IT
WAS. AND THAT WAS THE IMPACT ON
OUR WORK FORCE ESPECIALLY THE
VOLUNTEER WORK FORCE SO MANY
OLDER ADULT PROGRAMS ARE DRIVEN
BY A CADRE OF VOLUNTEERS
INCLUDING VOLUNTEERS PERFORMING
AT THE PROFESSIONAL LEVEL WE
HAVE VOLUNTEERS DOING TAX
ASSISTANCE WE HAVE VOLUNTEERS
IN SINGLE SENIOR LEGAL PROGRAMS
WE HAVE A VOLUNTEERS. ARE DOING
NURSING HOME PROTECTION
VOLUNTEERS EXPLAINING HOW
MEDICARE WORKS SO THOSE ARE
JUST CASUAL PEOPLE THAT CAN
LEARN HOW TO DO THEIR JOB AND
YOU KNOW HALF AN HOUR OF
TRAINING IT'S EXTENSIVE ONGOING
TRAINING AND THAT. IS A GREAT
WAY FOR OLDER ADULTS THE STAND
GATES WITH THE COMMUNITY BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WHEN THE OLDER
ADULTS ARE ALSO BEING TOLD
ISOLATE WE NOW HAVE THIS
VOLUNTEER CORE COMPONENT OF
PROVIDING SERVICES. OUT OF THE
PICTURE. INCREASED DEMAND LOSS
OF WORK FORCE INCLUDING
VOLUNTEER WORK FORCE SO THAT'S
BEEN A HUGE CHALLENGE- IT'S
ALSO A PLACE WHERE I THINK WE
SHOULD PUT ADDITIONAL EMPHASIS
IN THE COMING YEAR OR YEARS IS
TRYING TO LEVERAGE THOSE
VOLUNTEERS IN A MORE EFFECTIVE
WAY AND MANNER. AND LOOKING AT
THAT AS A COMPONENT FOR HOW ALL
OF OUR SERVICES ARE STRUCTURED
AND FORWARD. I'M TO KIND OF
WRAP IT UP I THINK. THE PARTING
COMMENT TO MAKE IS HAVING THE
FLEXIBILITY WE CURRENTLY. FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING AND
ADMINISTRATION ON AGING
FEDERALLY OR ALLOWING THEM TO
PROVIDE ENHANCED- BUT ALSO WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT THE INCREDIBLE
QUANTITY OF NEED THAT WE HAVE
AND THEN IS THE SECOND PART OF
THAT THE COMPLEXITY OF THAT
MEET- SERVICES ARE MUCH MORE
COMPLICATED THAN EVER IN TERMS
OF THE CHALLENGES WE'RE FACING.
IN OUR ROLE- IS FAR BEYOND YOU
KNOW JUST DETERMINING IF
SOMEBODY'S ELIGIBLE ONES
ACTUALLY FIGURING OUT HOW TO
BEST PROVIDE SERVICES TO MEET
NEEDS RATHER INTENDED TO MEET
QUALIFICATIONS. I'M HOPEFUL
THAT MASTER PLAN FOR AGING WILL
SERVE AS A BRIDGE BETWEEN WHERE
THE SHORTAGES ARE AND WHAT WE
WANT TO GO IN THE DECADE SO
HAPPY TO SEE. THAT COMING OUT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND- I
WANT TO MENTION AGAIN THAT THAT
THIS IS SUBCOMMITTEE HAS BEEN
TACKLING THIS ISSUE FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS NOW AND THAT IS
ALSO EXTREMELY ENCOURAGING TO
SEE THAT THERE'S LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP IN TRYING TO GET
THESE CRITICAL NEED SMITH.
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS. ARE IF
ANY HOUSE. YOU I THINK WE'LL
MOVE O TO KELLY DETERMINANT
AND WE WILL ACKNOWLEDGE AND
THANK DR PAMPERS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS COMMITTEE AND REALLY
TAKING THIS ISSUE TO HEART AND
I CERTAINLY HOPE TO BE ABLE TO
FOLLOW IN HIS FOOTSTEPS. HI MY
NAME IS KELLY CHAIRMAN- GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR GIVING ME THIS OPPORTUNITY.
I AM I AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES WHICH IS THE
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES. PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES PROVIDE REGISTRY
SERVICES TO ASSIST CONSUMERS TO
FIND PROVIDERS PROVIDE TRAINING
AND ARE THE EMPLOYER OF RECORD
OF I. HSS PROVIDERS FOR
PURPOSES OF COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING. LAST MARCH WITHIN
DAYS OF THE GOVERNOR SHELTER IN
PLACE ORDER KAPPA PARTNERED
WITH THE CONSUMER DISABILITY
GROUPS UNIONS AND CW DA
TRIDENTINE FIVE THE KEY CHANGES
NEEDED TO KEEP PILOTS HAS US
RUNNING. CDSS HAS BEEN VERY
HELPFUL AND AUTHORIZING PROGRAM
FLEXIBILITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
ESSENTIAL DURING THE PANDEMIC.
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES ADMINISTERED
THREE MAJOR HOPE IT CHANGES I
HSS. ONE CDSS AUTHORIZED
ENROLLMENT OF NEW PROVIDERS TO
BE HANDLED REMOTELY PREVENTING
A CRISIS AND ENSURING PROVIDERS
GET PAID. PROVIDER MOMENT AN
ORIENTATION IS STILL BY AND
LARGE BEING HANDLED REMOTELY.
AND AS YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD
SINCE APRIL TWENTY TWENTY CDSS
HAS PROVIDED MUCH NEEDED PP TO
EVERY PUBLIC AUTHORITY FOR
DISTRIBUTION TO HSS PROVIDERS
AND CONSUMERS. ALSO CDSS ISSUED
THE MANDATE FOR COVERT
EMERGENCY BACKUP SERVICES ON
MARCH THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY.
COUNTIES DELEGATED THIS
RESPONSIBILITY TO PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES BECAUSE IT MADE
SENSE TO TIE EMERGENCY BACK UP
WITH A REGISTRY SYSTEMS.
THROUGH HARD WORK AND GRIT
EVERY PUBLIC AUTHORITY HAD AN
EMERGENCY BACKUP SYSTEM IN
PLACE WITHIN TWO WEEKS WHEREAS
BEFORE CO BID MOST PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES HAVE NOT. SAN
FRANCISCO LA IN RIVERSIDE HAVE
EMERGENCY BACKUP SYSTEMS BEFORE
COUGHING. ALL WITH WAGE
DIFFERENTIALS FOR THE HSS
PROVIDERS. IN SAN FRANCISCO WE
HAD AN ADVANTAGEOUS POSITION
WHEN FACED WITH THE PANDEMIC BY
HAVING HAD AN EMERGENCY BACKUP
PROGRAM IN PLACE THAT'S BEEN
RUNNING FOR THE LAST TWENTY
PLUS YEARS. THIS PROGRAM IS
UNIQUELY STRUCTURED COMPARED TO
A REGISTRY BACKUP PROGRAM AS
THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
AUTHORITY COOLEY MANAGES THE
PROGRAM FROM RECRUITMENT HIRING
TRAINING COORDINATED SERVICE.
FOLLOWING CARE PLANS AND
TRIAGING ADDITIONAL SERVICE ME.
AND SAN FRANCISCO THE PROGRAM
IS USED A LOT HOWEVER THE
UTILIZATION OF EMERGENCY BACK
UP ACROSS THE STATE IS LOWER
THAN EXPECTED. ANECDOTAL
INFORMATION SUGGESTS THAT MANY
CONSUMERS DO NOT WANT A
STRANGER PROVIDING CARE AND
THAT FAMILY OR FRIENDS HAVE
FILLED IN. FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
NEEDED AND USE OUR EMERGENCY
BACKUP SYSTEMS IT HAS BEEN
ESSENTIAL AND SOMETIMES LIKE
SICK. OUR MERCHANTS THE BACKUP
SERVICES HAVE PREVENTED
UNWANTED EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS
AND HOSPITALIZATIONS FOR SOME
OF OUR CONSUMERS. IN TERMS OF
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS POST COBIT
WE AGREE WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
MASTER PLAN ON AGING WHICH
RECOMMENDS INCREASING STABILITY
R. I. HSS RECIPIENTS. THROUGH A
BACKUP PROVIDER SYSTEM AND WE
ARE DEVELOPING A PROPOSAL TO
ADDRESS THIS GOAL IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION CONSUMER GROUPS
UNIONS AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS.
WE BELIEVE THAT EVERY COUNTY
SHOULD HAVE AN EMERGENCY BACKUP
SYSTEM THAT IS ADMINISTERED BY
THE PUBLIC AUTHORITY TO AUGMENT
OUR RECORDS REGISTRY SERVICES.
COURSE RECRUITMENT WILL BE A
REALLY BIG FOCUS THERE HAS TO
BE A WAGE DIFFERENTIAL AND
PERHAPS A MILEAGE REIMBURSEMENT.
IT MAKES SENSE TO DEVELOP A
CONTINUAL APPROACH ADMINISTERED
BY PUBLIC AUTHORITIES IN
COORDINATION WITH COUNTIES
WHERE CONTRACT AGENCIES COULD
PROVIDE SERVICES IN SOME
SITUATIONS. IT KEEPS CONSUMERS
AT THE CENTER AND GIVES THEM A
CONTINUUM OF CHOICE AND OPTIONS
THAT BEST MEET THEIR NEEDS. I
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE INFORMATION ON WAYS
THAT PUBLIC AUTHORITIES
RESPONDED TO MAINTAIN IT HAS A
SERVICES IN THE WAKE OF COBIT
AND- LIKE EVERYONE ELSE I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
PROGRAM FINANCE ANYTHING.
FILAYO ANYTHING ON THIS. OKAY
JACQUELINE. CHAPLAIN BRAZIL AT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND JUST A FEW THINGS
THAT WE WENT TO ELEVATE THAT
WAS DISCUSSED- WITH THE PANEL
AND HIGHLIGHTED IN YOUR AGENDA
QUESTIONS IS THAT WE DO AGREE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT
TO REQUEST ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE MERITS OF
KEEPING- PROGRAM BOOKS
ABILITIES ARE CHANGES LIKE THE
I JUST AS BACKUP PROVIDER
SYSTEM- OR REMOTE TO SEE BASS
AND K. COMMUNITY BASED ADULT
SERVICES- AB THAT WERE PUT IN
PLACE DURING COALBED THE MERITS
OF CONTINUING THOSE AFTER KOPET
AND WHAT WOULD THAT MEAN FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES- ALSO
AS DISCUSSED BY PANELISTS-
WHILE THAT. THERE HAVE BEEN
INCREASED SERVICE LEVELS DURING
KOBE IT FOR MANY PROGRAMS AND
THE ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ASSISTANCE HAS- AS
FANS HOPE TO DRESS THOSE
INCREASED FUNDING LEVELS OR
INCREASED AS SERVICE NEEDS
HOWEVER IT'S UNCLEAR TO US WHAT
SHARE OF THE INCREASE SERVICE
NEEDS- ARE TRULY TEMPORARY-
VERSUS WHAT SHARE WILL ACTUALLY
CONTINUE PAST COPING NINETEEN
I'M SO TO BETTER ASSIST THE
LEGISLATURE IN DETERMINING WHAT
THOSE ONGOING FUTURE SERVICE
LEVELS MAY LOOK LIKE AND THE
LONG TERM EFFECTS COLD IT MAY
HAVE ON THE STATE PROGRAMS-
PERHAPS REQUESTING ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ON- HOW. IS
SERVICE LEVELS- WILL EITHER
RANKED DOWN POST COLD VENT AND
SO WE HAVE A BETTER SENSE OF
WHAT THE NORMAL NEW STATE WILL
BE LIKE- AND TAKE THAT INTO
ACCOUNT AND COMPARED TO WHAT
FUTURE FUNDING LEVELS WOULD
LOOK LIKE ONCE THE TEMPORARY
FUNDING FROM. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT RAMPS DOWN. GRADIENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I THINK I
WOULD I WOULD IF WE COULD
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE THOSE
QUESTIONS WHAT DO WE THINK IT
SOUNDS LIKE ACROSS LIKE
EVERYONE I HEARD FROM SAID THAT
THEY WANT THE ELECTRONIC
SIGNING UP. I'M SO MANY MORE
VIRTUAL VISIT WHAT ELSE DO YOU
THINK WILL WANT TO KEEP AND
MAINTAIN- AFTER THE PANDEMIC IS
HOPEFULLY BEHIND US. I GUESS
IT'S BACK TO THE- BEIJING OUR
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES.
SURE I THINK THAT'S EXACTLY
RIGHT- CHAIR THIS IS CHEMICALLY
WAY TO THE DIRECTOR OF AGING IS
THAT I DO THINK THERE IS I
THINK ACTUALLY GOES BOTH WAYS
BUT THERE'S A RECOGNITION- OF
THE VALUE OF HYBRID SERVICES SO
FOR EXAMPLE- IN ADULT DAY CARE
WHERE A PERSON MAY BE RECEIVING
TWO OR THREE DAYS OF IN CENTER
FULL DAY SERVICE COULD THOSE
OTHER TWO DAYS TO GET A VIRTUAL
CHECK OR SOME OTHER CHECK AND
OF COURSE IT COMES DOWN TO
CANNOT BE A PAID SERVICE UNIT
HOW YOU APPROPRIATELY TO.
ENSURE QUALITY AND-
EFFECTIVENESS BUT THAT WOULD
ALLOW US TO EXPAND BOTH THE
AMOUNT OF SUPPORT TO AN
INDIVIDUAL AS LIKELY COUNTS
MENTION IT ALSO ALLOWS PERHAPS
TO SERVE MORE PEOPLE IN THE
SAME PHYSICAL CONSTRAINT RIGHT
IF YOU'RE ON A GIVEN DAY YOU'RE
BUILDING CAP MAYBE A HUNDRED
PEOPLE THAT MAYBE YOU'RE
CALLING FIFTY MORE SO COULD BE
A WAY TO- GROW SERVICES TO MORE
PEOPLE AS WELL I THINK THAT'S-
REALLY IMPORTANT I THINK
ANOTHER THING THAT WE REALIZED-
IS REALLY BEING CLEAR ABOUT THE
DISSERVICE MIX SO FOR EXAMPLE
IN THE MEAL DELIVERY- PROGRAMS
THE HOME DELIVERY. BUT IT'S
MORE THAN A MALE BUT THERE'S A
MEAL COMPONENT AND THERE'S ALSO
A SOCIAL ISOLATION COMPONENT IN
AND TALKING TO THE PERSON
HAVING AN EYE TO EYE CONTACT
CHECKING THE MAIL THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS ONLY HAPPEN WHEN YOU
HAVE THAT THAT PERSONAL CONTACT
OR HAPPENED DEEPER SHOULD SAY
AND SO HOW DO WE VALUE ON BOTH
THE MEAL AND THE ISOLATION
CHECK THAT HAPPENS IN THAT
PERSON CONTACT WE GIVE IT ITS
FULL WORK. SO THOSE ARE TWO OF
THE EXAMPLES FOR US AND I THINK
YOU KNOW PAYING FOR THE
TECHNOLOGY FOR VIRTUAL TO BE
POSSIBLE IF YOU WERE DOING A
VIRTUAL CHECK IN WITH THE
CONSUMER THEN THEY NEED THE
DEVICE BROADBAND AND THE
SUPPORT TO MAKE THAT CONNECTIVE
ITTY POSSIBLE I KNOW ALL OF US
CAN RELATE TO THAT. SO I THINK
THAT'S A BIG PART OF IT TOO IS
THE PERMISSION STRUCTURE IN THE
PAYMENT FOR THE SERVICE BUT
THEN THE ACTUAL INFRASTRUCTURE
TO DELIVER QUALITY VIRTUAL
SERVICES IMPORTANT. TO BE
ALLOWABLE PAIN AS WELL. THE YOU
VERY MUCH. THE YOU HAVE YOUR
HAND UP. MICHAEL YEAH THANK YOU
I LOVE TO BUILD THAT'LL- BIT
AND THANK YOU FOR- THIS. TO
FRESH THE INNER. HAS SOMETHING
THAT ARM AND- HAVE BEEN NOTICE
AS WELL. I WAS REMISS IN NOT
MENTIONING IT EARLY. SO I'M
REALLY GLAD DIRECTOR MCCOY WADE.
IT ESPECIALLY IN OUR RURAL
AREAS BUT ALSO IN A MORE
POPULATED AREAS. THE INTERNET
SERVICE CAN BE SKETCHY. AND
BROADBAND- CAN BE EXTREMELY
EXPENSIVE IF YOU'RE IN A RURAL
AREA. AND NOT THAT RELIABLE.
AND SO WERE SUPPORTING EFFORTS
TO TRY TO POINT. ADDITIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. FINANCING IN
THE PLACE OR JUST GETTING DOWN
INTO THE INDIVIDUAL LEVEL AND
TO THEIR HOME. TO ENSURE THAT
THEY HAVE INTERNET ACCESS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. SOMETHING
OUR MEMBERS ARE DEFINITELY.
SEEING A RECORDING ON AND ARE
WORRIED ABOUT. AND HAVE SCHOOLS
AND OTHER PLACES HAVE WE DONE
HOT SPOT FOR PEOPLE OF THE
COMMUNITY. THIS IS CAN'T WAIT
AND I CAN SPEAK BRIEFLY TO THE
AUDIT DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY
STRATEGIC BROADBAND COUNCIL IS
VERY MUCH TRYING TO TAKE IN ALL
AGES LOOK AT THOSE COMMUNITY
HOT SPOTS SO THAT THOSE SPOTS
WOULD BE ABLE TO BENEFIT. BOTH
CHILDREN IN SCHOOLS AND THE
MAYBE THE COMMUNITY CENTER WERE
OLDER ADULTS MIGHT BE
ATTENDING. WE ARE TRYING TO
LOOK AT A PLACE BASED OFFER
THOSE KINDS OF HOT SPOT
SOLUTIONS AND THAT IS PART OF.
THE NEW STRATEGIC PLAN THAT
THAT- BROADBAND COUNCIL
RELEASED IN DECEMBER. AND AGAIN
WE SEE THE IMPORTANCE OF
BROADBAND REALLY BEING SPREAD
ACROSS THE STATE TO THAT
EVERYBODY HAS THE ACCESS AND-
ALL THESE GREAT SERVICES THAT
WERE ABLE TO DO ONLINE ARE ABLE
TO ACTUALLY BE DONE. FOR SO
MANY. DO YOU HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT. ONE GREAT PLACE GOES
AWAY THE- INCREASE IN THE
DESERT AND YOU KNOW PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN USED TO GETTING. MEALS AT
HOME AND MAYBE WEREN'T A PART
OF- MEALS ON WHEELS OR OTHER
SERVICES. ALL OF A SUDDEN%
FLOCKING TO THE AGENCY AND HOW
DO YOU. ANTICIPATE BEING ABLE
TO. TAKE THAT IN. YES I SEE NOT
I SEE NODS. I THINK EVERYONE ON
THE PANEL IS NODDING I. STARTED
IN MY COLLEAGUES CAN'T CAN SCAN
CAN SPEAK TO IT YES WE DO- THAT
GREAT PLACE WAS A TRAFFIC MODEL
IN BRINGING MORE PEOPLE IN THE
L. AT HOME HAVING THAT LOCAL
ECONOMIC STIMULUS SUPPORTING
RESTAURANTS IN THE WORK FORCE-
AND SO. IT DID AS AS AS L. A.
L. INDICATED BOTH HELP US MEET
A TEMPORARY NEED OF MORE PEOPLE
OR THE SAME PEOPLE WITH MORE
MEALS- BUT I THINK IT'S ALSO
REACHED INTO SOME ONGOING NEED
OR SOME NEW NEED FROM THE
PANDEMIC THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
SELL. ITS BOTH THE
UNDERSTANDING THE POPULATION
WHO WILL NEED A HOME DELIVERED
MEAL BUT IS PERHAPS OUR HIGHEST
TOUCH WE DO PROVIDE NUTRITION-
AND THEN DOING THAT MATCHING
WITH WHO NEEDS A HOME DELIVERED
MEAL WHO MIGHT BE PROVIDED TO
ME ALL- THE TRADITIONAL NEEDS
THROUGH THE EXPANSION OF
CALFRESH AND THEN ONLINE OFF
OFFERS THEY'RE THERE NOW. I
JUST ALSO PROVIDES AN ESSENTIAL
MEAL SUPPORT AS WELL SO REALLY
A DEEPER UNDERSTANDING OF ABOUT
THE DOZEN DIFFERENT OLDER
CALIFORNIA TUITION PROGRAMS-
THAT HEALTHY TOGETHER TO MEET
IS VERY DIVERSE POPULATION FROM
SIXTY TO A HUNDRED FROM URBAN
TO RURAL- IS ONE OF OUR
PRIORITIES AND WE ARE
PARTNERING WITH THE TRIPLE AA
IN VENTURA COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
AGING BETWEEN JOB TO KIND OF
HELP US WITH THIS NEEDS
ASSESSMENT OF THE DIVERSITY OF
NEEDS. AND THE DIVERSITY. OF
PROGRAMS AND WHERE THE GAPS
REMAIN. THEN WHAT ELSE ONE TO
THAT I SEE. MISTER KEMPF. YEAH
I JUST TO THE WEB DIRECT WAY
JUST LAST- THE MOM PART OF THE
SHOW. HOW SERVICES ARE IN I'VE
ROLE COMMUTER VERSUS URBAN
COMMUNITIES AND YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE'VE SEEN IS A
LOT OF RURAL COMMUNITIES DON'T
HAVE GREAT PLATES. THEY HAVE A
NICE DINERS SO. I'M DEPENDS
WHERE THEY LIVE. HERE'S HOW IT
IT REALLY DOES SO THE POINT I'M
TRYING TO LOOK AT NEW WAYS OF
DOING BUSINESS AND PROVIDING
SERVICE THAT THAT'S A REAL KEY
P. SEVEN AND THAT HIS BACKEND
WITH FLEXIBILITY ISSUE OF YOU
KNOW WHAT NEW MODELS CAN WE
CREATE A WEB MODELS HAVE.
POPPED UP THAT WE ALL WANT TO
USE AND TRY TO EXPAND ON I'M SO
I JUST THINK IT'S YOU KNOW IT
DOES KIND OF TOUCH ON INTERESTS
ARE STRUCTURE ISSUE BUT IT'S
ANOTHER REASON TO HIGHLIGHT THE
IMPORTANCE OF FLEXIBILITY AND
INNOVATION WHICH WERE ALL
TRYING TO DO ALL THE TIME. AND
I DO LIKE EUROPE FOCUS MISTER
CAMP ON LOOKING FORWARD AND
KNOWING THAT WE'VE GOT A CLIFF
IN FRONT OF US IF WE DON'T. WE
DON'T PUT SOME WORK INTO THIS.
AND I THINK THE FINAL QUESTION
I'LL ASK FOR WE TURN IT OVER
TO. DR PAM FOR SOME QUESTIONS.
IS ABOUT ABOUT VACCINATIONS
RIGHT TO YOUR- BY DEFINITION
SERVING PEOPLE WHO ARE IN.
WITHIN THE CATEGORY OF PEOPLE
WHO SHOULD BE VACCINATED. AND
BY DEFINITION- WORKING WITH
PEOPLE WHO. STRUGGLE WITH
ISSUES AROUND EQUITY THAT WERE
SO DESPERATELY TRYING TO. TO
REACH. HOW HOW HAVE YOU DONE OR
HOW HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO
TRACK. OF THE PENETRATION OF
VACCINATIONS INTO THE
POPULATIONS THAT YOU'RE WORKING
WITH. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION THIS IS AGAIN CAME
AWAY TO DEPARTMENT OF AGING. SO
I. JUST THAT IS OUR JOB NUMBER
ONE RIGHT NOW ONE TWO AND THREE
IS HELPING THE VACCINE SO WE
BEGAN WITHOUT REACH BUT YES
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. BEYOND
OUT REGION EDUCATION IN
ADDRESSING ANY CONCERNS OR
QUESTIONS IS THAT TRUE
MEANINGFUL ACCESS TO REALLY
CLOSE THAT LAST MILE. SO WE'VE
BEEN VERY- ACTIVE WITH R. C. PH
BROTHERS AND SISTERS TO EXPAND
THE- THE POP UP CLINICS THAT GO
WHERE PEOPLE ARE. WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL TO- I COUNTIES LIKE
SAMPOERNA DINO WHO HAVE DONE A
VERY DEEP PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
PUBLIC HEALTH IN AGING TO GO
OUT TO WEAR OLDER ADULTS ARE.
YOU'LL TELL ME HAS MADE SIMILAR
EFFORTS WE ARE SHARING AMONG
THE AGING NETWORK THAT'S BEEN
DISCUSSED PRACTICE COUNTY-
EFFORTS TO GO OUT. WE'VE SEEN
THIS ALSO WITH THE FEMA. SITES
WITH INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS
GOING OUT AND DOING POP UP AND
MOBILE CLINICS AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE REALLY ALL YOU'RE SEEING
THAT WITHTHE FACT DR RANDALL
AND FORMER CLINICS AS WE SPEAK-
AND WE'RE LOOKING TO AS WE MOVE
TO THIS BROADER VACCINATION.
NETWORK BLUE SHIELD. OUR
NETWORK THIS IS MY- IS TO GROW
GROW GROW GROW GROW. THOSE ARE
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS FOR POP
UP CLINICS WHERE PEOPLE ARE ON
THE OTHER THING I WOULD SAY IS
WE NEED WE ARE CONTINUING TO
WORK ON OUR DATA WE'VE GOT.
INCREASING DATA ON AGE AND DATA
ON RACE AND WE'RE LOOKING TO
GO. OF COURSE TO BE
INTERSECTIONAL THE AGENT REYES
DATA. SO THAT YOU CAN REALLY
SEE WHERE THE GAPS ARE AND
YOU'LL BE HEARING MORE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ON EQUITY
APPROACHES IN COMING DAYS- AS
WE AGAIN IN ABOUT TWO WEEKS.
EXPAND ELIGIBILITY TO ADULTS
SIXTY FOUR AND YOUNGER WITH
HIGH RISK MEDICAL CONDITIONS
OR- DISABILITIES WHO ARE ALSO
PART OF AGING DISABILITY
NETWORK. RUSSIA DEPEND. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND- FOR SITES
REALLY DO WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE THE PART OF AGING AND
PARTS OF SERVICES FOR YOUR HARD
WORK- OFTENTIMES WHAT MAKES
NEWS IS WHEN PROBLEMSHAPPENED
SO I GUESS CONGRATULATIONS ARE
NOT MAKING THE NEWS- AND ALSO
OF COURSE ALL OF THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE WORKING HARD IN OUR- I.
AGING AGENCIES AND OUR- SOCIAL
SERVICES THE PARK COUNTY SOCIAL
SERVICES DEPARTMENTS AND SO ON-
I DO JUST WANNA JUST BRIEFLY
MENTION I. REALLY APPRECIATE-
MR TENTHS OF PRAISE FOR OUR
PAST WORK THIS STATE SENATE'S
ONLYHAS- PLAYED A LEADERSHIP
ROLE ON AGING AND APPRECIATE
THAT- I DO WANT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT- EVEN THOUGH I WAS THE
CHAIR OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE THAT-
THOSE PRO TEM ATKINS WHO MADE.
AGING A PRIORITY WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT THE GOVERNOR
THEN BROUGHT IT UP IT IS STATE
OF STATE ADDRESS LATER ON- BUT
WE WERE WORKING A LITTLE BEFORE
AND I ALSO WANT TO RECOGNIZE.
THE ALSO THANK THE BUDGET STAFF
IN PARTICULAR WE NEED A PAUL
WHO'S BEEN STAFFING THE AGING.
ISSUES FOR ME AND HER HER
PASSION AND MAKING SURE THINGS
HAPPEN AS WELL SO. SHOULD THAT.
REALLY DON'T REALLY HAVE MUCH
QUESTIONS I THINK A LOT OF
MAREADY COVERED- WE LOOK
FORWARD TO GETTING- FURTHER
UPDATES AS WE TRY TO GET OUT OF
THIS- COATED- OPERATE CLOSELY
THROUGH BOTH VACCINATIONS AND
ALSO- THE- YOU KNOW THE OTHER
PUBLIC HEALTH MEASURES WHICH I.
ALWAYS REMIND PEOPLE STILL NEED
TO DO- AS WE'RE DOING
VACCINATIONS AND- CERTAINLY-
WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON WHAT MADE
THEIR CANCERS YOU READY GIVEN
ABOUT WHAT KIND OF THINGS WE
WANT TO CONTINUE INTO THE
FUTURE THAT WE CAN LEARNFROM
THIS EXPERIENCE WITH CODE. FOR
ALL THE TERRIBLE THINGS THAT
HAPPENED WE'VE ALSO LEARNED
SOME POSITIVE THINGS AND HOW WE
CAN CONTINUE THIS FOR. NOW LOOK
FORWARD ALSO TO ADDRESSING THE
MASTER PLAN AGING LATER ON AND
A GENDER SELF THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
DOCTOR OPINIONS- I THINK WE CAN
MOVE FORWARD. OKAY NOW WE'RE ON.
SPEAKING OF THE BUDGET
INVESTMENT NOT TO SUPPORT THE
MASTER PLAN ON AGING. THE CAN
BE YOUR DIRECT RECORD. YES
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU'RE EGGMAN
AND US SENATOR PAN AS WELL IT'S
GREAT TO BE WITH YOU TALKING
ABOUT THE MASTER PLAN- AFTER
EIGHTEEN MONTHS OF HAND IN HAND
WORK ON THIS AS YOU SAY WITH
THE SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE MINISTRATIONS OF THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OTHERS THREE
QUESTIONS ON THE AGENDA THAT
ALL ADDRESS. THE FIRST ONE IS
ABOUT THE BUDGET INVESTMENTS
RELATING TO THE MASTER PLAN ON
AGING VERY BRIEFLY THAT BUDGET-
IN THE SUMMARY THERE'S A
SECTION CALLED ADDRESSING
AGING- AND IT WELL OUTLINES THE
TWO APPROACHES THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET TAKES TO- AGING AND
DISABILITY AND CARE GIVING THE
FIRST IS IN THE MAJOR
INITIATIVES AGING IS LAYERED IN
SO THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
INITIATIVES- SOME OF THE
REDESIGN OF HOW A MEDICAID.
AGING IS A THEME THROUGHOUT
THOSE MULTI AGE
INTERGENERATIONAL MAJOR
INITIATIVES WITHOUT WEARING IN
STRATEGY IS ONE THAT YOU I HOPE
WE'RE HEARING IT MANY HEARINGS-
BUT THERE ARE SEVEN TARGETED
AGING INITIATIVES THAT ARE
LISTED BUT I WANT TO BRIEFLY.
RUN. THROUGH- IN. THE PAGES. OF
THE FIRST IS ANNUAL THAT ONLY
WAY OR TWO THAT ARE AFTER. OF
AGING THEY ARE- I ACROSS
DEPARTMENT AFTER IN THOSE THOSE
WILL BE TAKEN UP AT THE
APPROPRIATE HEARINGS- ARE THE
FIRST IS THE OPPOSITE MEDICARE.
INNOVATION AND INTEGRATION AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICE RECOGNIZING CRITICAL
MEDICARE IS FOR YOU CAN
CALIFORNIANS. THE SECOND IS THE
SOCIAL SERVICES UNDER DIRECTOR-
JOHNSON THE PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
FACILITIES TO SUPPORT HOUSING.
THE THIRD- IN ANOTHER ITEM
TODAY IS THE NO WRONG DOOR FOR
AGING AND DISABILITY RESOURCE
CONNECTION AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING. THE FOURTH IS AGAIN PART
OF SOCIAL SERVICES I JUST AS
BACK UP PROVIDER SYSTEM. THE
FIFTH IT IS OUR INTENTION TO
OUR- GERIATRIC CARE WORKFORCE
INCREASING THE GERIATRIC CARE
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF COST.
THE SIX THAT IS AID PACKAGE
AL-SADR'S PROPOSALS WHICH ARE-
RANGING FROM RESEARCH TO PUBLIC
EDUCATION TO TRAINING- AND MORE
WHICH ARE AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND LAST BUT NOT
LEAST THERE IS AN INVESTMENT IN
THE CONTINUED LEADERSHIP AROUND
AGING WITH BOTH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE POSITION ON A SENIOR
ADVISER ON AGING DISABILITY AND
ALZHEIMER'S AND INVESTMENT THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING TO FUND THE
CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP WITH
LEADERSHIP ON A MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING. OKAY M. AS YOU AS IS THE
AGENDA INDICATES THERE IS A
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR PLACE
HOLDER FOR THAT MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING FUNDING AND THAT IS IN
VERY ACTIVE DEVELOPMENT- WITH
AGENCY AND WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION RIGHT NOW- ABOUT
GIVEN THE PLANS FOCUS AND
STRUCTURE HOW TO BEST-
STRUCTURE THE IMPLEMENTATION
TEAM AND THEY'LL BE MORE TO BE
SHARED ON ADAM DISCUSSED ON
THAT VERY VERY SOON. AND THE
THIRD QUESTION ABOUT OUR CITY'S
ROLE RELATED QUESTION- BOTH
WITHIN C. HSS AND OUTSIDE OF IT
TOO FOR THE MASTER PLAN. SO
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S MASTERPLAN. WAIT
CLEARLY IN ITS EXECUTIVE ORDER
FROM- TWENTY NINETEEN TO THE
PLAN ITSELF IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THE GOAL IS TO AND BAD AND
ELEVATE AGING IN EVERY SINGLE
COUNTY AGENCY IN DEPARTMENT AND
YOU SEE THAT IN A CABINET WORK
GROUP THAT FRANKLY BEGAN WITH I
BELIEVE SEVEN OR EIGHT OF THE
AGENCIES THAT BY THE TIME WE
WERE DONE ALL TEN. WE'RE AT THE
TABLE ALL TEN WANTED TO HAVE
AGING- AS PART OF THEIR VISION
AND MISSION ALREADY DID AND
LOOKING TO DEEP AND DEEP IN
THAT AND THAT'S WHAT YOU SEE IN
THE MASTER PLAN. MINISTRATION
AGREEING TO A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO INITIATIVES IN THE
NEXT TWO YEARS BUT ONE OF THE
TEN AGENCIES AND SAID YES WE
WILL DO THAT WE WILL PARTNER
WITH STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO MOVE THAT WORK
FORWARD. BUT WHAT IS THE WHAT
IS THE DA'S ROLLING NOW WE HAVE
TWO ROLES ONE IS TO PARTNER
PARTNERSHIP IS A CENTRAL ONE
AGING FIELDS BUT US TO PARTNER
WITH OTHER DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES AND SUPPORT THEM IN
THEIR WORK. THEY ARE THE
EXPERTS THEY ARE THE LEADERS IN
THAT WORK AND HOW CAN WE
SUPPORT THEM SO UST IN THE
LAST COUPLE DAYS WE HAD
MEETINGS WITH A CURRENT PUBLIC
HELP ON THE ALZHEIMER'S
STRATEGY. DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES ON THE ELDER JUSTICE
STRATEGY- BUT ALSO TE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD IN NAY ON A
NEW SENIOR CHRISTIAN ISSUES AS
WELL AS AGING FARMWORKER
ISSUES- AND THEN THE DEPARTMENT
OF PARKS AND REC ABOUT
TARGETING A NEW ROUND OF
GRANTS. TO A PER CORE AREAS
PARTICULARLY SERVING PEOPLE OF
ALL GENERATIONS ALL AGES AND
HOW WE CAN FOSTER GENERATIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS IN OUR PARKS. SO
WE ARE HERE TO SUPPORT AND
PARTNER WITH ALL DEPARTMENTS
AND AGENCIES THAT'S ONE OF OUR
CRITICAL ROLES AROUND AGING AND
THEN THE SECOND PIECE IS THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE MASTER PLAN
ITSELF. AND SO WE WILL BE DING
VERY SIMILAR TO THE PLANNING
PROCESS CONVENING A STAKEHOLDER
GROUP WE HOPE TO ANNOUNCE THAT
VERY SOON IN THE SPRING. ADAPT
WITH MANY THINGS HAS BEEN A
FINAL LITTLE BIT DELAYED
BECAUSE OF THE NEED TO FOCUS SO
INTENTLY ON VACCINE ACCESS BUT
IT IS STILL ON ON TRACK FOR
SPRING. AND WE WILL BE
RELEASING REGULAR PROGRESS
REPORTS ON WHAT WE'VE DONE
TRACKING BACK TO THE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY TWO INITIATIVES HOW
ARE WE DOING. SO THOSE WILL BE
PUBLIC AND TRANSPARENT SO
PEOPLE CAN SEE. OUR PROGRESS IN
PARTICIPATE IN THE AS- MEETING-
AND OTHERS WILL HAPPEN- I WOULD.
REALLY BUT AGAIN VACCINE HAS
CHANGED THINGS AT LEAST THREE
TIMES. YEAR I THEN WE WILL BE.
FOR ANNUAL REPORT AT THE END OF
THE- YEAR. REALLY RECOMMENDED.
FOR WE GET RIGHT. WHAT WE NEED
TO ADJUST AND WHAT WE NEED TO
DO GOING FORWARD- AND THEN
LASTLY IN TERMS OF THE KIICHIRO
THE LEGISLATURE- AS YOU WELL
KNOW DR PANDA BELIEVE- ARE
IMMENSE TO DO AROUND TABLE IN
THE MASTER PLAN WAS THE LAST IN
PERSON EVENT I DID ANYWAY IT
WAS. FIRST WEEK IN MARCH WITH
YOU IN YOUR DISTRICT- SO- WE
WERE VERY PLEASED TO WERE GIVEN
THE LEGISLATURE ABOUT THE
MEMBER LEVEL HAVING A SERIES OF
ROUNDTABLES. ON IN OUR OUR BUT
AFTER THAT WAS A VIRTUAL WITH
SOMETHING MEMBER JIM WOOD- BUT
ALSO WITH THE STAFF WE WERE
VERY GRATEFUL TO HAVE STAFF AND
AFTER THAT THE COMMITTEES WHEN
THERE WAS A LONG TERM SERVICES
AND SUPPORT. OR RESEARCH
COMMITTEE SO WE ARE VERY OPEN
TO HAVE AS WE GO INTO
IMPLEMENTATION HOW DO WE.
INCLUDE BOTH MEMBERS AND STAFF.
EARNERS IN IN WORKING ON THE
AND I'M- HAPPY TO SAY THAT THIS
FRIDAY WERE DOING A DEMO OF THE
NEW DATA DASHBOARD FOR AGING.
FOR LEGISLATIVE STAFF AS ONE
WORK. WITHOUT THAT'S GREAT THE
ONE QUESTION I WOULD TO DISCUSS
THAT I DON'T KNOW IF HE HAS ON
THE WAY WHAT'S ARE WHAT YOU
PLAN TO KEEP US UPDATED AS WE
GO FORWARD. SURE WHAT AT A
MINIMUM WE WILL BE DOING THESE
REGULAR PROGRESS REPORTS I
BELIEVE DURING THE PLANNING.
BECAME UP ABOUT EVERY QUARTER
WE ARE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU
AND YOUR STAFF ON A MORE- AND
BRING REGULAR BRIEFINGS.
CONSULTATION WE'RE OPEN TO CO
CREATING WITH THE FORMS ARE
THAT ARE BEST FOR YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I THINK
THAT JUST THAT I AM I AM NEW TO
THIS THIS PARTY- BUT WHEN I
HEAR HUNDRED THIRTY TWO
INITIATIVES AND I THINK
EVERYTHING IS A PRIORITY IS
ANYTHING REALLY A PRIORITY.
THAT'S A LOT OF INITIATIVES.
YES AND WE THINK AGING IS
EVERYWHERE. IT'S ALMOST
ANYTHING PEOPLE ARE WORKING ON
WHETHER IT'S- CORRECTIONS OR AS
I SAID PARKS. I SHOULD INCLUDE
ALL OF ALL AGES AND SO THAT IS
IT WHAT ONE WAY IT'S
INTEGRATING AND HOPEFULLY
CELEBRATING PARTICULARLY COMING
OUT OF COBIT- HOW WEIRD IT IS
TO ADDRESS THIS POPULATION IN
EVERYTHING WE DO. I THINK YOU
AT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ANYTHING FROM YOU. HELLO. YES
THIS IS MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY IN
THE MASTER PLAN ON AN AGING
REALLY IS KIND OF A ANOTHER
PIECE TO THE PUZZLE AND WAY TOO
MANY ORGANIZATIONS AND ENTITIES
ARE PART OF PUTTING TOGETHER-
AS WAS MENTIONED- THE
LEGISLATURE WITH ITS PRIOR
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS I KNOW
OUR OFFICE WE'VE DONE
PROJECTIONS AROUND BOTH THE
NUMBER OF SENIORS BUT ALSO THE
NUMBER OF SENIORS WITH
DISABILITIES TO TRY TO INFORM-
HOW SERVICE LEVELS FOR AND
STATE PROGRAMS WE LOOK LIKE IN
THE FUTURE- SO NOW THAT WE HAVE
THE ADMINISTRATION'S MASTER
PLAN- JUST SOME QUESTIONS WE
WOULD RAISE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE. IS ONE EXACTLY
WHAT YOU ABOUT WHAT WHAT WHAT
WHAT THE CHAIR ASKED IS WHAT
DOES THAT LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
LOOK LIKE AND HOW CAN THAT BE
BUILT INTO THE ROLLOUT PROCESS
FORMALLY ON ANY GIVEN THAT THE
MASTER PLAN ISN'T ITERATIVE
PROCESS- IN WHICH POTENTIALLY
NEW INITIATIVES MAY BE ADDED IN
THE FUTURE AS WE MAKE PROGRESS
ARE COMPLETE AND THESE INITIAL
INITIATIVES HAVE BEEN PROPOSED
HOW WILL THE LEGISLATURE AND
STAKEHOLDERS BEING GAUGED AND
THE EVOLUTION OF THE MASTER
PLAN AND THOSE FUTURE
ITERATIONS. I'M IN AND IN
ADDITION ON THE CONCEPT OF
PRIORITIES AND IF ADDITIONAL
INITIATIVES WERE ADDED I'M
MOVING FORWARD- HOW WILL THE
LEGISLATURE INFORM THE
PRIORITIZATION PROCESS AND THE
SELECTION OF THOSE.
INITIATIVES- IT YEAH AND- A
LEAVE MY CAR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND- AGAIN APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION I KNOW THAT- ONE
OF THINGS WE HAVE BEEN
CONSIDERING- IS- NOW THAT THE
MASTER PLAN IS OUT IS ACTUALLY
HAVING A LEGISLATIVE HEARING ON
THAT- AS CHAIR THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE AND I DON'T KNOW THAT
SOMETHING THAT- THE SUB
COMMITTEE MAY ALSO WANT TO
PARTICIPATE AND- MANY WAYS I
WOULD ARGUE THAT AGAIN NOT AT
LEAST FROM OUR SIDE ON THE
DESCENT STATE SENATE SIDE. I
RECALLS A COUPLE YEARS AGO- AND
EVER HAD THIS AT A SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARING JUST LIKE THIS ONE A
CLOSE QUESTION TO THE PART OF
AGING IN THE FINANCE AS TO WHAT
IS THE- PROJECTED INCREASE
BASED ON DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGES
ALONE ON WHAT WE'D HAVE TO
SPEND. ON SOCIALLY AGING
SERVICES GOING FORWARD IF WE IN
TERMS OF MAINTAINED CURRENT
LEVEL SERVICE JUST BECAUSE OF
DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGES. SO IN FACT
I DIDN'T HAVE ANY ANSWERS SO WE
HELD AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING
AND APPRECIATE- I THINK THE L.
A. O. FOR THE CONTRIBUTIONS
THAT HEARING. AND A SICKLY THE
BOTTOM LINE THAT IS VERY SHORT
ANSWER IS THAT- 5% PER YEAR. 5%
ANNUALLY IN PER YEAR NOW THAT'S
OF COURSE ASSUMING WE DON'T
MAKE YOU KNOW SERVICE REFORMS
OR OTHER CHANGES ETCETERA BUT
IN ORDER TO JUST MAINTAIN
SERVICE LEVELS THE WAY THEY-
THEY THEY WORK. WE KEPT
EVERYTHING THE SAME JUST WITH
DEMOGRAPHICS LOAN WAS 5% A YEAR
NOW. KEEP IN MIND OUR GDP
DOESN'T GROW 5% A YEAR ARE
POPULOUS YOU KNOW OUR TAX BASE
DOESN'T GROW 5% A YEAR. AND SO
THAT OF COURSE IS THE BUDGET
CHALLENGE RIGHT I MEAN THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY HUMAN CHALLENGES WELL
IN TERMS OF BEING SURELY.
PROVIDE THE HELP WE NEED TO THE
SENIORS TO LIVE IN THE STATE
BUT I MEAN JUST EVEN FROM A
STRICTLY BUDGET STANDPOINT. AND
I'M ALWAYS CURIOUS EVERY TIME
THE BUDGET COMES OUT AS ARE WE
KEEPING UP WITH 5% A YEAR FOR
HE SERVICES- THINGS LIKE I. HSS
AND- NURSING HOME CARE AND- YOU
KNOW OTHER TYPES OF SENIOR
PROGRAM C. BASSETT CENTER- AND
SO FORTH. SO- SO GUESS ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS- I. FELT LIKE I
DO HAVE. IS THAT AND- IS THAT
IN TERMS OF. THE ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT- THAT'S- APPS ON
THE IN TERMS OF PARTICULAR
BUDGET STANDPOINT ONE THE MORE
EXPENSIVE THINGS IS YOU KNOW
THE PAYMENT FOR LTSS SERVICES
MARKET LEADER TALK ABOUT HSS IN
THIS HEARING. AND OFTENTIMES
PEOPLE- IT WAS A COMPLAINTS NOT
RIGHT WORD BUT THEY- EXPRESSED-CONCERN ABOUT HOW QUICKLY I HSS
SPENDING GOES UP BUT IF YOU
THINK ABOUT THE DEMOGRAPHICS
ACTUALLY IT'S NOT COMING UP
VERY FAST IN RELATION TO THE
DEMOGRAPHICS. AND SO- AND THEN
OF COURSE WE HAVE WHEN WE HEAR
THE PART HEALTHCARE SERVICES.
YOU KNOW I IN TERMS OF AGAIN
THE MEDICAL PROGRAM A GOOD
CHUNK OF SPENDING ON MEDICARE
ALL IT ACTUALLY GOES TO AGAIN-
NO INSTITUTIONAL CARE. RIGHT
SO- YEAH WHEN THINGS WERE
TALKING ABOUT BEFORE THE MASTER
PLAN GOT STARTED AND- WOULD BE
INTERESTED IS THE QUESTION- THE
ANSWER TO THIS SO WE'VE BEEN
EXPLORING THIS IDEA OF SAYING
THAT. WE NEED TO. FIND A WAY TO
FINANCE LONG TERM SERVICES
SUPPORTS NOT JUST THROUGH THE
MEDICAID PROGRAM SO BASICALLY
THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS THAT.
YOUR FAMILY YOU BASICALLY SPEND
DOWN UNTIL YOU CAN QUALIFY FOR
MEDICAID THEN YOU END UP ON
MEDICAID AND THEN YOU GET YOUR-
SERVICES THAT WAY. THAT THERE'S
GOT TO BE AN ALTERNATIVE THAT
PARTICULAR FROM MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES. AND- SO IN RELATION
TO THE MASTER PLAN- AND SO
FORTH THAT THAT IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT'S IN THE MASTER
PLAN AND IF SO. WHERE DOES THAT
SAID SO I KNOW THAT THERE'S
PIECES AND ALL SORTS OF
DIFFERENT PARTS AND WE HEARD
FROM THE FAR HEALTHCARE
SERVICES WE'VE HEARD SOME
THINGS FROM SOCIAL SERVICE AND
WE HEAR SOME MORE LATER THIS
HEARING. AND I KNOW THAT THIS
IS- SO I DON'T KNOW FOR
DEPARTMENT AGING IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT WOULD FALL UNDER
DEPARTMENT AGING TO DO THIS
KIND OF ACTUARIAL STUDY OR IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT. FALLS
UNDER DIFFERENT DEPARTMENT AND
IS THERE A CHANCE IN THIS-
EVADING DOESN'T KNOW PERHAPS
FINANCE CAN ALSO ADDRESS THIS
QUESTION AS WELL SO- BECAUSE I
THINK THIS DEFINITELY AS A
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE. THAT'S
THAT THAT WOULD HAVE A
POTENTIALLY VERY INTACT ON HER.
BUT GOING IN THE FUTURE. IF WE
ARE ABLE TO ACT SUCCESSFUL DO
THIS. GREAT LET ME TRY TO
PROVIDE ONE ANSWER TO IT AND
THEN I WILL TURN MY FINANCE
COLLEAGUES TO ASSIST SO- AGAIN.
PERMITTING SUCH A KIND OF I
MEAN I THINK YOU'RE ASKING BOTH
A SYSTEM QUESTION AND TO PAY
YOUR QUESTION WHICH IS YES IT
MORE I'M GONNA GIVE YOU TWO
ANSWERS. THAT WOULD YOU THINK.
I MEAN YOU KNOW YOU YOU ARE
CORRECT THE LONG TERM SAYS LONG.
TERM SYSTEM. ACER THAT P. THAT
WE AS WE- IS. BY MY- PAIRS
MEDICAID MEDICARE OTHERS
PRIVATELY BANKS MEDICARE NOT SO
MUCH BUT THAT'S A LITTLE BIT
YES. IN MULTIPLE PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT MANY OF OUR
APARTMENTS. SERVICES AGING SO
YOU'RE RIGHT SO I THINK THERE'S
TWO THINGS- THE MASTER PLAN DID
BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER AROSS
PROGRAM DEPARTMENTS TO HAVE
THAT SYSTEM TABLE. AT THE LTSS
SUB COMMITTEE AND WE ARE
LOOKING AT WAYS TO CONTINUE
THAT SYSTEM TABLE- PARTICULARLY
PERHAPS BUILDING ON THE STRONG
FOUNDATION OF THE OLMSTED
ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT BRINGS
TOGETHER DISABILITY AND AGING
STAKEHOLDERS TO LOOK AT
COMMUNITY INCLUSION- SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE A SYSTEM CONVERSATION.
AND CERTAINLY AGING IS PART OF
FACILITATING THAT PARTNERSHIP
CONVERSATION. BY TIER ABSOLUTE
POINT MEDICAID AS A DH CS DHS
CONTINUES TO BE THE LEAD ON
THAT ISSUE AND DELETE THE WORK
WORK WITH MELANIN TO DO THE
ACTUARIAL STUDY- THE NEW
MEDICARE OFFICE OF INNOVATION
INTEGRATION IS PROPOSED TO BE
AT DH. CS BECAUSE THEY ARE
ABSOLUTELY. BOTH MEDICARE. THAT
EXIST NOW. TO EXPAND MEDICARE'S
ABILITY TO PAY FOR HOME AND
COMMUNITY SERVICES. AND
POTENTIALLY SOME EXCITING
OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION. TO
REVISIT MEDICARE'S ROLE LTSS I
AND THEN TO YOUR POINT THERE IS
BEYOND. THE STATE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONERS RECONVENING A
LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE
COMMISSION FOR ANOTHER PIECE OF
THE PUZZLE. THERE ARE I DO YES
YES IT'S CLEARLY AT THE HEART
OF THIS- BUT WE ARE AND ALSO WE
ARE TRYING TO. HAVE A SYSTEMS
TABLE CONVERSATION AS WELL
WELCOME YOUR PERSPECTIVE IN
ADVICE ON THAT AND RECOGNIZE
YOUR LEGISLATION IN THAT AREA
AS WELL YEAH. WELL AND IF IT'S
APPRECIATE THE ANSWER- IN SOME
WAYS- WELL CERTAINLY- DCS THOSE
HAVE ALWAYS THE EXPERTISE AND
HEALTH CARE HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
AND IN PAIN AND SO FORTH. THIS
ISN'T YEAH WE'RE NOT ALKING
ABOUT. THAT WELL WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT SIMPLY THE PART
THAT FITS IN MEDIC CAL OR EVEN
THE PART THAT FITS AND MEDICARE
ALTHOUGH DEPENDS AGAIN ON THE
FEDERAL LEVEL IT CREATES NEW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MATCHING
FUNDS IT'S EVERYONE TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT. SO BUT JUST
STUDYING THE ISSUE OVER ALL
BEYOND META CAL RIGHT SO WE
HAVE MEDICARE WE KNOW THAT'S
THERE BUT FOR PEOPLE. IS THERE
AN OPTION FOR PEOPLE TO NOT
HAVE TO GO ON MEDICARE HOUSE IN
ORDER TO GET LTSS SERVICES AND
WHAT ARE THEY SO YES THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER IS
LOOKING AT- YOU KNOW PRIVATE.
THAT THE PRIVATE- ISHMAEL HAVE
LONG TERM CARE CERTAINLY L. A.
SURE IT'S ADDRESS- I THINK WE
NEED TO LOOK AT FOR EXAMPLE AND
OF COURSE THAT'S PLAYED BY THE
FACT THAT YOU HAVE ADVERSE
SELECTION OF NEARLY NOT
EVERYONE'S IN AND SO FORTH. IS
THERE. A SPACE WHERE WE CAN
ACTUALLY LOOK AT THIS ISSUE AND
MAYBE IT IS IN YOUR TELL ME ITS
DTS THAT'S FINE ENOUGH TO
INTEREST HERE FROM DIED. FROM
FINANCE. BUT WE SHOULD HAVE A
FIGURE OUT A CONVERSATION ABOUT
SAYING LOOK HOW COULD WE- HOW
COULD BE. WE HAVE TO SEVEN YOU
PROGRAM. RIGHT DAD WHERE
EVERYONE HAS TO BE AND IN THE
SAME WAY WE ACTUALLY SET UP THE
RETIREMENT PROGRAM ACTUALLY
THERE TIME SEEMS PROGRAM HERE
AS WELL- THAT. THAT WAS DONE
THAT THAT MAY BE. PART OF THE
SOLUTION SO. WHERE WOULD THAT
SIX. OUT IN TERMS OF- WOULD
THAT STILL CERTAIN EIGHT C. S.
A. SIM IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE
NOT SAYING IT'S QUITE AN AGING-
MAYBE FINANCING THOMAS TO
WHERE'D THAT DISCUSSION SHOULD
SET. YEAH I DO THINK IT'S A
PARTNERSHIP BECAUSE THE
HEALTHCARE PAYER IT IS A GAP IN
MEDICARE IT'S ULTIMATELY
GAPPING MEDICARE IN OUR COUNTRY
AND SO THAT IS A STARTING PLACE
BUT INTO THE- YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
YOU'RE CORRECT THAT WE- SERVE
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE- WHO ARE IN
THAT EXACT DILEMMA YOU DESCRIBE
TO CANNOT AFFORD IT WHO ARE
SPENDING DOWN AND SO WE ARE
ALSO. SEEKING TO PARTNER WITH
OUR DH CS LEADSAND I WITHOUT A
HAND IT TO FINANCE TO FURTHER
ADDRESS THIS. IS A QUESTION OF
HOW DO WE FINANCE AND FIND OUT
LONG TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS.
DEPARTING FINANCE. BOB GOOD
AFTERNOON ALFA MIKE HARTMAN
FINANCE- WE I CO DIRECTOR
MACQUARIE FOR WEIGHTS OFF
STATEMENTS AND THE LATEST
VERSION OF THE PROPOSAL OUT OF
THE OFFICE OF MEDICARE
INNOVATION IMMIGRATION ACT
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES- AND THE PURPOSE OF
THIS OFFICE. WOULD BE BROADER
THAN JUST- BUT IF CALCULATION
IT WOULDN'T BE FOR. OLDER WERE
JUST ODD MEDICARE. OKAY AND.
WORKING ON STRATEGIES INCENTIVE
ALL ON HOW TO INCREASE ACCESS
TO LONG TERM AND SUPPORTS FOR
POPULAR SIZES THAT'S MORE SO
QUESTION IS- FUNDING ASIDE TO
THAT I. AND THEY THAT ****
SHOULD TALK TO WE TALKED
DETAILS BUT IS THERE FUNDING
ASSIGNED THE OFFICE TO DO THE
ACT OR- NECESSARY. TO AND IF TO
HELP START DEVELOPING AIDS. TO
PROVIDE. THE FINANCE LTSS
SERVICE FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
COOL HOPEFULLY NOT COULD END UP
IN THE ATTIC CAL I MEAN WE CAN
FORCE THEM INTO EVENTUALLY IF
THEY SPEND DOWN ENOUGH. BUT
THAT. BUT BASICALLY LOOKING AT
ALTERNATIVES. TO SPENDING DOWN
TO MALAKAL IS A WAY TO FINANCE
AND AFTER ALL OF WE THE PEOPLE
DO SPEND ON AMERICA WE'RE STILL
PAYING FOR AS TAXPAYERS RIGHT
WE PAY OUR HALF OF THE STATE
SO. I THINK THERE'S AN ADVANCED
US TO DOING ITS ONLY BE SURE WE
ACTUALLY PUT IN MONEY INTO THE
BUDGET TO LOOK INTO THE FUTURE
AND TO DO THE KIND OF ACTUARIAL
WORK NECESSARY TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT. HOW TO FIND OR SELL OUT
OF BASICALLY. COME UP SOLUTIONS
AT THE LLAMA. I DO BELIEVE THAT
THAT IS A DHD ASK QUESTIONS
GIVEN THAT THEY HAVE THE
CONTRACT ON THE CURRENT
ACTUARIAL STUDY. WITH NORMAN
THAT'S COME OUT THIS PAST
SUMMER- THAT DID PUT. SOME
ASSUMPTIONS AND SOME ESTIMATES
AND SOME PRICES ON VARIOUS WAYS
TO DO SOMETHING CALIFORNIA
SIMILAR TO WASHINGTON STATE
DID. SO I DO WITHOUT YOU KNOW
WITH ALL RESPECT BUT THEY
COMMITTEE AND MY CALL TO DH YES
BELIEVE IT IS A CONVERSATION
THAT. OKAY BUT ONCE WE THAT'S
L. A. A. REALIZING IT MAY NOT
BE USED TO THAT TO EVERY CAN
RELAY THAT INFORMATION TO THE
PROPER PERSON OVER. FINANCE.
HER DHS- I WOULD LIKE TO BE
THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY. BUDGETING
DOING STUDY THAT'S A VERY SMALL
DOWN PAYMENT. FOR SOMETHING
THAT WILL DEFINITELY WELL WE'RE
PROBABLY LOOKING AT A RIGHT NOW
IN TERMS OF. HOW WE'RE GONNA
FINANCE LTSS- IN THE VERY IT
BOTH THE NEAR AND DISTANT
FUTURE. YES FINANCING PERMITTED
AGING CAN BRING THAT BACK TO DH
CS. OKAY I THANK YOU AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN ANSWER THAT
OKAY THANKS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT THAT ANSWER- IF WE CAN
MOVE ON NOW TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO
AGING AND DISABILITY RESOURCE
CONNECTIONS. YES I DO WAY TO
GET FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING I'M DELIGHTED TO TALK
WITH YOU ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL.
AS YOU HAVE BEEN HEARING AND IS
YOU KNOW AND IT'S ACTUALLY
DIRECTOR JOHNSON REALLY
BEAUTIFULLY- PRESENTED THERE IS
QUITE A SPECTRUM OF SERVICES-
QUITE A SPECTRUM OF US SUPPORTS
AND NONPROFIT PARTNERSHIPS IN
COUNTY PROGRAMS AND HEALTH
PLANS AND HOUSING. WHAT IS
CHALLENGING FOR THE PUBLIC IS
FINDING HOW TO ACCESS THEM AND
SO WHAT THIS PROPOSAL DOES THIS
CROSS SUGGEST. A UNIFIED FRONT
DOOR. THAT WOULD CONNECT YOU
WITH SOMEONE IN YOUR COMMUNITY
WITH THE EXPERTISE AND TRAINING
TO HELP YOU NAVIGATE. THAT THAT
MAYES AND FIND THE RIGHT MIX OF
SERVICES FOR YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY SO THIS IS ODD.
FEDERALLY KNOWN AS THE AGING
DISABILITY RESOURCE CONNECTION
ADRC OFTEN IN CALIFORNIA WE
CALL IT N RUN DOOR- THERE'S
ACTUALLY A PROPOSAL TO- REALLY
THINK ABOUT AS WE MOVE TO A
STATEWIDE SYSTEM AND PROPOSED
DOING THAT- THREE LOOK AT
BANNING AS WELL TO MAKE SURE
THAT'S A NAME THAT RESONATES
WITH OLDER ADULTS. AND PEOPLE
DISABILITIES AND CARE GIVERS
AND IS RECOGNIZABLE- I OFTEN
JOKE THAT I'M JEALOUS OF THE
FIRST FIVE BRAND THAT HAS BEEN
SO SUCCESSFUL WITH YOUNG
CHILDREN WE NEED TO FIND THAT
OUT FOR OUR POPULATION SO THE
NO MATTER WHERE YOU LIVE YOU
KNOW WHO TO CALL. AND AGAIN
IT'S THAT FRONT DOOR IT'S
COMMON ACROSS THE STATE BUT IT
IT CONNECTS TO YOUR LOCAL.
AGENTS ON AGING AND IN THE-
LIVING SO THAT IS THE EXPERT.
IN BOTH PERSON CENTERED CARE
HE'D- SERVICES. I IN YOUR
COMMUNITY. THIS PROPOSAL WILL
HELP US TO GET STATEWIDE- WE
CURRENTLY. IF YOU COUNT BOTH OF
OUR ESTABLISHED FULL SERVICE AT
OUR SEAS AND ARE EMERGING
PARTIAL SERVICE IN YOUR SEATS.
WE ARE HAVE A PRESENCE IN ABOUT
A THIRD OF THE STATE. SO THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD HELP US GET
BASELINE FUNDING. THROUGHOUT
THE STATE- AND BEGIN TO BE THAT
BAD THAT FRONT DOOR. FOR PEOPLE
STATEWIDE AND THAT THAT THAT
FULL SERVICES BEYOND JUST INFO
AND REFERRAL BUT TRULY
COUNSELING TRULY. NAVIGATION AN
ENROLLMENT ASSISTANCE. I WILL
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
FUNDING THAT CAME IN TWENTY
NINETEEN- VERY ESSENTIAL TO
HAVE THAT STATE SUPPORT WE'RE
ALSO PLEASED WITH THE PANDEMIC
ON THE THAT WE ALSO HAVE THREE
MILLION MORE IN FEDERAL FUNDING
SO THAT INFUSION OF THAT.
FEDERAL STATE PARTNERSHIP WITH
EIGHT MILLION- IS HELPING US
EXPAND SERVICES AS THEY THEY
ROSE IN THE PANDEMIC I WILL SAY
ALSO THE IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC
HAS MADE IT- WE'VE ALL BEEN IN
CRISIS RESPONSE MODE SO IT'S
BEEN A LITTLE BIT HARDER TO
MOVE SOME OF THE PLANNING. FOR
WORK SO WHILE THE SERVICE A MAN
WENT UP AND WE AND WE CONTINUE
TO MEET THE SERVICE DEMANDS.
AND THE WAY THAT WE WERE WE ARE
ALSO STILL MOVING TO EXPAND
THAT THE RANGE OF SERVICES IF I
CAN. I CAN SAY THAT. I'M
LOOKING AHEAD. JUST AS WE ARE
THINKING A LOT ABOUT THE
PUBLIC- ACCESS POINTS AND THE
HIGH QUALITY SERVICES BEHIND IT
WE ARE ALSO LOOKING AT THE
FINANCIAL SUSTAINABILITY AND
HOW DO YOU FIND- THIS PROGRAM
AS A FRONT DOOR. LIKE I SAID TO
SOCIAL SERVICES HEALTH SERVICES
HEALTH PLAN SERVICES COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND MORE. I WILL BE
LOOKING AT- OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS FOR CONSUMING OLDER
AMERICANS ACT OPPORTUNITIES
WE'RE ALSO EXPLORING MEDICAID
ADMINISTRATIVE CLAIMING WITH T.
H. C. S. A MODEL THAT'S USED
IN- SEVERAL OTHER STATES. WILL
BE CONTINUING TO WORK ON THE
SUSTAINABLE FINANCIAL PLAN TO
SUPPORT THE EMERGING. AND
GROWING STATEWIDE NETWORK.
THAT'S A VERY BRIEF I'M HAPPY
TO STOP GIVEN TO. AND I. OUGHT
TO GET A QUOTE YOU MAY. M.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- DEPARTMENT
FINANCE ANYTHING. HELLO HELLO
YES WE WOULD LIKE THAT
CURRENTLY THE ADRC FUNDING IS
SUBJECT TO POTENTIAL SUSPENSION
ON DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE
IF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
FINDS THAT THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH
REVENUES TO COVER ALL
SUSPENSION ITEMS- IN THE MAY
REVISION- AND JUST BASED OFF OF
CURRENT LAW LOOKING AT ACTUAL
REVENUE LEVELS IT'S LIKELY
THAT- IF THIS CALCULATION WERE
CONDUCTED IN MAY AND THERE
WOULD BE ENOUGH REVENUE TO-
COVER ALL SUSPENSION ITEMS
MEANING THAT THE FUNDING FOR A
YEAR SEIZE WOULD CONTINUE
PERMANENTLY HOWEVER UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S CURRENT BUDGET- THEY
ARE PROPOSING TO SUBJECT AB OR
SEE FUNDING AND OTHER ITEMS AND
THE EXISTING SUSPENSION ITEMS.
TO NEW SUSPENSION LANGUAGE
WHICH ESSENTIALLY WOULD PUSH
OUT THIS CALCULATION TO MAY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO- AND- AND
THEN ALSO PUSH OUT THE POSSIBLE
SUSPENSION DATE TO DECEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY TWO SO WHILE WE
HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THEM
DETER C. FUNDING REQUEST- IN A
PRIOR RIGHT UP WE DID RECOMMEND
OVERALL REJECTING THE
SUSPENSION LANGUAGE- AS IT IN
PART I'M PREEMPTIVELY REDUCES
OR ELIMINATES FUNDING FOR
CERTAIN PROGRAMS WHICH THEN IT
HINDERS THE LEGISLATURE'S
ABILITY TO WEIGH THE BENEFITS
AND TRADE OFFS OF ALL POSSIBLE
OPTIONS WHEN CONSIDERING HOW TO
MANAGE- THE PROJECTED BUDGET
SHORTFALL. ON IN ADDITION A IN
IN ADDITION TO OUR
RECOMMENDATION OF REJECTING THE
NEW BUDGET BILLS SUSPENSION
LANGUAGE- WE ALSO- WOULD
SUGGEST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
REQUEST ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
ON ONE- THE CREATORS THE
SERVICE LEVELS- HOW THE RECENT
STATE FUNDS HAVE IMPROVED
ACCESS I'M AND SEVEN SERVICE
LEVELS ACROSS THE STATE AND HOW
ANY FUTURE REDUCTIONS TO OR
ELIMINATION OF STATE FUNDING TO
EACH YEAR SEES- COULD IMPACT
ACT. THE EIGHT YEARS HE NETWORK
AND POSSIBLY COME RESYNC THAT
WE MADE A NEXT. ON THE NETWORK
WITHIN THE STATE. THANK YOU.
FOR THE LETTER AT ENFORCEABLE
AGREE WITH WHAT THE L. A.
ASSIGNMENT MONEY JUST BECAUSE
THIS QUESTION AGING- IF FOR GOD
FORBID- IT WAS STRANDED- WELL
THIS IS LIKE- HOW DOES THIS
PROGRAM- POTENTIALLY EITHER MAY
ACTUALLY SAVE US MONEY BECAUSE
WE GET PEOPLE SERVICES OR
IMPROVES ACCESS- TO FOR SENIORS
SO- YOU KNOW WE HAVE. THE THE A
PROPOSAL FOR THE AIR SEAS IS IT
IS IT IS IT HELPFUL. THE HELP
PEOPLE. WELL BASED ON ALL OF
OUR EXPERIENCES- BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC BUT EVEN MORE RECENTLY
GETTING INFORMATION. NO OLDER
ADULTS ABOUT. BEING HOME ABOUT
MEALS ABOUT TESTING ABOUT
VACCINATIONS ABOUT EVERYTHING
WE NEED TO STAY IN OUR HOME
COMMUNITIES AND A BUT AS YOU
SAY AVOID THAT HEALTH CRISIS.
AVOID INSTITUTIONALIZATION
AVOID THAT SUICIDE ATTEMPT.
THESE ARE- THE VERY VERY
VALUABLE NAVIGATOR SERVICES
BOTH IN TERMS OF- THE
COMPLEXITY OF SERVICE IS BEING
PROVIDED TO HELP SOMEONE PUT
TOGETHER A PACKAGE OF CARE
COORDINATION THAT REALLY WORKS
FOR THEM AND THEIR NEEDS MAY
CHANGE- AND ALSO- V. THAT-
OLDER ADULTS THEMSELVES MAY OR
MAY NOT HAVE HAD. SOMEONE ELSE
WHO CAN HELP THEM REDUCE MORE
MORE LIVING ALONE- MORE AND
MORE MAY HAVE A CHALLENGES TO
BE AS WE AGE AT HOME SO AND
THEN TO THE THIRD WITH THAT YOU
MADE THE COST OF THE
ALTERNATIVE- THE COSTUME OF THE
NURSING HOME OR ASSISTED LIVING
YEAH A WELL IN THE CENTRAL PART
OF A CONTINUUM OF CARE IS CAN
BE ONE OF THE MOST. EXPENSIVE
SO THE MORE WE CAN DO TO. HELP
PEOPLE BE AWARE OF THEM FIND
THEM AND ACCESS THEM WE THINK
THEY THAT IT PAYS OFF IN EVERY
WAY AND WE AND WE ACTUALLY ALSO
THINK IT'S A MATTER OF EQUITY.
THAT'D BE CLEAR WHAT'S
AVAILABLE AND THAT THERE ARE
MULTIPLE WAYS TO ACCESS THAT
THAT IT NOT BE AMAZED TO FIND
IN THE SERVICES MY COMMUNITY-
SO BRINGING IT TO PEOPLE AN
ACCEPTABLE LANGUAGE FRIENDLY
AND CULTURALLY COMPETENT WAYS
AND- VERY INSPIRED BY THE MODEL
IN SAN FRANCISCO WHERE I DIDN'T
SPEAK TO HAVE KELLY HERE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO WITH HER
EXPERTISE. WHERE THERE IS A
CENTRAL TRIPLE A BUT THEY ALSO
HAVE THIRTEEN COMMUNITY
PARTNERS RECORD- HOUSE AND
SPOKE. OUT TO THE DIFFERENT
CULTURAL COMMUNITIES IN Q.
INCLUDING LGBTQ I THINK ALLOWS
US TO REALLY BE THAT BEST OF
BOTH WORLDS THAT COMMON FRONT
DOOR FOR EASIER ACCESS BUT THEN
ALSO THAT TAILORED LOCAL
ASSISTANCE FOR THAT MEANS THAT
PERSON'S NEEDS WHERE THEY ARE
THAT PERSON CENTERED BOB
EQUITIES LED APPROACH SO- YES.
WE ARE VERY INSPIRED BY WHAT WE
SEE IN WASHINGTON STATE AND
OTHER PLACES AROUND THE
COUNTRY- GETTING LOTS OF OFFERS
OF HELP FROM OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS TO HELP CALIFORNIA
TAKE THE BIG LEAP FORWARD. I
THINK WE KNOW WHAT IT MADE A
DIFFERENCE. INDEPENDENT AND WE-
THAT WITH SUPPORT WE CAN. ON A
DIFFERENCE BY FORWARD OKAY NO I
APPRECIATE- FINANCES YOU HEARD
THAT ANSWER. BECAUSE OF- I'M
NOT GONNA ASK DIRECTOR IN THEM
OF. THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THEREFORE CANNOT DISAGREE WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. BUT FOR
ALL THE REASONS WHICH I ALSO
FIRMLY AGREE WITH THE- THE
DIRECTOR THAT THIS IS NOT ONLY
VERY BENEFICIAL IT ACTUALLY
ACTUALLY SAVE US MONEY. TO ME
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE THEN TO
PUT ON. A SUSPENSION. WHERE YES
YOU KNOW I IT'S NT CERTAINLY A
WIN BUT IF- IF THE ECONOMY
ACTUALLY WIN WOULD ARGUE THAT A
PROGRAM THAT PROTESTERS
BENEFITS- DESCRIBED AS WELL AS
THE POTENTIAL COST SAVINGS.
WOULD BE ONE WOULD WANT TO
RETAIN. EVEN IF THE ECONOMY WAS
DOWN. WITH WITH WITH THAT WAS
THAT IT WOULD BE THAT IS THAT
SOMETHING YOU WOULD DISAGREE
WITH. FINANCE WHERE KNOWLEDGE
BURKE CONCERNS ALL BARBARA BY
THE LEGISLATURE MLA- AND WE
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
ADRC PROGRAM- BUT AS SOMETHING
WILL KEEPING THIS VERY STRONG.
AS FOR OF THE OVERALL JUST ONCE
HE'S BACK IT'S AN OVERALL- ST
STE THIS FOCUS ON. OKAY. HE AT
RICHARD AT AT THEN A REAL THAT-
DISMAY MESSAGE RELY TO FAR UP
THE CHAIN- BUT YOU KNOW WHEN
THE THAT I WAS OF THE SENATE
OFTEN. ABOUT IS THAT WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT- WE SAY SOMETHING
COSTS X. AMOUNT OF DOLLARS
RIGHT IN THE BUDGET WITH THE
SAY WELL HOW MUCH IS THE COST
WE DON'T DO THAT. RIGHT SO HOW
MUCH IS THE BECAUSE THAT'S IT'S
NOT SO MUCH DO WE SPEND MONEY
ON THIS. WE JUST DON'T SPEND
MONEY SO THEREFORE WE STE YOU
KNOW I HAVE A NUMBER OF.
POSITIONS OR WHATEVER ELSE AND
THAT'S GONNA BE THAT MANY
DOLLARS. BUT HOW MUCH WE SPEND
WE DIDN'T HAVE IT. RIGHT AND-
AND SO IT TURNS OUT WE'RE GONNA
END UP SPENDING MORE FROM NOT
HAVING IT. THEN FROM HAVING IT.
I'M NOT SURE WHERE WE WOULD PUT
IT ON A SUSPENSION LIST OR SOME
OTHER SITUATION I MEAN. THAT
THAT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE A GOOD
INVESTMENT. AND SO I HOPE THE
ADMINISTRATION I CERTAINLY
AGREE WITH THE L. L. I
CERTAINLY AGREE WITH THE
DIRECTOR OF AGING ABOUT THE
BENEFITS OF THIS PROGRAM. AND
ALSO IT'S EVEN FINANCIAL
BENEFITS SO I HOPE THAT
CERTAINLY- WHEN IT COMES TO.
SUSPENSION LANGUAGE WE CAN ALL
AGREE MAYBE WE SHOULD JUST
ELIMINATE THE SUSPENSION
LANGUAGE BECAUSE WHY WOULD WE
WANT TO SUSPEND A PROGRAM THAT
NOT ONLY HAS THIS TREMENDOUS
BENEFITS AS WAS DESCRIBED I
WON'T REPEAT ALL OF THEM. BUT
ALSO PROBABLY. AND THEN OF
COURSE WE CAN TO MAKE IT MORE
ANALYSIS OF THERE'S
DISAGREEMENT ON THAT. THEY
ACTUALLY SAVE US MONEY. SO WITH
THAT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR PAN
AYE I CALLED THE BLUE TARP
SYNDROME EVEN AROUND YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD AND YOU SEE THOSE
HOUSES WITH THE BLUE TARP ON
THE ROOF AND YOU KNOW THERE WAS
A HOLE IN IT DIDN'T GET PATCHED
AND THEN PRETTY SOON THE RAIN
CAME IN THAT WHOLE GOT BIGGER
AND THEN THE ROOF CAVED IN AND
THEN HAVE FLOODING IN A LOT
MORE PROBLEMS- SO WE CAN ALL
AGREE IT'S A IT'S A IT'S AN
IMPORTANT THING TO KEEP THE
ROOF. SECURE I THINK WE CAN
KEEP EVERYBODY INSIDE DRY OKAY
CAN WE MOVE ON TO DEPARTMENTS
SOCIAL SERVICES ADULT PROGRAMS.
VERY JUST. NEEDED THERE HI THIS
IS SAKET NIELSEN THOMPSON
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES-
IT AND I HOLD ON A SECOND.
SHIFTING TO BE OFF TRACK. OKAY
THE PROPOSAL FOR AGING
INVESTMENT I'M SORRY. SORRY
ABOUT. THANK YOU. WE GET
ILLEGAL CAN REINFORCE. YES AND
JACQUELINE BRAZIL BALANCED
OFFENSE- AS WAS MENTIONED WE
WERE ASKED TO READ THE
PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENTS
RELATED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING- I'LL FOR THOSE THAT WANT
TO FOLLOW ALONG I'LL JUST BE
READING EXACTLY WHAT'S IN THE
AGENDA- WE MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS AS WERE STILL
COMING UP TO SPEED WITH MANY OF
THESE PROPOSALS BUT IF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
WERE HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP WITH
STAFF AT A LATER POINT. SO THE
FIRST- BUDGET PROPOSAL IS FROM
THE MISSISSIPPI SIDE
ASSOCIATION WHICH IS REQUESTING
TWENTY FOUR POINT SEVEN MILLION
GENERAL FUND I'M GOING TO MAKE
PERMANENT A TEMPORARY RATE
INCREASE FOR MSSP PROVIDERS SET
TO EXPIRE JUNE THIRTIETH.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THE SECOND
BUDGET PROPOSAL. FROM THE IS-
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF AREA AGENCIES WHICH REQUIRES
TEN MILLION GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY ONE. TWENTY TWO TWENTY
FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND. IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. AND
FIFTY THREE MILLION GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. AND ONGOING TO IMPLEMENT
A STATEWIDE ADRC PROGRAM. THE
THIRD BUDGET REQUESTED FROM THE
IS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF AREA AGENCIES
WHICH REQUEST THREE POINT THREE
MILLION GENERAL FUND I'M GOING
TO PROVIDE FOR THE BASIC
OPERATIONS AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING. AGING'S OVERSIGHT DUTIES
AND RESPONSIBILITIES. THE
FOURTH BUDGET REQUEST IS FROM
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
AREA AGENCIES WHICH REQUEST
FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO TEN
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AND FIFTEEN
THREE TWENTY FOUR AND I'M
GOING. TO IMPLEMENT A FALL
PROTECT A PREVENTION PROGRAM
FOR OLDER PERSONS LIVING IN
THEIR HOMES. THE EFFECTIVE
BUDGET REQUEST IS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF AREA
AGENCIES WHICH REQUEST THIRTY
FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. FIFTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AND SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR AND
I'M GOING. TO EXPAND THE SENIOR
NUTRITION PROGRAMS. THE SIX
BUDGET REQUEST. ISFROM THE
MEALS ON WHEELS ASSOCIATION
WHICH REQUEST SEVENTEEN POINT
FIVE MILLION IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. AND THIRTY FIVE
MILLION ANNUALLY THEREAFTER FOR
SENIOR NUTRITION PROGRAMS. THE
SEVENTH AND LAST BUDGET REQUEST
IS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES- WHICH REQUESTED SIX
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND FIVE POINT
FIVE MILLION ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER TO ESTABLISH THE
OFFICE OF THE PATIENT
REPRESENTATIVE WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING. THANKS
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY. THE DOCTOR PAN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- JUST JUST A FEW
THE COUPLE BRIEF COMMENTS- SO
AGAIN SORT OF APROPOS- IN TERMS
OF SAYING WHAT WHAT THE COST
NOT TO DO IT FOR EXAMPLE I KNOW
FALLS- HAVE A TREMENDOUS IMPACT
ON NOT ONLY THE HEALTH BUT
ACTUALLY EVEN MORTALITY RATES
AND SENIORS SO I'D BE
INTERESTED TO EVER DOING THE
PROPOSAL IF YOU CAN COME BACK
AND SHOW SOME STUDIES THAT
WOULD ACTUALLY SAVE MONEY MAY
NOT JUST BE IN THE PHARMACY
WHEN THEY SAVE MONEY AND-
ANOTHER DEPARTMENT LIKE
MEDICAID DOLLARS SOMETHING.
THAT WOULD BE ALWAYS BE VERY
HELPFUL- I THINK AND IN TERMS
OF THAT CONVERSATION WE WOULD
HAVE ABOUT- SHOULD BE YOU KNOW
IN TERMS OF THE FUNNY OBVIOUSLY
IT'S NOT THE ONLY REASON WE
WOULD FIND SOMETHING BUT
CERTAINLY IF THERE IF IT TURNS
OUT THAT IT WOULD SAVE US MONEY
OVER ALL THAT ALWAYS IS HELPFUL
AND I WOULD ALSO MAKE NOTE
THAT- I KNOW THAT THERE'S SOME-
SOME ISSUES THAT COME UP IN
pTERMS OF- THAT PATIENTS WHO-
WHO ARE NOT YES UNABLE TO IT
WERE NOT CONFIDENT. YEAH
OPPOSITION REPRESENTATIVE THAT
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL TO HELP
THOSE PARTICULAR PATIENTS AS
WELL SO ANYWAY DID AGAIN THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATIONS- LOOK FOR TO OF
FOR THE CONSIDERATION OF THESE-
THESE- PROPOSALS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES ADULT
PROGRAMS. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS DEBBIE THOMPSON WITH
THAT FROM THE SOCIAL SERVICES
ADULT PROGRAMS AND I CAN
RESPOND TO THE QUESTIONS THAT
WERE. WERE IN THE- AGENDA THE
FIRST ONE BEING A PLEASE
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE CASE
THAT IN FUNDING LEVELS FOR THE
I JUST LAST PROGRAM. SO THE
CURRENT YEAR- FUNDING FOR THE I
JUST AS PROGRAM TOTAL FUNDS WAS
FOURTEEN POINT EIGHT BILLION.
EIGHT MILLION FEDERAL FIVE
POINT ONE STATE AND ONE POINT
SEVEN TELL ME. THE PROJECTED
FOR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO IS TOTAL FUNDS
SIXTEEN POINT FOUR BILLION.
EIGHT POINT NINE FEDERAL FIVE
POINT EIGHT EIGHT AND ONE POINT
EIGHT COUNTY FUNDS. SO THAT'S
THE OVERVIEW OF CURRENT AND
BUDGET YEAR FOR FUNDING FOR IHS
US WITH REGARDS TO CASE LOAD
THE I JUST AS RECIPIENT
CASELOAD DOES CONTINUE TO GROW-
THE AUTHORIZED CASES AS OF
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY. SIX
HUNDRED FORTY THREE THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT
STATEWIDE. I'M AS COMPARED TO-
LAST DECEMBER OF TWENTY
NINETEEN WAS AT. 1-660-016-0006
HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX. IT
PROVIDERS- THAT THAT SERVES
THOSE RECIPIENTS A NUMBER OF
PROVIDERS ALSO CONTINUES TO
GROW AS OF DECEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY
SIX THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SIX. UP FROM THE- PRIOR
DECEMBER OF NINETEEN WHICH WAS
AT. FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED SORRY
FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY ONE
THOUSAND. SEVENTY THREE SO THAT
IS WHERE WE ARE ASKED FOR I
JUST SAYS AS FAR AS FUNDING AND
SHE SLOWED. THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS TO RESPOND- I BELIEVE
NOW WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM SAY
WHAT SIMONE. MISSING THAT
CORRECTLY. IT DID YOU WANT ME
TO COVER THE OTHER QUESTIONS
THAT YOU HAD IN THIS THIS AREA.
I BELIEVE. THEN WE HAVE SOMEONE
FROM- THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES NOW. YES THIS IS
DEBBIE FROM THE PHARMACIST OF
SERVICES YOU HAD TWO OTHER
QUESTIONS. WHEN YOU WANT TO GO
AHEAD AND DO THAT PLEASE. OKAY
IS STILL ONE WAS READ RELATED
TO THE CONTINUED GROWTH OF THE
AYE OBSESSED POPULATION AND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN TO
ADDRESS RISING COSTS WITHIN
WITHIN A I HSS- YES AS WE'VE
ALL BEEN SPEAKING ABOUT THIS
POPULATION. CONTINUES TO GROW
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE VERY- THAT
JUNE TWO THAT TO THAT SITUATION
AND IT WAS A PART OF THE MASTER
PLAN- DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW TO
LOOK AT AND ADDRESS THESE COSTS
IT WILL BE ONGOING DIALOGUE
THROUGH THAT PROCESS AS WELL AS
INTERNALLY. TO LOOK AT WAYS
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO ENSURE
THAT THESE TYPES OF SERVICES
ARE PROVIDED AND INDIVIDUALS
CAN REMAIN IN THEIR HOMES
SAFELY AND AVOID
INSTITUTIONALIZATION AND THAT
WILL BE- INTO NEED TO BE
LOOKING LOOKED AT ON. AN
ONGOING BASIS- AS FAR AS THE
DEPARTMENT ASSUMING COST
SAVINGS RUSH AVOIDING
INSTITUTIONAL CARE AS A PART OF
BUDGETING THAT WE DON'T ASSUME
COST SAVINGS THIS IS REALLY
MORE OF A COST AVOIDANCE
SITUATION AS FAR AS THOSE
INDIVIDUALS NOT HAVING TO GO
INTO INSTITUTIONAL CARE. THE
THIRD QUESTION WAS RELATED TO
THE L. A. O.'S COMMENTS AROUND-
ARE LIMITING MY AGE IS A
SERVICES- DOES THERE IS
INSTRUCTION YOU THE OPTION TO
YOU- IMPLEMENTED A 7% ACROSS
THE BOARD. REDUCTION TO BE JUST
REALLY CLEAR THAT- THAT
CURRENT. THE CURRENT BUDGET AND
THE BUDGET FOR THE FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO DEALT
INCLUDING- TAKING BACK TO-
BATCH 7% ACROSS THE BOARD
REDUCTION. AS FAR AS VIOLATING
THE ADA ANYTIME THERE IS-
IMPLEMENTATION OF REDUCTIONS
THERE'S POTENTIAL FOR SOME TYPE
OF MEDICATION THIS THIS- 7% HAS
BEEN IMPLEMENTED IN THE PAST
OBVIOUSLY WHEN WE IMPLEMENT
THESE THINGS WE DO WORK VERY
HARD TO ENSURE THAT- WE HAVE
LOOKED AT ALL OF THAT AND
BELIEVE THAT IT WAS LAWFUL THE
IMPLEMENTED. SO THAT'S- THAT'S
ALL I HAVE TO. SPEAK TO ON THAT
UNLESS FINANCE WOULD LIKE TO.
ADD ANYTHING ADDITIONAL TO
EITHER OF THOSE LAST TWO.
FURTHER TO ADD AT THIS TIME
PROPERTY ANSWER ANY QUESTION
YEAH. OKAY THANK YOU MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- IF WE CAN HERE-
FROM SOMEWHERE SIMONA MY SAYING
THAT CORRECTLY HELP ME. YOU ARE
OKAY NEED. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY NAME IS
WHITE CM AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
DRC IS JOINED BY FIFTY SEVEN
ORGANIZATIONS AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A
PERMANENT REPEAL OF THE 7% BY
HSS HOURS HI. THE I JUST AS
PROGRAM KEEPS UP CALIFORNIANS
WITH DISABILITIES INCLUDING
SENIORS AND THEIR OWN HOMES AND
SAVES TAXPAYERS HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. AS OF
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THERE ARE SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY
ONE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND
NINETY THREE CONSUMERS AND FIVE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED AND SEVEN
PROVIDERS IN THE AYE INTEREST
AS PROGRAM. 55% OF PROVIDERS
LIVE WITH THEIR CONSUMERS AND
THE LIVING DATA IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THE PROVIDER WAGES
OFTEN SUPPORT THE BASIC NEEDS
OF THE HOUSEHOLD. FOR MANY
FAMILIES WHO DEPEND ON AID TO
PROCESS INCOME TO LIVE IN CARE
FOR THEIR LOOK LEFT ONE AT HOME
RATHER THAN AN INSTITUTION BUT
CUTS REALLY MEANS DOUBLE IMPACT
IN TERMS OF LOSS OF SERVICES.
FOR A FAMILY MEMBER AS WELL AS
LOSS OF WAGES. I'VE BEEN ASKED
TO DESCRIBE THE IMPACT THAT THE
REDUCTION IN AGES JUST HOURS
WILL HAVE ON PARTICIPANTS IN
THE H. SAYS PROGRAM. AND WHILE
I'VE TOUCHED ON THIS I WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE VERY CLEAR. IF
TEMPERAMENTAL THE 7% CUT TIE
EACH SUBCLASS WOULD BE
DEVASTATING I JUST AS CONSUMERS
AND PROVIDERS ALIKE. A CONSUMER
ASSESSED AS NEEDING THE AVERAGE
NUMBER OF MONTHLY HOURS WOULD
LOSE EIGHT OF THOSE HOURS.
THOSE SERVICE HOURS ARE NEEDED
FOR FEEDING MILK PREPARATION
BAITING AND OTHER AUTHORIZED
TASKS. A CONSUMER WHO WAS
ASSESSED AS NEEDING THE MAXIMUM
NUMBER OF TWO HUNDRED. AND
EIGHTY THREE HOURS WOULD LOSE
TWENTY HOURS OF HELP PER MONTH.
MORE THAN TWO DAYS OF PERSONAL
CARE. FOR DOMESTIC SERVICES.
THE NEW FOR PERSONAL CARE SO.
IS NOT GOING AWAY BUT THE HELP
WHAT. THE 7% REDUCTION IN IT
SAYS HOURS MEANS PROVIDERS
WORKING FOR THE AVERAGE
CONSUMER WOULD LOSE A HUNDRED
AND NINETEEN DOLLARS AND FIFTY
TWO CENTS OF THEIR MONTHLY
INCOME. BAKERIES TO WAIT CHEST
MEANS CONSUMERS WILL HAVE A
MORE LIMITED SUPPLY OF HOME
CARE WORKERS MAKING IT
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO REMAIN
SAFELY IN THEIR HOMES. AND
POSSIBLY FORCING THEM AN
INSTITUTION INSTITUTIONAL CARE
SUCH AS NURSING HOMES. MANY I
JUST HAS PROVIDERS ALREADY LIVE
IN POVERTY AND ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
FOOD STAMPS AND OTHER PUBLIC
BENEFITS. BECAUSE OF THE LOSS
OF INCOME PROVIDERS MAY SEEK
WORK ELSEWHERE. CLOSING I'D
LIKE TO REMIND EVERYONE THAT
THE OSCAR LOCATION SETTLED IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN. WHAT THE
PROMISE THAT THE 7% CUT WOULD
BE PERMANENTLY RESTORED BY
TWENTY FIFTEEN. HERE WE ARE IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE COMING BACK
TO THE LEGISLATURE YET AGAIN
ASKING OUR LEGISLATIVE LEADERS
TO STAND BY THE AGREEMENT THAT
WAS MADE IN TWENTY FIFTEEN. IF
EVER THERE WAS A TIME TO STAND
BY THIS AGREEMENT IT IS TODAY.
IN A TIME WHEN WE HAVE SEEN
INDIVIDUALS RESIDING IN NURSING
HOMES AND INSTITUTIONAL
SETTINGS CONTRACT COBIT
NINETEEN AT DISPROPORTIONATE
RATES. MANY WHO ARE NO LONGER
WITH US TODAY WE REALLY SHOULD
BE WORKING FULL TIME TO FURTHER
INVEST IN THE- IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES PROGRAM.
AND OTHER PROGRAMS THAT HELP
INDIVIDUALS LIVE SAFELY AT HOME.
AT THE VERY LEAST FOR OUR
PURPOSES TODAY WE SHOULD
PERMANENTLY SUSPEND THE 7% HI
THAT HAS BEEN LOOMING OVER THIS
PROGRAM FOR FAR TOO LONG.
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
AND ARE FIFTY SEVEN PARTNER
ORGANIZATIONS CALL ON OR
LEGISLATIVE LEADERS TO
PRIORITIZE THE HEALTH IN WITH
WELL BEING OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE DURING THIS PANDEMIC
AND INTO THE FUTURE WHAT OTHER
CHALLENGES MEET MAY AWAIT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DEPARTMENT FINANCE ANYTHING
FROM YOU. LOL. THANK AYE I
WOULD JUST WANT TO FLAG THAT
OUR OFFICE RECENTLY RELEASED A
WRITE UP IN WHICH WE REVIEWED
I'M BASIC PROGRAM TRENDS WITHIN
THE PROGRAM INCLUDING GROPING
CASELOAD HOURS PER CASE AND
WAGES AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY
SIGNIFICANT TURCA CONCERNS- WE
WOULD NOTE THAT REGION JUST
NOTICED THAT SOME PROGRAM
TRENDS WERE SLIGHTLY IMPACTED
IN THE EARLIER MONTHS OF COLD
BED- SOME OF THE PROGRAM TRENDS
HAVE RETURNED TO CREE COVE IN
NINETEEN LEVELS- WHILE OTHERS-
MAY NOT HAVE FULLY- FOR EXAMPLE
WE NOTICED THAT THE GROWTH IN
PAID CASELOAD WHILE WE'RE STILL
CONTINUING TO SEE A GROWTH IT'S
A SLIGHTLY SLOWER GROWTH RATE-
RELATIVE TO PRIOR YEARS. ON
THAT STARTED IN THE FIRST FEW
MONTHS IN COPING NINETEEN AND
AGAIN WE HAVE NO CONCERNS- WHAT
THE SLIGHT CHANGES IN PROGRAM
TRANSFER JUST FLAG AS WE WILL
CONTINUE TO MONITOR ON THESE
TRENDS AND PROVIDE ANY UPDATES
TO THE LEGISLATURE AS THEY
BECOME AVAILABLE ADDITIONALLY-
I WOULD JUST WANT TO- FLAG-
OTHER COMMENTS WE NEED AS IT
RELATES TO THE 7% RESTORATION
AGAIN UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL AND- HE IS
PROPOSING TO BOTH MAINTAIN AND
EXTENDED THE- SUSPENSION
LANGUAGE AS IT AS IT RELATES TO
THE 7% RESTORATION- A- SIMILAR
TO. THE EIGHTY SEE ISSUE RECKON
OF THE- BRIDGE. THE NEW BUT
BILL SAYS- AS TREATS. AN
ONGOING I JUST SAYS SERVICE
COSTS. AS TEMPORARY. SO WHAT
THAT ESSENTIALLY WOULD MEAN
THEN BY REJECTING THAT IS AGAIN
UNDER CURRENT LAW WE WOULD
JUST- AND HERE TO THE EXISTING
SUSPENSION LANGUAGE AND THAT
CALCULATION WOULD BE DONE IN
MAY AND AGAIN OUR OFFICE BASED
OFF OF RECENT REVENUES- IT'S
LIKELY THAT BACK CALCULATION
WOULD SHOW THAT WE DO HAVE
ENOUGH FUNDS- TO- SUPPORT THE
I. HSS. SUSPENSION IN THE FOR
PAY AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE SO THEN
THAT WOULD HAVE THE EFFECT OF
PERMANENTLY RESTORING I JUST US
HOURS ARE PROVIDING FUNDING
NEEDED TO DO THAT- HE SAID THAT
THE LEGISLATURE DOES. REJECT
THE SUSPENSION LANGUAGE WE ALSO
SUGGEST CLEANING UP STATUTE-
WHICH CURRENTLY TIES THE
RESTORATION OF THE SERVICE
HOURS TO THE MANAGED CARE
ORGANIZATION TAX AND THIS
CLEANUP WOULD AGAIN JUST
FURTHER ENSURE THAT BY
REJECTING THE SUSPENSION
LANGUAGE THE 7% RESTORATION IS
MAINTAINED ON AN ONGOING BASIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- YEAH I
WOULD CAN CURRENT INCOME WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE NUMBERS AND
INCREASING LIKE WE DO AND TO
THINK ABOUT. A MEETING SUFFERS
AND CUTS JUST DOESN'T DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE AND WE'RE NOT
GOING TO SEE THIS POPULATION
DECREASING I THINK. AS MY
GENERATION CONTINUES TO- THE
BOOMERS CONTINUE TO AGE- AND AS
OUR SOCIETIES CONTINUE TO
CHANGE WHERE PEOPLE AREN'T
LIVING IN THE SAME NUCLEAR
LITTLE ENVIRONMENT LIKE THEY
USED TO BUT THEY'RE SPREAD OUT.
MORE PEOPLE HAVE TO WORK MORE
FAMILY MEMBERS HAVE TO WORK.
AND I WOULD CERTAINLY SAY AS A
MEMBER OF THE LATINO CAUCUS WE
ESPECIALLY HAS BEEN HARD HIT
WITH THIS- AS A MEMBER OF THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS WE KNOW THAT
MORE WOMEN END UP. BEING CARE
GIVERS A LOT OF THEIR LIFE AND
THEN AT THE VERY END OF THEIR
LIFE AND UP ALONE HAND IN
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
THEMSELVES WITHOUT. PROPER CARE
AND AS A MEMBER OF THE LGBT
CAUCUS WE KNOW OUR LGBT
BROTHERS AND SISTERS SPECIALLY.
ON THOSE PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE
EVEN MORE AT RISK OF BEING
ALONE WHEN THEY'RE OLD AND
WITHOUT THE SUPPORT. STAFF TO
MAINTAIN THEM AND AS WAS POINT
OUT WE KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENED IN
OUR- CONGREGATE SETTINGS.
DURING THIS PANDEMIC WHERE
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN. SOMETIMES YOU
KNOW YOU'RE TRAPPED AND THE
PANDEMIS COME THROUGH AND MORE
PEOPLE HAVE DIED AND A LOT OF
THOSE WHO HAVE DIED AS AS I
THINK WE'VE ALL SEEN. HAVE BEEN
SOME OF THE POOREST AND PEOPLE
OF COLOR AND PEOPLE TO LEAST
ACCESS SO THAT IS NOT A GOOD
REFLECTION ON US AND WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO DO BETTER. AT
PROVIDING THE SERVICE. OKAY
THANKS VERY MUCH- SO THAT'S THE
QUESTION FOR FARM SOCIAL
SERVICE AGAIN PRESHEAF YEAR
PRESENTATION YOU DID MENTION
THAT- IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL YOUR QUOTE NAT ARE
SUSPENDING THE 7% CUT FOR TWO
YEARS IS. I REALIZE WE PASS A
BUDGET EACH YEAR BUT- USE THAN
APPLYING THAT WHEN YOU'RE DOING
OUT YOUR CALCULATIONS ON YOUR
THREE THERE'S AUTOMATIC 7% CUT.
THIS IS DEBBIE FINANCING ANSWER
THAT IF THERE'S A REMOTE CHANCE
THAT. SYDNEY IF YOU WANT TO
THAT'S OUR NON. AS OF RIGHT NOW
THE LANGUAGE STATES THAT ON THE
SUSPENSION WOULD GO INTO EFFECT
ON DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO OKAY SO THERE IS A
YOUR PLANE CAUGHT. CORRECT OKAY
SO I THINK- THAT THAT'S
TROUBLESOME- BE INTERESTING
DURING THE JUSTIFICATIONS THAT
BUT I GUESS THE SECOND QUESTION
AND ACTUALLY- THIS. WELL IT.
SOUNDS IN FOR DEPARTURE SERVICE
IT DO YOU CALL THE- U. T. TO
YOU CAREFULLY SAID TRYING TO
CORRECT THIS BY SAYING IT'S NOT
A COST SAVINGS OF THE COSTA
WAIT AND SEE. AND I DON'T SPEND
TOO MUCH TIME PARSING LANGUAGE
BUT- TO ME IT'S STILL A COST
SAVINGS BECAUSE I MEAN. IT
BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT
NOW YOU WEEK WE CAN TRY TO HIDE
THE MEDICAL PROGRAMS IN THE
NURSING HOME PROGRAM FROM
PEOPLE MAYBE THEY WON'T SIGN UP
FOR MEDICARE ONLY FIND OUT
ABOUT IT. BUT THAT'S AN
ENTITLEMENT SO. IF SOMEONE IS
NOT ABLE TO GET THERE. SIR I
HSS SERVICES. YEAH THEY NEED
THEM NOW NEED TO CARE- WELL
FIRST OF ALL I DON'T THINK IT'S
GOOD POLICY WE DENY IT TO THEM
ALL TOGETHER I MEAN THAT'S
OBVIOUSLY QUOTED POLICY OPTION
ONE THAT I WOULD NOT ACCEPT.
BUT AT LEAST FOR RIGHT NOW A AS
I UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY UNDER
CURRENT POLICIES DALY BEAT AND
ABLE TO- GET NURSING HOME CARE.
IS THAT CORRECT- MY WRONG.
THERE'S NOTHING THAT PREVENTS
ANYBODY FROM GETTING NURSING
HOME CARE ALL ALL I WAS REALLY
TRYING TO SPEAK TO WAS THAT MY
BUDGETING PERSPECTIVE WE'RE NOT
MAKING ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT COST
SAVINGS- BECAUSE- CALCULATING
COST AVOIDANCE BECOMES MORE
COMPLEX- OKAY WELL WE- DIDN'T
HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH WHAT
SERVICES INDIVIDUALS CAN ACCESS
IT. IF YOU TO THE BALLOT THAT
WAS NOT THE INTENT OKAY ALL
RIGHT ALL RIGHT WELL WE DON'T
LET'S NOT SPEND TOO MUCH TIME
PARSING WORDS BUT I KNOW WE HAD
A REPORT PREVIOUSLY SCENARIO
SEVERAL YEARS AGO. SHOW THAT
ACTUALLY- BUT A CALL COST
AVOIDANCE OR COST SAVINGS THAT
BASICALLY- WE- YEAH. TO I HSS
AND AGAIN YOU KNOW THE
CASELOADS GOING UP BECAUSE THE
MORE PEOPLE WHO NEED THE
SERVICES. WOULD BE SPENDING
MORE ON INSTITUTIONAL CARE NOT
SAYING THAT EVERYONE AND I JUST
AS IF THEY WERE YOU KNOW CAN
GET IT WOULD END UP IN THE
SEASONAL CARE BUT A GOOD
PORTION WOULD WHICH IS OF
COURSE A LOT MORE EXPENSIVE
THAN ACTUALLY ARE SPENDING
WOULD GO UP QUITE A BIT. DONE
SO I JUST WANT TO KEEP THAT IN
MIND AS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
SUSPENSION. THE OTHER THING IS
THAT I DO APPRECIATE IN THE
ALLEY- REPORT ON PAGE TEN THE A
CHART SHOWING STATEWIDE AVERAGE
IHS US EARLY HOURLY WAGE AND
HOW IS WE'VE GOTTEN CLOSE. FIND
OUT BASICALLY THE LINE BETWEEN
THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE IN THE
STATEWIDE AVERAGE HSS HOURLY
WAGES SENSUALLY HE ARE ALMOST
OVERLAPPING- AND I THINK THAT
TELLS YOU THAT- IN TERMS THE
AMOUNT OF SPACE YOU KNOW. HOW
MUCH WE'RE PAYING AND IT'S-
BASICALLY I MEAN. OUR OWN LAWS
ARE REQUIRED REQUIRING THE
WAGES TO GO UP FOR APPROPRIATE
REASONS AND I PROBABLY VOTED
FOR THOSE LAWS- BUT- IT'S AN
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT THAT WE CAN
CUT. WAGES AND WE SHOULD OR
SHOULD CUT WAGES AND THEN SO
THE QUESTION IS THAT IF WE DO
THE 7% CUT I GUESS IT'S 7%
HOURS WE JUST HEARD TESTIMONY
ABOUT WHAT THAT MEANS SO. IF
SOMEONE ACTUALLY AND I PRESUME
WHEN PEOPLE GET SERVICES
THROUGH I JUST AS WE DO DO AN
EVALUATION NOW TO EVALUATE
THAT. THERE NEEDS FOR EIGHTY
ALSO FOR IT SO WHAT DO WE
EXPECT TO HAPPEN WHEN IF WE DO
A 7% CUT I MEAN IT'S GOING TO
BE S. COTTON HOURS WE CAN'T
LEGALLY GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE
PASSED THE MINIMUM WAGE
ACTUALLY CUT THEIR SALARY BY
SEVEN PERCENT- ESPECIALLY SINCE
THE TWO LINES ARE ESSENTIALLY
OVERLAPPING- SO. WHAT DOES WHAT
DOES THE DEPARTMENT AND AGAIN-
OUR FINANCE THINGS GOING TO
HAPPEN AND IF WE DO IF AND. IN
TWO YEARS WE DO A 7% CUT. THIS
PERCENT CUT IS TO AUTHORIZED
HOURS IT DOESN'T CUT. RIGHT
RIGHT I THINK WHAT THE INTENT
OF THE PERSON I WAS SPEAKING
WAS TO SAY THAT IF THERE'S
FEWER HOURS THE PAY OF THE
PROVIDER IF THEY DON'T FIND AT
OTHER NO THAT'S IT OKAY SO I
GET THAT BUT NOT BUT LET'S JUST
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE CLIENT. SO
THE CLIENT YOU'VE ASSESSED THE
SAY THEY NEED THEY HAVE THESE
NEEDS THEY CAN'T FEED
THEMSELVES OR WHATEVER CAN'T BE
THEMSELVES OR BECAUSE OF THEIR
DISABILITY. THEN WE TAKE AWAY.
YOU KNOW HALF A DAY A DAY HEARD
UP TO TWO DAYS OF SERVICES. SO
DO THEY NOT EAT THOSE DAYS I
MEAN WHAT WE EXPECT TO HAPPEN.
THE PERSON FINANCES ARE HAND UP
THERE. OKAY HI SARAH HANSON
ANTENNA WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AGAIN I THINK I JUST
WANT TO REITERATE HERE WE
RECOGNIZE THE DIFFICULTY OF THE
SITUATION WE ARE YOU KNOW.
COMMITTED TO REASSESSING AS WE
GO THROUGH AND THEY ARE NOT
FORECAST THE STRUCTURAL
NONTERMINAL TIRE WE ARE DOING
THIS- THAT'S NOT GOING BASIS
DIFFICULT OF A CONVERSATION AS
I WOULD WANT TO REITERATE. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES INCLUDE.
THAT LET'S SEE. NINETY NINE
NINE HUNDRED NINETY FOUR POINT
FOUR MILLION. TOTAL FINE OF
WHICH FOUR HUNDRED FORTY NINE
POINT EIGHT MILLION AS GENERAL-FUND. TO RESTORE THIS OUR
PRESENT THROUGH DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO SO JUST
REENTERING THE FACT. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES INCLUDE
THE RESTORATION AT THIS POINT
FOR OKAY. AND FIRST OF ALL I
APPRECIATE THAT- BUT AS I
POINTED OUT IN OTHER AREAS FOR
EXAMPLE WE DON'T HAVE A 7% CUT
ACROSS THE BOARD IN THE BUDGET
FOR EVERYONE ELSE FOR EXAMPLE
TRANSPORTATION WE DON'T TELL
PEOPLE WHO BUILD OUR ROADS.
THAT BY THE WAY IF THE ECONOMY
ISN'T SO GOOD YOU GET SAID
ALUMAX 7% CUT IN YOUR CONTRACT
TO BUILD WHATEVER ROAD
REBUILDING OR OTHER TYPES OF
THINGS ARE IT PROJECTS RIGHT DO
WE HAVE IN OUR CONTRACTS 27%
CUT AUTOMATIC CUT FOR YOUR I.
T. PROJECT NOW WE DON'T HAVE TO
GO BACK IN AND RENEGOTIATE
CONTRACT NOW I TELL YOU THE
ECONOMY IS BADLY IF I WOULD GO
BACK HEY BY THE WAY. NO HE DO
FERTILITY BROCHURE SHOWING CASH
BUT I'M NOT SURE WHY. HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES INCLUDING
THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM. WE
NEED TO TELL PEOPLE. THAT BY
THE WAY. WE'RE GONNA BUILD THIS
CUT IN AND THEN WHAT HAPPENS IS
EACH YEAR WE'RE GOING TO GO AND
SAY WELL YOU DON'T WANNA DO
THIS YEAR. BUT IT'S STILL GOING
TO HANG OVER YOU. WERE NOT
GOING TO DO NEXT YEAR BUT IT'S
GONNA HANG OVER YOU. ESPECIALLY
SINCE IT'S A CORE SERVICE
TONIGHT THAT THAT'S WHY GOES
BACK TO MY QUESTION OF WHAT
WHAT YOU SUPPOSED TO DO WHEN
YOU DECIDE TO PULL THE CAT.
RIGHT WITH- YOU KNOW IT'S THE
PERSON NOT SUPPOSED TO EAT FOR
A DAY. IT'S ENOUGH TO GET PAID
FOR A DAY OR TWO DAYS OR
WHATEVER DEBT REPRESENTS IN
TERMS OF HOURS. BECAUSE AFTER
ALL DIDN'T END UP IN THE
PROGRAM. BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
HAVE THOSE NEEDS IN FACT WE
EVEN REQUIRED OR FOR YOU TO.
GET THE SERVICES THAT. YOU HAVE
TO DEMONSTRATE YOU HAVE YOU DID
YOU NEED THE SERVICES. I MEAN
WE DO IT'S NOT LIKE ANYONE CAN
JUST SIGN UP FOR IT WITHOUT
HAVING TO GET AN ASSESSMENT
DONE. AND SO TO ME. IT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE. TO TAKE A CORE
PROGRAM. THAT IN BUT WHICH BY
THE WAY IN THE END COLLECTIVELY
AND WE DON'T THE CASE BY CASE
WOULD ACTUALLY SAVE US MONEY
BECAUSE THE ALTERNATIVE IS THAT
THEY END UP IN INSTITUTIONAL
CARE. FINANCIALLY BECAUSE WE
PRIDE REALLY COULDN'T STOP
FEEDING PEOPLE OR STOP IT YOU
KNOW IT SAID IT. I'LL BE PEOPLE
SELF. EVENTUALLY NEED TO GO
SOMEWHERE ELSE. AT LEAST A
PORTION OF THEM SO. SO THAT'S
TO ME SO AGAIN- THAT'S I THINK
THE FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM AND WHY
IS IT ONLY IN HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES INCLUDING THIS PROGRAM
WHICH IS SO CRITICAL. TO
PEOPLE'S CARE. THAT WE KEEP
THIS ESSENTIALLY CUT HOVERING
OVER THEM. RIGHT I MEAN IS THIS
THIRD YOU YOUR BUDGETING OR.
SO YES THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ACTUALLY IT'S INTERESTING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR KEEPING
THINGS AS YOU KNOW FOR PUTTING
THE MONEY THERE BUT MAYBE MAYBE
SHOULD TAKE THAT'S WHAT WE
SHOULD EXPECT. INSTEAD OF-
SAYING THAT. BECAUSE WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IS TWO YEARS
LATER WE HAVE TO. PRAY THAT IT
WON'T HAPPEN YOU KNOW. AT THAT
POINT IN TIME. AND IS THAT THE
RIGHT WAY TO DO THINGS AFTER WE
DON'T DO THAT FOR OTHER
DEPARTMENTS IN THE STATE. AND
WE DO THAT FOR OTHER THINGS AND
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES BUT
NOT FOR OTHER DEPARTMENTS WE
DON'T HAVE A COTTON AND SAID IT
WAS A SPENDING CUT. HIM
BUILDING A 7% CUT ACROSS. OTHER
DEPARTMENTS. UNLESS I'M WRONG I
MEAN I DON'T KNOW I'VE I'VE-
CAN'T YOU KNOW I MAINLY DO THE
SUB COMMITTEE BUT I DO PAY
ATTENTION TO THE OTHER PARTS OF
THE BUDGET. IS THERE AN EXAMPLE
WHERE THAT'S BEING DONE
ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE BUDGET
OUTSIDE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. W. PARTNER FINANCE.
THANK YES ANYTIME OUT APARTMENT
OF FINANCE I WOULD JUST NOTE
SINCE THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT THERE HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAM
INVESTMENTS THESE PROGRAMS
SINCE THAT'S THE DESTRUCTION A
BALANCED BUDGET TO SUPPORT ON
AN ONGOING BASIS SO THE
SUSPENSION FRAMEWORK IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
ADDRESSES IMBALANCE AGAIN
SENATOR PAT AND WE FULLY
RECOGNIZE THIS IS A DIFFICULT
ISSUE ONLY WELCOME CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON THIS PROPOSAL.
OKAY AND- I APPRECIATE THAT'S
THE ANSWER YOU HAVE TO GIVE ME
A AND- THE- BUT I CERTAINLY
HOPE THAT WE CAN HAVE A YOU
KNOW A FULL DISCUSSION AND HE
SAID REALLY WHAT IS A REAL
ALTERNATIVE RIGHT I MEAN OF
COURSE IS A BUDGET SO CAN WE
TALK ABOUT MONEY AND NUMBERS
AND I KNOW THAT BUT ALSO WHAT
DOES THAT TRANSLATE INTO- WHAT
WE DON'T DO IT- THE OTHER
QUESTION I ALSO HAVE IS THAT-
AGAIN- IS- IT IN THIS. PROPOSED
IT'S ADDRESS BUT I THINK THE
ISSUES COME UP AND SO I
UNDERSTAND CERTAIN THINGS ARE
EXPIRING FRIDAY JUSTICE IN
TERMS OF COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS AND SO FORTH- YOU
NOTED THAT THE SPLIT OF MONEY
BETWEEN. THE STATE AND THE
COUNTY THAT AGREEMENT. AS WELL.
AT SO WHAT WHAT'S THE STATUS
OF. OF THE DECISION IN REGARDS
TO- HOW THEY'LL BE ADDRESSED
BECAUSE I IF I REMEMBER RECALL
HOWEVER MANY YEARS. EXACTLY
WHICH SURELY MADE THAT
AGREEMENT I BELIEVE ACCESS
EXPIRES THIS YEAR. SO IS THAT
GOING TO BE ADDRESSED IN THIS
BUDGET. THE FINANCE RECRUITMENT
YES. WITHOUT THE COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES AND C. W. DHSS-
THE NEEDS FOR ITS ONGOING AND
RESOURCES DO YOU OR THE-
AGREEMENTS. SO THAT'S OKAY I'M
NOT SURE WHAT THE ANSWER MEANT
SO- IS IT IS GOING TO BE
ADDRESSED IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
THEN. YES WE'RE CURRENTLY
EVALUATING THAT OKAY. BUT YOU
DON'T EITHER IS NO PROPOSAL AT
THIS POINT TIME. NO NOT AT THIS
OKAY AND- WHEN WE TRY BY SOON
WE GET IT WELL WHEN DO WE
EXPECT TO GET THE PROPOSAL I
PROVIDE PRESUME AT THE LATEST
MAY REVISE BUT WE ALSO NEED
TIME FOR CONCERTS IT FOR CAN.
TO CONSIDER IT SO. RIGHT RIGHT
CURRENT STATUTE. SORRY THIS IS
DANNY WITH DSS MY CURRENT
STATUTE- AT THE TIME THAT
MINIMUM WAGE GOES TO FIFTEEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR LOCALLY
BARGAINED WAGES AND BENEFIT
INCREASES. CAPS THAT WE'VE HAD
OF WHAT THE STATE WILL
PARTICIPATE IN IS REMOVED
THERE'S NO LONGER A CALF. BUT
THE COST OF THE INCREASE IS
SPLIT BETWEEN THE COUNTIES AND
THE STATE- 65% COUNTY AND 35%
STATE SO THAT. THE AB PORTION
THAT THAT COUNTY AND STATE HAVE
IS SLIPPED AT THAT POINT IN
TIME THAT'S MY CURRENT STATUTE
I THINK A NAM WAS TALKING ABOUT
THERE'S CONTINUED DIALOGUE
WITH. GOING ON OKAY. OKAY AND I
THINK- CERTAINLY INTERESTED IN
HEARING FROM- THE- THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING UNITS IN
THE COUNTY IS ABOUT- THAT THAT
ABOUT ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE I KNOW THAT THERE'S A
PROPOSALS WELL- BUT WE EIGHT I
JUST WANNA BE SURE YOU PUT A
PIN ON THAT ISSUE BECAUSE I
KNOW WHEN IT COMES TO BE
REVISED WE OFTEN HAVE. ARE
SHORT ON TIME AND WE HAVE TO
RUSH BUT WE'LL BE SURE WE HAVE
THAT WE HAVE SUFFICIENT TIME TO
MORE THOROUGHLY DISCUSSED THIS
ISSUE BECAUSE IT'S NOT
ACTUALLY. TECHNICALLY THE FINAL
PART IS THE GENDER BUT I KNOW
IT'S GOING TO COME UP AND CAN
BE VERY IMPORTANT. I WOULD HOPE
THAT WOULD MANDATE OKAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OKAY I THINK
WE'LL MOVE ON NOW. TO
ELECTRONIC VISIT VERIFICATION
DISCONTINUATION. HEY THIS IS
DEBBIE THOMPSON AGAIN- FROM THE
SOCIAL SERVICES ADULT PROGRAMS
AND I AM GOING TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT YOUR QUESTIONS AROUND
ELECTRONIC VISIT VERIFICATION
BCP- I'M ACTUALLY GONNA FLIP
THAT ORDER AND GIVE YOU AN
UPDATE OF KIND OF WHERE THINGS
ARE- AND THEN TALK ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL FOR THE CONTINUED
RESOURCES. SO THAT THE
ELECTRONIC VISIT VERIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS WHICH BECAME LAW-
THE END OF FEDERAL LAW AT THE
END OF TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE HAD A VERY
ROBUST STAKEHOLDER PROCESS- DID
CAME UP WITH AN APPROACH FOR.
DOING THE ELECTRONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION FOR I JUST US AND
WPCS PROVIDERS OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS FELT COMFORTABLE
WITH AND BEGAN IMPLEMENTATION
OF THAT- THAT APPROACH- AFTER
RECEIVING- APPROVALS FOR OUR- I
THE END OF PLANNING TO. BY THE-
BY GOVERNMENT- WE BEGAN THAT
PILOT WITH L. A. COUNTY IN JULY
OF NINETEEN AND THEN BEGAN
IMPLEMENTING- THAT SYSTEM A
STATEWIDE IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY AS OF THE END OF THE
YEAR WE HAVE AND CURRENTLY WE
HAVE. OVER 98% OF OUR
RECIPIENTS AND PROVIDERS WHO
ARE ENROLLED. IN ONE OF THE
ELECTRONIC OPTIONS EITHER THE
ONLINE OR THE TELEPHONIC OPTION
WE'VE HAD A VERY SUCCESSFUL-
THE ROLLOUT AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF THAT- IT. IN AUGUST OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WE DID GET
SOME FURTHER GUIDANCE THAT WAS
RELEASED BY- CMS TALKING ABOUT
MEETING THE REQUIREMENTS OF EDV
AND INDUSTRY AIDED- DISCUSSIONS
WITH THEM TO DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT THAT IMPACTED. OUR
APPROACH AND- THAT WENT ON FOR
QUITE QUITE SOME TIME AND WE
HAVE NOW RECEIVED FROM THEM-
CLARITY. THAT THEY- THEY HAVE
TO US THAT ARE SYSTEM APPROACH
NEEDS TO BE MODIFIED IN ORDER
TO FULLY MEET THE EBV
REQUIREMENTS- WHAT NEEDS TO BE.
MODIFIED IS THAT. PROVIDE NON
LIVE IN PROVIDERS HAVE TO CHECK
IN AND CHECK OUT IN THE SYSTEM
AT THE TIME THEY BEGIN SERVICE
AND SERVICE AND AFTER THOSE TWO
POINTS IN TIME THEIR LOCATION
HAS TO BE ELECTRONICALLY
CAPTURE. WE CURRENTLY IN OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM DO COLLECT THE
INFORMATION BUT IT'S NOT IN
REAL TIME AND IT'S NOT USING-
GPS OR- A METHOD THAT THE- THAT
THAT CMS HAS DETERMINED NEEDS
THAT THE REQUIREMENT. SO
THEREFORE WE HAVE TO MAKE AN
UPDATE TO THAT SYSTEM WE DID
BEGAN BEGAN HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS
ABOUT THE NEED TO DO THIS
CHANGE IN IN THE FALL AMISH AND
WE HAVE ALSO RECEIVED
ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE FROM CMS
BATCH WE ARE ALLOWED TO EXCLUDE
LIVE IN PROVIDERS FROM THE EBV
REQUIREMENTS ALTOGETHER. SO
PART OF OUR DISCUSSION IN THE
FALL WAS THAT THE STATE MADE
THE DECISION TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH EXCLUDING LIVIN PROVIDERS
WE SHARED THAT WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE METHOD BY
WHICH WE WOULD. BE ABLE TO DO
THAT WITH PROVIDERS AND THAT'S
STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITY AND THAT
WAS IMPLEMENTED IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO LIVE IN
PROVIDERS ARE NO LONGER
REQUIRED TO DO THE EASY THE
REQUIREMENTS THEY ARE STILL
USING AN ELECTRONIC MATHIS
THERE EIHER- USING ONLINE OR-
TELEPHONIC METHODS FOR
SUBMITTING THEIR TIME. AT
HOWEVER THEY DO NOT HAVE TO
ANSWER THE ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OF START TIME AND TIME AND
LOCATION WHEN THEY ARE ENSURING
THAT INFOR. INFORMATION INTO
THE SYSTEM. FOR NON LIVE IN
PROVIDE. WE DID TALK ABOUT ONE
OPTION WITH STAKEHOLDERS- WHICH
IN THE FALL WHICH WAS AROUND-
YOU UTILIZING AN OUT AND OUT.
THAT WOULD BE UTILIZED A GPS
TYPE FUNCTIONALITY CAPTURING-
LOCATION COORDINATES AT THOSE
TWO POINTS AND TIMES THAT I
SPOKE TO- OBVIOUSLY AS YOU'RE
PROBABLY WELL AWARE ARE
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE HAD LOTS OF
CONCERNS ABOUT- GPS AS AN
OPTION. AND SO WE ARE
CONTINUING TO EXPLORE WITH CMS
WHAT. OTHER ALTERNATIVES WE MAY
BE ABLE TO OFFER FOR MEETING
THIS REQUIREMENT THAT WOULD NOT
INCLUDE GPS DOES JUST THAT IS
WHERE THE POINT IN THE PROCESS
WHERE WE'RE AT NOW. WE ARE
INTERESTED IN AND IN SEEING
WHAT MAY HAPPEN UNDER THE NEW
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATIONABOUT
FLEXIBILITIES IN THIS AREA- AND
WE ARE EXPLORING THAT AND ONCE
WE HAVE MORE CLARITY ABOUT WHAT
OTHER LTERNATIVES THAT THAT
MAY WE MAY BE ABLE TO MAKE
AVAILABLE. TO OUR PROVIDERS AND
RECIPIENTS IN THIS IN THIS- EBV
IN MEETING THE CD REQUIREMENT-
THEN IT WE WILL BE RE ENGAGING
THE STAKEHOLDERS TO TALK
THROUGH THOSE DIFFERENT OPTIONS
AND COME TO DECISIONS ABOUT HOW
WE WILL BE MOVING FORWARD. AND
WILL THEN BEGIN IMPLEMENTATION.
OF THOSE CHANGES. FROM WHAT WE
ABOUT- ABOUT THESE TYPES OF
KAFR CAPTURING THIS
INFORMATION- WE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THE SYSTEM CHANGES WILL BE
NECESSARILY. TAKEN TAKE A LONG
TIME OR BE SIGNIFICANT HOWEVER
WHAT IT WILL TAKE TIME AND BE
VERY CRITICAL IS ENSURING THAT
THE NON LIVE IN PROVIDERS ARE
CLEARLY- INFORMED AND PROVIDED
TRAINING AND SUPPORT AROUND-
HOW TO UTILIZE THE SYSTEM WITH
THOSE CHANGES AND SO THAT WOULD
BE THE PRIMARY FOCUS. OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE CHANGES
ONCE WE DECIDE. WHAT DIRECTION
WE WILL BE GOING SO THAT IS
WHERE WE'RE AT IN THE PROCESS.
BECAUSE OF THOSE CHANGES. WE
ARE REQUESTING THAT ARE LIMITED
TERM POSITIONS THAT. WE HAVE
SHE'D SUPPORT THESE ACTIVITIES
ON THE- CONTINUE FOR ANOTHER
YEAR IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT WE
PROVIDE ALL THE NECESSARY RISKS
ARE SUPPORT AND- IN MAKING
THESE CHANGES ON THOSE
POSITIONS AND QUESTION THREE
THOSE POSITIONS WILL WORK ALSO
BEING UTILIZED TO SUPPORT THE
MANDATE FOR. PAYROLL PAYROLL
CARDS OR DIRECT DEPOSIT TO BE
UTILIZED TO RECEIVE PAYMENT BY
THE PROVIDERS AND WE'VE REALLY
ROLLED BACK MANDATE OUT
SIMULTANEOUSLY AND IN
CONJUNCTION WITH OUR EBV
TRAINING AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
THAT SYSTEM- AND THAT HAS BEEN
A VERY SUCCESSFUL APPROACH-
THAT WE HAVE ABOUT 75% OF-
PROVIDERS- THAT ARE ALREADY
ENROLLED. IN A DIRECT DEPOSIT
MESSAGE TO RECEIVE THEIR THEIR
PAYMENT- COMBINING THAT USE OF
AN ELECTRONIC SUBMISSION OF
TIME AND AN ELECTRONIC- PROCESS
FOR RECEIVING PAYMENT HAS LED
TO PROVIDERS BEING PAID WITHIN
THREE OR FOUR DAYS OF
SUBMISSION OF THEIR TIME WHICH
HAS BEEN AND IT AT A VERY
POSITIVE IMPACT TO OUR
PROVIDERS AND LEAD TO A LOT OF
TO SUCCESS. IN IN THE MEETING
THAT A NEW MANDATE AND IN
QUESTION FOR IT ASKED ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT- ZACKS. THANK
THAT MANDATE IS ONE TWO TWO ONE
AND DO WE X. PROVIDERS TO HAVE
BEEN TRANSITIONED BY THAT DATE
AS I SAID ABOUT 75% OF
PROVIDERS HAVE ALREADY
TRANSITIONS TO AN ELECTRONIC-
MATHIS SAID AB EITHER DIRECT
DEPOSIT OR A CARD FOR RECEIVING
THEIR PAYMENT- HOWEVER THAT
STATUTE ALSO ALLOWS FOR.
ADJUSTING BACK DATE BASED ON
THE STATUS OF THE EVG OUR
SYSTEM AND WHERE WE ARE WITH
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT'S
REQUIREMENTS AND SO BASED ON
WHERE WE ARE WITH THAT WE ARE
LOOKING AT A POTENTIAL OF
MOVING BACK TO EAT. OUT AND
WILL BE- COMMUNICATING AS-
FINAL RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
HAPPENING. IN THAT ERA. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ANYTHING. LMAO DO YOU
HAVE SOMETHING TO ADD TO THIS
ONE. HELLO PLEASE HEY. JACKIE
BRUCE YEAH WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST OFFICE WE WOULD JUST
SAY THAT- WE REVIEWED THE
PROPOSAL AND HAVE NO CONCERN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPARENTLY
CONCERNED WITH THIS BILL WILL
GET TO THIS REMOVE ONTO ISSUE
NUMBER THREE. SS I SS P. YOUR
MUTE MISS THOMPSON. GET TAKE
YOURSELF OFF MUTE GOT IT WOULD
YOU SORRY. IT'S GOING TO MY
OTHER DOCUMENTS- STILL IN
RELATIONSHIP QUESTIONS ON SS I
SS HE THE FIRST ONE BEING
CASELOAD AND FUNDING LEVELS FOR
SSI AND S. S. P. SO- THAT
CURRENT CASELOAD- FOR SSI S. S.
P. I'M GONNA START SORRY MR
WITH THE BUDGET. THE ESTIMATED
BUDGET FOR THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE YEAR WAS NINE
POINT EIGHT BILLION ARM TWO
POINT SEVEN ONE BILLION OF THAT
BEING THE S. S. P. PORTION- FOR
THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO YEAR
ESTIMATED BUDGET IS AGAIN AT
NINE POINT EIGHT BILLION. TWO
POINT SIX NINE BILLION OF THAT
BEING THE ACCESS- HE OR SHE
CAN. DE UM CASELOAD FOR SSI S.
S. P. DOES CONTINUE TO DECLINE
SITE SLIGHTLY- IT. IS IT HAD
BEEN. IN TWO. FOURTEEN ABOUT
ONE POINT THREE MILLION AND
WE'RE JUST UNDER ONE POINT TWO
MILLION- PROJECTED IN JUNE OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. SO WE HAVE
ON ON A NUMBER OF OCCASIONS
pLEGISLATIVE STAFF AROUND SOME
OF THE FACTORS IMPACTING THIS
CASE LOAD AND ITS DECLINE- AND
I ARE HAPPY TO DISCUSS THOSE IF
YOU'RE INTERESTED- AT THIS TIME.
OTHERWISE WE WILL MOVE TO YOUR
NEXT QUESTION PLEASE PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
REGARDING THIS STATE STIMULUS
PAYMENTS TO SS I SS HE
RECIPIENTS WE HAVE REACHED OUT
TO SSA TO DETERMINE IF THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO. ISSUE A
PAYMENT ON OUR BEHALF TO ****
I. S. P. RECIPIENTS THE SIX
HUNDRED DOLLAR PAYMENT- THAT
WAS PART OF THE GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS- WE HAVE ACTUALLY-
CALL WITH THEM THIS WEEK TO
ANSWER ANY REMAINING QUESTIONS
THAT THEY MAY HAVE. IN THIS
AREA AND THEN HOPE HOPE TO
HAVE- A RESPONSE FROM THEM
SHORTLY THERE AFTER. OKAY AND
CAN YOU SPEAK ABOUT QUESTION
NUMBER ONE LITTLE BIT MORE BUT
THE EXPLANATION FOR THE
DECLINING CASELOADS DECLINED
OKAY YEAH HAPPY TO THAT- AS FAR
AS THE DECLINE SOME OF THE
FACTORS THAT THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED. ARE THAT THAT HAS
YOU WERE REFERENCING EARLIER
THE KIND OF BABY BOOMERS THAT
ARE MOVING INTO THIS OLDER AGE
GROUP- ARE ACTUALLY. THEIR
MEDIAN INCOME IS HIGHER THAN IT
USED TO BE OBVIOUSLY AND IT
OFTENTIMES IS EXCEEDING THAT OF
SOCIETY S. S. P. ELIGIBILITY
STANDARDS SO THAT'S ONE OF THE-
IMPACTS AS TO. FOLKS BEING
ELIGIBLE FOR IT FOR THIS
BENEFIT- AND- ANOTHER IS
IMPROVEMENTS IN TECHNOLOGY AND
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY THAT- PEOPLE
ARE ABLE TO GATCH MEDICAL-
PROCEDURES OR OTHER TYPES OF
SUPPORTS THAT. ALLOW THEM TO
CONTINUE TO WORK. ON WITH WITH
DISABILITIES SO THAT THEY ARE
NOT MEETING THE BENEFITS
THEY'RE ABLE TO ACTUALLY BE
EMPLOYED- PEOPLE ARE HAVING
HEALTHIER BEHAVIORS AS FAR AS
LIFESTYLE WHICH IS LEADING TO.
TO BETTER HEALTH AND LESS NEED
FOR THIS TYPE OF SERVICE- AGAIN
SOCIOECONOMIC STATUS AND THEN
ON THE OTHER IS- ASSET LIMITS
OF SSI AND S. S. P. I'M NOT
REALLY- CHANGE THE ASSETS
WRESTLE THRESHOLDS- I HAVE BEEN
IN PLACE AND THE SAME- SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE. SO MANY
PEOPLE ARE ABOVE THOSE THOSE
TYPES OF LIMITS TO QUALIFY FOR
THE BENEFITS OF PEOPLE HAVING.
MORE MONEY AND MORE ASSETS ARE
IMPACTING THEIR ELIGIBILITY FOR
THE SS I SS P. BENEFIT- THAT
HAVEN'T REALLY CHANGED AS. FAR
AS HOW THAT DETERMINATION IS
NAY. TO IDENTIFIES ISSUE I
THINK THAT'S PART OF THE YES
I'M WITH- YOU KNOW MORE
TECHNOLOGY AND PEOPLE BEING
ABLE TO CONTINUE TO WORK. I
THINK THE PART IN FINANCE
MEETING ON THIS. DELEO. YES ONE
THING WE WANT TO FLAG FOR THE
COMMITTEE IS. WHATEVER AS
AUTOMATION CHANGER FOR DELIVERY
SYSTEM THAT IS ADOPTED IN ORDER
TO ALLOCATE THE SIX HUNDRED
DOLLAR ONE TIME PAYMENT
STATUSES ISIS P. RECIPIENT IF
THERE'S AN ABILITY TO RETAIN
THAT PUNCTUALITY SO IF IN THE
FUTURE THE STATE WORK
INTERESTED IN ISSUING ONE TIME
TEMPORARY PAYMENTS TO US ISIS
EXERCISES P. RECIPIENTS WE
ALREADY HAVE THE CHANGE THEY
CAN LEVERAGE THAT AND NOT FOUND
IN CURRY DECISIONAL COSTS. IN
ADMINISTERING. ANY POSSIBLE
FUTURE PAYMENTS. GREAT POINT
THINK YOU THAT DEPENDING ON
THIS. THANK YOU- APPRECIATE
THAT- AT LEAST WE DIDN'T TRY TO
TAKE THE COLA FROM THEM WE DID
THAT DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION. ALSO WE JUST NOTE
THAT THE MAXIMUM MONTHLY AS A
SITE PLAN FOR AT LEAST FOR
INDIVIDUALS IS ACTUALLY BELOW
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL AND OF COURSE
HAVE A HIGHER COST OF LIVING
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SO I KNOW I KNOW THIS IS BEEN
SUCH A CHALLENGE WE- THE
DIFFICULTY WITH. THE HERE AND
CALIFORNIA IN TERMS OF- HOPING
WE WERE ABLE AT LEAST GET. THE
MAX'S THE CALFRESH A FEW YEARS
AGO- AND- BUT- I THINK THIS IS
REMAINS A CONTINUING CHALLENGE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY AND THEN I THINKTHERE'S
SOME REQUEST FOR PROPOSALS
HELLO. YES I'LL BE READING-
FROM THE AGENDA OF THE REQUEST
FOR PROPOSALS RELATED TO DSS
ADULT PROGRAMS I'M AGAIN IF
THERE ANY QUESTIONS HAPPY TO
CIRCLE BACK WITH STAFF AND GET
RESPONSES TO THOSE AT A LATER
DATE. THE FIRST PROPOSAL IS
FROM SEIU CALIFORNIA AND UNITED
DOMESTIC WORKERS SLASH ASKED ME
LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY WHICH
PROPOSES TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO CREATE A NEW FISCAL PENALTY
EQUIVALENT 210% OF A COUNTIES
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE I JUST
S. M. O. E. TO BE APPLIED
ANNUALLY IN AUTOMATICALLY AS
LONG AS A COUNTY DOES NOT REACH
A CONTRACT. THE SECOND BUDGET
REQUEST IS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA JUSTICE IN AGING I
SEE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA AND YOU
D. W. ASKED ME LOCAL THIRTY
NINE THIRTY WHICH PROPOSES
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO REPEAL
WELFARE AND INSTITUTIONS CODE
SECTIONS- TWELVE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED ONE POINT 001-312-0003
HUNDRED ONE POINT ZERO TWO. OR
ZERO FIVE AND PERMANENTLY
RESTORING THE SEVEN PERCENT.
CUT I JUST SAYS SERVICE HOURS.
THE THIRD PROPOSAL IS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES YOU W. ASKED ME LOCAL
THIRTY NINE THIRTY I SEE ARE
YOU CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. THE URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
PROVIDE. CONTEST WILL
CONTINUITY- OKAY CONTINUE
READING. FOR THE EXISTING I
JUST AS COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
FUNDING TOOLS SO THAT FURTHER
PROGRESS ON LOCAL BARGAINING
FOR WAGE AND BENEFIT INCREASES
WILL BE ACHIEVED COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS CHANGE FOR
SIXTEEN MILLION GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
AND THIRTY TWO MILLION IN THE
OUT YEARS. THE FOURTH BUDGET
REQUEST IS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF PUBLIC AUTHORITIES WHICH
REQUEST FIVE MILLION GENERAL
FUND ON GOING TO BE MATCHED
WITH FIVE MILLION FEDERAL FUNDS
TO ALLOW COUNTIES TO IMPLEMENT
OR EXPAND TECHNOLOGIES FOR
ELECTRONIC FORMS THE MIDDLE.
THIS PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES-
BUT COMPANIES TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO REQUIRE CDSS TO
CREATE A PLAN TO DEVELOP THE
ABILITY TO ELECTRONICALLY SIGN
AND SUBMIT FORMS. THE FED
BUDGET REQUEST IS FROM THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND JUSTICE IN
AGING WHICH REQUEST TWENTY FIVE
MILLION IN THE CURRENT YEAR AND
A HUNDRED MILLION ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER TO EXPAND THE ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES PROGRAM. TO
BUILD UPON THE APS HOME SAFE
PROGRAM. THE SIX BUDGET REQUEST
IS FROM GRIFFIN STEVENS AND LEE
CONSULTING ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMONWEALTH OF PENNSYLVANIA
WHICH PROPOSES TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO AUTHORIZE BUT NOT
REQUIRE DSS TO CONTRACT WITH
THE GOVERNMENT VENDOR TO
ADMINISTER ITS STATE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT PROGRAM.
AND THAT'S THE END OF THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YET THE DOCTRINE I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- AND YOU MAY OR
MAY NOT HAVE AN ANSWER THIS
QUESTION- BUT- THE PROPOSAL IN
TERMS OF REGARDS TO THE-
CONTINUITY OF DIE JUST AS
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING FUNDING
MECHANISM WHICH WE'RE WE
REFERENCE LOW EARLIER THIS-
SEVENTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE. FLIP
HOW DOES THAT IMPACT OTHER
PROGRAMS BECAUSE OF THE NINETY
ONE REALIGNMENT SO ESSENTIALLY
WE KNOW THAT FURTHER DOWNSTREAM
IS ACTUALLY MENTAL HEALTH AND
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND SO IF NOW
THE COUNTIES ARE HAVING TO BEAR
A HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF THESE
COSTS WOULD HAVE AN IMPACT ON
LOCAL MENTAL HEALTH AND PUBLIC
HEALTH FUNDING AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL. THIS IS JACKIE FROM THE
ELIO- CENTER PAM HAPPY TO GET
BACK TO YOU I'M GONNA HAVE TO
CONNECT WITH OUR OTHER NINETEEN
ANYONE REALIGNMENT BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH FOLKS JUST A FOLLOW UP
OKAY I APPRECIATE THAT- PLEASE
GET BACK TO ME BUT I'LL MAKE
NOTE AND WHATEVER DISCUSSIONS
HAPPENING. AROUND THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE I WOULD. BE
SURE WE KEEP THAT IN MIND-
BECAUSE AS- HOPEFULLY WE
RECOGNIZED THROUGH CODED
OBVIOUSLY WE'VE UNDERFUNDED
PUBLIC HEALTH FOR WAY TOO LONG.
WE DON'T AYE COMPOUND THAT AND
WE KNOW OUR MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
ARE GOING UP PANDEMIC AS WELL
AND WE DON'T WANT TO UNDERCUT
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING AT
THE LOCAL LEVELS WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY THANK YOU. OF
MOVING ON TO COMMUNICATOR
LICENSING. WELCOME HEY GOOD
AFTERNOON SHOULD MONETARY CHIEF
DEPUTY DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. NOW I AM GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND GIVE YOU JUST AN
OVERVIEW FIRST OF COMMUNITY
CARE LICENSING AND THEN GO INTO
OUR FIRST DIVE BUDGET PROPOSAL.
A COMMUNITY CARE LICENSING
DIVISION IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
LICENSING OVER SEVENTY THREE
THOUSAND FACILITIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO ENSURE
THAT HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS. R.
THREE PROGRAM AREAS INCLUDE
ADULT AND SENIOR CARE
CHILDREN'S RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES AND CHILD CARE
FACILITIES. THE MOST COMMON
ADULT AND SENIOR CARE
FACILITIES ARE RCMP'S OR
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY AND A ARE AT OURS
OR ADULT RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES
AND THOSE ARE FACILITIES THAT
SERVE ADULTS AND SENIORS WITH
DISABILITIES OR OTHER LONG TERM
CARE. AT THE PORTAGE MEAT AND
IT'S ALL BE REFERENCING THOSE
FACILITIES TODAY OKAY. THE
FIRST BUDGET PROPOSAL IS THE
ADULT RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES
CLOSURE AND RESIDENT TRANSFERS
AB. TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN.
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL ADDRESSES
POLICY CHANGES TO BE
IMPLEMENTED UNDER AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN WHICH
ADDRESSES ADULT RESIDENTIAL
FACILITY FOR OUR CLOSURES AND
RESIDENT TRANSFERS. PRIOR TO
THE PASSAGE OF AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN ARCS WERE ONLY
REQUIRED TO GIVE A THIRTY DAY
EVICTION NOTICE TO RESIDENTS IN
THE EVENT THAT THEY WERE
SPEAKING OPERATIONS. THIS NEW
ASSEMBLY BILL REQUIRES ARTISTS
TO PROVIDE A ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DAY NOTICE OR AS SOON AS
PRACTICALLY POSSIBLE. TO BOTH
CITY AND COUNTIES AS WELL AS TO
RESIDENTS AND THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES THEY'RE GOING
TO CEASE OPERATIONS. THIS GIVES
THE COUNTY OR CITY SIXTY DAYS
TO DETERMINE IF THEY WOULD LIKE
TO PURCHASE OR OPERATE THE
FACILITY. WITH THE INTENT OF
PRESERVING OVERALL FACILITY
CAPACITY. CDSS CURRENTLY HAS
THE AUTHORITY UNDER SENATE BILL
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE TO APPOINT A
TEMPORARY MANAGER TO A FACILITY
FOR A LIMITED DURATION IN THE
CASE THAT A FACILITY OPERATOR
IS UNDER A TEMPORARY SUSPENSION
AND CAN NO LONGER FULFILL THEIR
DUTIES. THIS ALLOWS RESIDENTS
TO CONTINUE TO BE CARED FOR
SAFELY ON THEIR HOME REDUCING
THE RISK OF TRANSFER TRAUMA
EITHER WELL THE NEW OWNER OR
PROVIDER TAKES OVER OR LOW
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES ARE ABLE TO
FIND RESIDENTS NEW HOMES. AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN
ADDED THE AUTHORITY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO UTILIZE A
TEMPORARY MANAGER IF HERE WAS
ANY SUBSTANTIAL THREATS TO
HEALTH AND SAFETY. NO
ALTERNATIVE PLACEMENTS FOR THE
RESIDENTS AND IT WAS NECESSARY
TO CARE FOR THE RESIDENTS. THIS
CURRENT TEAM WOULD ALLOW THE
CDSS TO CONTRACT WITH THE
TEMPORARY MANAGERS FOR THIS
PURPOSE. THE FUNDING WILL BE
USED TO CONTINUE OPERATIONS OF
THE FACILITY IF THERE IS A GAP
BETWEEN THE FORMER LICENSEES
ABILITY TO MAINTAIN CARE AND
SUPERVISION AND A NEW PROVIDER
TAKING ON OPERATIONS OF THE
FACILITY. WE'RE CURRENTLY
ESTIMATING THAT TEN FACILITIES
WILL REQUIRE TEMPORARY MANAGERS
TO STAY OPEN FOR THE REQUIRED
SIXTY DAYS UNDER AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN. THE SECOND
QUESTION IF THE DEPARTMENT HAS
INDICATED THAT THE REQUESTED
RESOURCES MAY HELP SLOW DOWN
THE CURRENT TREND OF HIGHER
FACILITY CLOSURES ACROSS THE
STATE. HOW MANY OF THESE
DISABILITY TYPES OF CLOTHES IN
THE PAST FIVE YEARS. AND HOW
MANY FACILITIES DOES THE
DEPARTMENT ESTIMATE WILL NEED.
A TEMPORARY MANAGERS. IN THE
PAST FIVE YEARS EIGHT HUNDRED
AND FORTY ONE ARCS HAVE CLOSED
THEIR DOORS. BEYOND THE OVERALL
NUMBER OF OUR FACILITIES THAT
HAVE CLOSED FOR ALL ADULT AND
SENIOR CARE FACILITIES THERE IS
A GROWING CONCERN THAT WE ARE
SEEING IN OUR DATA BUT THE
NUMBER OF SSI RECIPIENTS WERE
LOW INCOME RECIPIENTS BEING
SERVED IN OUR LICENSED
FACILITIES IS DECLINING. THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF LIMITATIONS
WITH OUR DATA THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO DRILL DOWN ON
OVERTIME HOWEVER WE MUST ALSO
CAN CURRENTLY PLAN TO BUILD OUT
THE CONTINUUM OF LONG TERM CARE
OPTIONS. FOR AGING ADULTS AND
ADULTS WITH DISABILITIES OF ALL.
ONE INTENT OF AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN WAS TO SLOW DOWN
THE PROCESS THE FACILITIES THAT
SERVE LOW INCOME RESIDENTS.
HAVING TO CLOSE THEIR DOORS DUE
TO FINANCIAL INSOLVENCY AND
THEREBY LOSING THE CAPACITY TO
SERVE THIS VULNERABLE
POPULATION. AND AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE WE ARE ESTIMATING THAT
TEN FACILITIES ANNUALLY. WILL
REQUIRE TEMPORARY MANAGERS TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE CARE AND
SUPERVISION DURING OWNERSHIP
TRANSITION. AND THE THIRD
QUESTION IS A TEMPORARY MANAGER
NEEDED IN EVERY INSTANCE. IN
WHICH A FACILITY IS TRANSFERRED
FROM ONE LICENSEE TO ANOTHER.
AND IN WHICH SITUATIONS IS A
TEMPORARY MANAGER NECESSARY.
HOW DOES THIS MODEL WORK WITH
RCMP. AND THE ANSWER IS NO
TEMPORARY MANAGERS. THEIR USE
MOST TYPICALLY WHEN THE
TEMPORARY SUSPENSION ACTION BY
THE DEPARTMENT AND IN ALL CASES
WHEN THE IN THE MEDIA AT
RELOCATION OF THE RESIDENTS
IT'S NOT FEASIBLE BASED ON
THINGS SUCH AS RISK OF TRANSFER
THOMAS LACK OF ALTERNATE
PLACEMENTS OR OTHER EMERGENCY
CONSIDERATIONS FOR THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF RESIDENTS. OR
WHEN THE LICENSEE IS UNWILLING
OR UNABLE TO ENSURE THE STATE
RELOCATION. DURING THE PANDEMIC
TEMPORARY MANAGERS HAVE BEEN
UTILIZED TO TIMES WHEN THE
ADMINISTRATOR CONSCIOUS
CONTRACTED PUBLIC NINETEEN A
COULD NOT CARE FOR THE
RESIDENTS. AND FINALLY IN
SITUATIONS WHERE THE LICENSEE
MAY PASS AWAY OR FILE FOR
BANKRUPTCY THE DEPARTMENT MAY
APPOINT A TEMPORARY MANAGER TO
ENSURE THE FACILITY CAN
CONTINUE TO OPERATE AND
RESIDENTS ARE CARED FOR. IN
SITUATIONS IN THE SITUATIONS
I'VE DESCRIBED THE DEPARTMENT
HAS CONTRACTED WITH TEMPORARY
MANAGERS AND BOTH ARE AN RCMP
AND I FOUND THEM TO BE
INSTRUMENTAL IN ENSURING
UNINTERRUPTED KAREN SUPERVISION
FOR VULNERABLE FRANCE. AND THE
FINAL QUESTION IN THIS SECTION
ADVOCATES INSTEAD THAT THE
FACILITIES THAT CARE FOR
CLIENTS ON SSI ARE STRUGGLING
TO COVER OPERATING COSTS. HOW
DOES THE STATE PROPOSED TO
ENSURE THESE FACILITIES REMAIN
OPEN. THERE ARE SEVERAL
STRATEGIES THE STATE COULD
CONSIDER TO ENSURE THE
FINANCIAL VIABILITY OF ARCS AND
RCOG. ONE SUCH PROGRAM IS THE
COMMUNITY CARE EXPANSION
PROGRAM CURRENTLY BEING
PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET. THIS
PROGRAM WOULD PROVIDE TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION AND
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND OVER A
THREE YEAR PERIOD TO COUNTIES
FOR THE ACQUISITION OR
REHABILITATION OF OURS AND OUR
CFE. THE GOAL OF THIS PROGRAM
IS TO CREATE NEW CARE
FACILITIES SECOND. PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WITH
A FOCUS ON SENIORS AND THOSE
WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS. AS WELL AS TO
STABILIZE EXISTING SETTINGS
THIRTY PEOPLE AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS DUE TO THEIR
LIMITED INCOME. FANS WILL BE
PRIORITIZED FOR THE CREATION OF
NEW AND EXPANDED SETTINGS BUT
MAY ALSO BE USED TO FUND
CAPITAL INVESTMENTS IN
REHABILITATION COSTS FOR
EXISTING SETTINGS AT RISK OF
CLOSURE. THIS PROPOSAL AIMS TO
LEVERAGE OTHER INVESTMENTS SUCH
AS FEDERAL AND LOCAL PROGRAMS
TO SUPPORT OPERATING COSTS AND
SERVICES TO RESIDENTS BY
REDUCING THE CAPITAL COSTS FOR
FACILITY OPERATORS. THANK YOU
AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE ANYTHING
ON THIS ONE. BELIAU. IN SHORT
GOOD AFTERNOON ANGELES SHORT
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- JUST TO SAY THIS
PROPOSAL ALIGNS WITH CURRENT
LAW AND AS YOU HEARD WOULD-
BRING THE CLOSURE PROCESS FOR
OUR MORE IN LINE WITH THE
CLOSURE PROCESS THAT PARTY
EXISTS FOR RCMP'S- AS SUCH WE
DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS- WITH
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I GUESS I WOULD
JUST ASK THEM- THE- TO DO WE DO
WE KNOW THESE FOR ARE GOING ON
ONE IS FOR CLOSE. AND THEN. IS
THAT WHAT HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED
AS WIFE FACILITIES CLOSES
BECAUSE OF CAPITAL COSTS. OFTEN
PUT MONEY IN THE CAPITAL COST
IS THAT WHY THEY'RE CLOSING OR
IT. THEY WERE THERE OTHER
REASONS. YES SO I'LL TAKE THE-
FIRST OF BAD OF INFLUENCE JUST
FURTHER THAT. CURRENTLY HAVE
SOME PRETTY. LIMITATION WITH
OUR- INTO OF UNDERSTANDING OF
WHERE A RESIDENTS TRANSFER AS A
RESULT A LOT OF WHAT WE HAVE
IS- ANECDOTAL DATA. THAT
RESIDENTS ARE HAVING TO FIND
OTHER OTHER SITUATIONS OTHER
LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES. ON
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN THE DATA
AS I REFERENCED IS THAT EVEN
THOUGH WE HAVE. A NUMBER OF
FACILITIES THAT ACCEPT AS BEST
I RESIDENTS WE ARE SEEN A
DECREASE IN THE NUMBER OF SSI
RESIDENTS UTILIZING FACILITIES.
SO WE CURRENTLY ARE INTERESTED
IN DOING SOME ORGANIC DATA
EXPLORATION ABOUT THAT BUT YOU
HAVE TO HM I CAN'T FULLY ANSWER
THAT QUESTION AND ARE THEY
USING THEM. LESS BECAUSE THEY.
THINK THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS.
ARE THESE THEM LESS RIGHT YOU
SHOULD DON'T HAVE ACCESS- AT
NIGHT I DON'T KNOW I CAN IN
THAT- THAT COULD. SPECIFICALLY
BUT SOMETHING I CAN SIR GET
SOME GET OKAY INFORMATION AND
IF WE END OF WEIRD. IN ORDER TO
FUNDING THE SAID RHONDA- WE GOT
TO MAKE PEOPLE CAN FIND THE
FROM DOOR FOR FIRST. AND THAT
PROCESS. AND WHAT WHAT'S THE
PLAN FOR THE DATA THAT WE CAN
OUR- SO. WE NEVER CAN TRACK
PEOPLE ARE GOING AND WHY DO WE-
YEAH. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION SO THE I CAN. CARELESS
PRO- A IN PROCESS OF THE- A NEW
DATA. AND WE ARE SO. LOOKING AT
STRATEGIES AN AVENUE FOR A TO
BE A TO CALL MORE DATA AT THIS.
WORK PRIMARILY. WITH THE LADY
LOW DATA. BUT THERE'S NO SUCH.
OR RIGHT. THAT ALLOWS US TO DIG
FURTHER ANKLE. FOR ON. THE- THE
ACTUAL RESTED AND SO. WE ARE.
AT HOW ARE SYSTEM AND HOW ARE.
TO SO CO FRIENDS WITH OUT-
WE'VE LEARNED SOME STRAY. FOR
BEING A TO OUR READ MORE. TO
OUR FACILITIES AND THOSE OF
THOSE INCLUDED. THE USE OF AT
EVERYBODY IN ORDER TO. SO AND
SERVE ON SURVEYS AND SO WE ARE
DEVELOPING NEW STRATEGIES FOR
BEING ABLE TO COLLECT DATA BUT
AT THIS TIME. WE CERTAINLY HAVE
SOME- LIMITATIONS AS I
REFERENCED AND NOT SO. WE WILL
DEFINITELY BE LOOKING. BACK
WITH YOU AS WE LEARN MORE. I
THINK THIS IS AN AREA THAT WE
NEED TO VOTE ON FOR THE SHOW
NET AND WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENED PEOPLE IN THE SLIPPED
TO THE NET THAT'S PROBLEM. DR
GRANT. I THINK OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THINK WE CAN. ON
TO ISSUE A FIVE CHILDREN'S
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES AND
REDUCING. LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THANK YOU. NOW I WILL TAKE THIS
NEXT ONE CHICAGO. AND CHIEF
DEPUTY DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES- THIS EASY P. IS
REQUESTING PERMANENT FUNDING
POSITION OF AUTHORITY FOR THREE
LICENSING PROGRAM AND ARCHER
RESIDENTIAL. TO PERFORM THE
MANDATORY REQUIREMENTS OUTLINED
IN EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY EIGHT
UNDER THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE CHILDREN'S RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES ARE REQUIRED TO
REPORT LAW ENFORCEMENT CONTACT
WITH CHILDREN RESIDING IN THEIR
CARE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ENSURING YEAR AND FOSTER CARE
ARE NEITHER BEING ARRESTED OR
HAVING CHARGES FILED AGAINST
THEM DUE TO MINOR INCIDENTS.
THE DEPARTMENT CURRENTLY
RECEIVES OVER THIRTY THOUSAND
LAW ENFORCEMENT CONTACTS PER
YEAR FROM OUR EIGHT HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FACILITIES. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE A BACKLOG OF APPROXIMATELY
FIVE THOUSAND LAW ENFORCEMENT
CONTACT REPORTS TO CROSS THAT.
IN FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN CDSS
RECEIVED THREE LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS TO PERFORM THIS WORK
LOWER. EAST POSITIONS WILL BE
NECESSARY IN AN ONGOING WAY TO
BOTH MEET THE WORKLOAD DEMANDS
A BABY THREE EIGHTY EIGHT AS
WELL AS THE EXPANDED SCOPE OF
THE REQUIREMENTS. FOLLOWING AB
FOR- OH FOUR IN EIGHTEEN
ELEVEN. SECOND QUESTION IS HOW
IS THE INCREASED REVIEW AND
MONITORING OF THESE FACILITIES
FAMILIES. WE'VE SEEN A NUMBER
OF OVERALL BENEFITS TO YOU
EXPLAINS WE'VE INCREASED THE
MONITORING OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
CONTACT. PROVIDERS HAVE BECOME
MORE AWARE OF THE DETRIMENTAL
EFFECTS OF UNNECESSARY AND
SOMETIMES DRAMATIC INTERVENTION
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT SUCH AS RE
TRUMPETED STATION DUE TO THE
YOUTH FAMILY HISTORY WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT. OR THE YOU'RE
GETTING A CRIMINAL RECORD WHICH
MAY IMPACT THEIR ABILITY LATER
TO OBTAIN EMPLOYMENT OR HOUSING
OPTIONS. AS A RESULT OF THIS
AWARENESS MANY PROVIDERS HAVE
CREATED INTERNAL POLICIES AND
TRAINING THAT EIGHT STEP IN
CONFLICT RESOLUTION. THE
ESCALATION STRATEGIES AND
BEHAVIORAL MANAGEMENT SKILLS.
SUCH AS CRISIS PREVENTION
INSTITUTE TRAINING. DISTILLS
AND KNOWLEDGE THAT IN TURN NOT
ONLY LEAD TO INCREASE SAFETY
FOR YOUTH IN CARE BUT SAFER
ENVIRONMENTS FOR THE FACILITIES
STAFF AS WELL. AND THE THIRD
QUESTION IS WHAT ARE THE
REASONS FOR INCREASED LAW
ENFORCEMENT REPORTS AND MOST
FACILITIES. THE VAST MAJORITY
OR 82% OF LAW ENFORCEMENT CALLS
ARE FOR YOUTH WHO HAVE LEFT THE
FACILITY FOR SOME PERIOD OF
TIME WITHOUT THE APPROVAL TO DO
SO. MOST PLACEMENT AGENCIES
REQUIRE THAT FACILITIES CONTACT
LAW ENFORCEMENT WHEN THE U.
BECAUSE BEEN GONE FOR OVER
FIFTEEN MINUTES. WITHOUT
APPROVAL. EVEN IF YOU HAS
RETURNED TO THESE FACILITIES WE
HAVE. EVEN EVEN WHEN THE YEAR
HAS RETURNED TO THIS FACILITIES.
FIFTY AN OVERALL DEEP FROM
COURSE BEING FOR. ISSUES LIK
DO TO AN IN EMPHASIS ON
TRAINING FOR THE STAFF
INCLUDING AS A REFERENCE DE
ESCALATION STRATEGIES AND OTHER
TRAUMA INFORMED PRACTICE. WHEN
WE DO IDENTIFY FACILITIES THAT
ARE CALLING ON MORE FREQUENT
OUR TEAM PROVIDES INCREASED
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO SUPPORT
OTHER STRATEGIES. THAT SUPPORT
THE. I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS- HELLO. SURE THANK
YOU AS YOU HEARD THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD CONTINUE PROVIDING
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS US YOU
SALES INCREASED WORKLOAD
AROUND- THE PROCESSING AND
REPORTING THAT'S REQUIRED- WHEN
CHILDREN'S RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES HAVE CONTACT WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT- AND AS SUCH
GIVEN THIS INCREASED WORKLOAD
THAT THEY'VE SEEN OVER RECENT
YEARS WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THE CONTINUATION
OF THE POSITIONS HAPPY TO
ANSWERING QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
A DOCTOR. THIS IS A ASSEMBLY
WHO'S WORKING FAMILIES WITH AND
IT IS A TOUGH ISSUE. DONNA OKAY-
COMMITTEE LICENSING. MEMBERS
THANK THANK YOU SHE LONGER
TERRY CHIEF DEPUTY DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES PLEASE
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
PROPOSAL AND SOME OF THE
METHODS THAT CCL HAS USED TO
REDUCE TIME TO PROCESS
APPLICATIONS. NO WE ARE
CURRENTLY REQUESTING PERMANENT
POSITION OF AUTHORITY TO
ADDRESS THE TIMELINESS AND
PROCESSING APPLICATIONS FOR
ADULT AND SENIOR RESIDENTIAL
CARE PROGRAM AS WELL AS TO
ASSIST WITH COMPLAINT
INVESTIGATIONS FOR BOTH THE
ADULT AND SENIOR RESIDENTIAL
CARE PROGRAM AS WELL AS THE
CHILDREN'S RESIDENTIAL CARE.
THE DEPARTMENT REQUEST TO MAKE
THIRTEEN LICENSING PROGRAM
ANALYST AND FOR ASSOCIATE
GOVERNMENTAL PROGRAM ANALYST
PERMANENT. IN ORDER TO INCREASE
EFFICIENCIES ON THE LICENSING
APPLICATION PROCESS THE
DEPARTMENT IS TAKING THE
FOLLOWING STEPS. FIRST WE'RE
MAKING BETTER USE OF OUR DATA
TO IDENTIFY APPLICATION PROCESS
TRENDS WHICH HAS ALLOWED US TO
FOCUS ON AREAS WHERE WE NEED TO
IMPROVE. WE HAVE CREATED
EFFICIENCIES REMOVING SOME UP
ELECTRONIC PROCESS THESE
INCLUDING ITEMS SUCH AS
GENERATING AUTOMATIC
NOTIFICATIONS TO REQUEST FIRE
FOR LOCAL PLANNING INSPECTIONS.
AND ACCEPT ELECTRONIC
SIGNATURES AND DOCUMENTS. WE RE
DISTRIBUTED WORKFLOW TO
SPECIALIZED TEAMS TO ENSURE WE
HAVE THE EXPERTISE TO PROCESS
MORE COMPLEX. AND REDUCE
PROCESSING TIME. WE HAVE
ENHANCED OUR PEER WHEN A CALL
LEGAL AND POLICY SUPPORT FOR
COMPLEX APPLICATION REQUESTS
AND PROCESS THESE. AND WE HAVE
INITIATED A STREAMLINED
ONBOARDING PROCESS FOR NEW
APPLICANTS TO ENSURE MORE
COMPLETE APPLICATIONS ARE BEING
SUBMITTED AT THE OUTSET. PLEASE
DISCUSS THE SEALS APPROACH TO
FACILITIES WITH A HIGH NUMBER
OF COMPLAINTS. THAT'S
COMPLAINTS COME TO OUR TEAM THE
CCL ASSESSES THE NATURE AND
IMPACT OF THE COMPLAINTS AND
THE IMMEDIATE HEALTH AND SAFETY
NEEDS OF RESIDENTS WHICH GUIDES
OUR NEXT STEP- NON EGREGIOUS
COMPLAINTS ARE TEAM GATHERS
MORE INFORMATION TO DETERMINE
THE ROOT CAUSE OF THOSE. PLANS
AND COORDINATES A MEETING WITH
THE FACILITY ADMINISTRATOR AND
STAFF TO IDENTIFY SOLUTIONS. WE
CONDUCT EARNED GREEN BUSINESS
AND WE PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO THE FACILITY IN
MEETING REGULATIONS AND
PREVENTING FUTURE COMPLAINTS.
FOR MORE AGREE JUST COMPLAINTS
OUR TEAM RECESSES HEALTH OR
SAFETY CONCERNS FOR THE
RESIDENTS AS WELL AS IMMEDIACY
UP THE REST. BASED ON THE
NATURE OF THE COMPLAINT WE
DETERMINE IF WE CAN PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
INCREASE OUR MONITORING TO HELP
CORRECT THE ISSUE OR IF WE NEED
TO TAKE ENFORCEMENT ACTION. IF
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
IS FOUND TO BE INEFFECTIVE AND
IF THE COMPLAINT RISES TO A
CERTAIN LEVEL OF EGREGIOUS
MASS. RIDGE THEIR ONGOING RISKS
TO THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
RESIDENTS. IN CCL IN OUR
DEPARTMENT'S LEGAL TEAM. TAKE
ON IT IN ACCORDANCE WITH
REGULATIONS AND STATUTES MAY
TAKE ENFORCEMENT ACTION. AND
MAY RESULT A LICENSE IF WE ARE
REVOKING A LICENSE THE
DEPARTMENT WORKS DILIGENTLY TO
ENSURE THAT THE RESIDENTS ARE
PROPERLY CARED FOR DURING THAT
STRETCH. THANK YOU AND I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. FOR TO FINANCE
ANYTHING. HELLO. YES AS YOU
HEARD FROM CHIEF DEPUTY
SECRETARY THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
MAKE SEVERAL A LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS PERMANENT TO ALLOW
CCL TO CONTINUE ADDRESSING BACK-
IN TERMS OF COMPLAINT
INVESTIGATIONS AS WELL AS
LICENSING APPLICATION
PROCESSING TIMES FOR CERTAIN
YOU STILL FACILITIES- ALSO JUST
TO HIGHLIGHT AS NOTED IN YOUR
AGENDA YOU STILL HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVED THESE
BACKLOGS OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS- IN LARGE PART BECAUSE OF
THE ADDITIONAL POSITIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN IN PLACE- ON A
LIMITED TERM BASINS BASIS SINCE
TWENTY FIFTEEN- AND THEREFORE
THE REQUESTED RESOURCES SEEM
REASONABLE TO ALLOW CCL. TO
SUSTAIN THESE IMPROVEMENTS THAT
THEY'VE MADE- AND TO CONTINUE
ADDRESSING THE REMAINING
BACKLOGS- SO AND TO CONCLUDE WE
DON'T ANY CAN WITH THIS PER-
BUT I'M TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
SKILLS AND GUESTS WORKS SHOULD
DO MORE OF IT HI. EVERYTHING
HONEST OF HIM. OKAY I THINK
THAT IS IT AND THIS EVERY. FOR
THEIR PLEASE TODAY THEIR WORK
AND PREPARE EVERY AND WORKING
ON. BEHALF OF VULNERABLE SEEN
CALLUM. I BELIEVE NOW WILL GO
TO PUBLIC- I WOULD FIRST BY I
NOTICED IT IS NO. IN OUR
COMMITTEE BUT TO. THERE SO NOW
WE'LL MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES
AND AGAIN THE TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE. SEVEN SIX
ZERO NINE AGAIN WE ASK THAT YOU
KEEP YOUR TESTIMONY TO ONE
MINUTE TO ALLOW US TO MANY
PEOPLE TO SPEAK AS POSSIBLE-
AND ALL ASKED THE MODERATOR TO
OPEN UP OUR PHONE LINES. THANK
YOU AND IF YOU WISH TO HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE. ZERO AND OUR FIRST LINE
WILL COME FROM WIND SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I WAS
JUST IN THERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES. SHE ADMINISTRATION
LEADERSHIP ON THE MASTER PLAN
FOR AGING AND LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING ON APPLICATION. I AM
WE ARE SPONSORED PROPOSAL
THREE. FOR CONNIE AND I
COLLECTED PARTY MAKE AND YOU
THE PAN REFERENCE IN THE NEED
FOR SUPPOSED. BURGER ALSO IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO PROPOSE
NUMBER ONE FOR THE OF THE
PENALTY. IN STRONG OPPOSE FIVE
TWO IF YOU. THE TWO I THOUGHT
THE POSTAL KIND OF THE MAY
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS ON
REACHING AN INCREASE NUMBER. OF
A GREEN TO INCREASE WEIGHT AND
BENEFITS RISE THAT'S PROVIDE.
FORTY SIX CAN COME MORE THAN I
FIVE FOR. OF THE ICE RIGHT AWAY.
PERMALINK CREEK WAY TO TWENTY.
INVESTING HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS
IN COUNTY. THE WAITING PROGRESS
I MEAN THE- IT'S CALLED
INCLUDING THE COUNTY SHARING
REYES ON THE TEMP SIDE OVER
YEARS TO. ABOUT ONE PROGRAM
THREE. AT LEAST NOT THE BILL OF
ANY OF FISCAL PENALTY AT
OUTLINED BY ONE THIS LED TO THE
INCREASE NUMBER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU MALCOLM FOR
THE LINE UP AND- SIX. YEAR IS
OPEN. YES GOOD AFTERNOON MY
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
FOR SNYDER. I'M HAPPY CAL CITY
HOW FACILITIES. THAT WE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT NUMBER. OF
THE PROPOSAL FOR EXACTLY
RELATED TO THE PART AG. AND THE
BELIEVES IN THAT THE AND UP THE
PACE REPRESENT THIS. FOR
PATIENTS BETTER IN PATH OF AND
ON RECORD IN NURSING BUT- AND
UNDER THE COURT ORDER BUILDING
FACILITY ARE NOT EIGHT. TO HIRE
OR PAY THESE AND- THAT WE'RE
OCCUR. BY. RECENT CONVERSATION
THE MINISTER. AND UNDERSTAND
THAT THEY'RE WORKING A PROPOSED
TO SET UP A PATIENT. SYSTEM AND
ALL STARTING IN. I'M FORTY.
THAT WE KNOW THAT GAY THIS ARE
THE TOP OF RUN. I WILL ACTUALLY
TAKE A AMOUNT OF TIME AND I'M
OF WEEKS USED NUMBER MONTHS-
AND SO WE ARE VERY CONCERNED
AND I OUR GREAT CONCERN IS THE
COURT REQUIRES THAT ARE LONG
TERM CARE OF PATIENTS THAT ARE
IMPACTING I'M ON MY-
APPLICATION. FIVE THIRD TWENTY
TWENTY AND SO. REALLY CONCERN
THE SAID MY NEEDS TO BE EXT AND
A PATIENT RECORDS TO CAN BE- UP
AND RUNNING AND REPRESENTED CAN
BE A BILL AND TO- SO WE LOOK
FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU. AND
SUBCOMMITTEE- I THIS- IF PAGE
REPRESENT PRO. AND- AND ALSO
LOOK FORWARD AND TALKING MORE
WITH THE ON THEIR HER THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY NEXT CALLER IN
THE CAN I AND MY PEOPLE MINUTE
YOU CAN. THANK YOU COME FROM
THE LINE OF NINETY FOR YELLOW
IS OPEN. NOT INSURE MEMBERS
SEVERAL YOU WANT YOU GET THE
ACT A LOCAL NICE. THANK YOU FOR
THE HEARING TODAY. WHEN I READ
ON IT I JUST FOR. AND FORTY
THOUSAND CLIMB. NOT WORKING THE
CARE THEY NEED IN TWENTY. I FOR
BARS LESS THAN THE MINIMUM WAGE
THROUGHOUT STATE AFTER ONE
THIRTY. STRONG THE THREE
PROPOSAL. EIGHT HUNDRED. DR
CAMPER UP LOOKING AT THE YOU.
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE WORK
WITH ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATURE
IN THE BUDGET COMMITTEE ON THE
MAP AGING. AND YOU CAN BE BACK
NATION THE MICRA CREEK COCONUT
PROTECT ON COUNTY OR WORK FOR
DURING THE- TIMES. THANKS SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FIFTY
EIGHT AT SOME. NEXT CALL PLEASE.
THANK YOU IN THAT COME FROM OF
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GO
AHEAD PLEASE CALLER. MOVING ON
MODERATED BY NINETY NINE. THANK
YOU AND OUR NEXT LINE WILL COME
FROM ONE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOU CAN ONLY THE WAY TOWN
REPRESENT HELLO. IN A YOU'RE
TOWN POCKET BUT THE RULE COUNTY
IN IRVINE CAN ARE COULD
SPONSORS OF PROPOSAL THREE IN
STRONG SUPPORT TO CONTINUE. OF
THE H. THAT LIKE TO BARK
FUNDING MECHANISM. INTIMATIONS
OF THE TOOLS ARE SPECIAL MAKE
FURTHER. WITHOUT THE CHANGES
ALLEN IN THE PROS PROGRESS ON
COLLECTED BARGAINING LIKELY TO.
BUT THE REAL IN EVERY ARE
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE-
NUMBER. I ACT THAT 10% OF THE
PENALTY. I'M HAPPY THAT I'M NOT
RESPECTING ARE AT. IT IS THE
HAVE IT IS THE- AND NOT THE
PERSON OF ANY SORT PHYSICAL OF
LIKE A ON A. ONE HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON AND MEDICARE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS
JENNIFER O'MALLEY REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION- WE WOULD JUST LIKE
YOU ACT SO- YOU D. W. AB
ACTUALLY USE ALL TESTIMONY. IN
SUPPORTING- YOU CAN PERCENT
FISCAL PENALTY ARE COUNTIES
THAT DON'T BARGAIN IN GOOD
FAITH. AND IT COULD IMPACT THE
SMALL NUMBER COUNTY IN THE
PENALTY WOULD ONLY BE APPLIED
AFTER ALL AVAILABLE MARKETING
TOOLS ARE USED. I CAN'T THAT
ARE PAID LOW WAGES FOR LIFE AND
WORK IN THIS TOOL WOULD HELP
MOVE COUNTIES WHO ARE UNWILLING
TO PARK AND- AND- LIKE I SAID
WE ECHO JEFF THAT THIS. THEY
EIGHT ARE FEDERAL YOU HAD COME.
AND YOUR KIDS. OF THE ITEMS.
GREATLY IT AND AGAIN WE ARE
HERE OF THREE I. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
MEDICAL FROM LINE ONE TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS KRISTOFF
MAYOR I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
AB DE CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF PROPOSAL ONE FOR THE-
OKAY HEALTHY ON TOWN. TO
WELCOME IN GOOD FAITH WITH I
PROVIDERS. WE ALSO SUPPORT.
ADULT FORTY PER REP OF THE 7%
CUT TO AT HOWARD AS WELL AS WE
WERE WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT THE IHS SHARE OF COST WITH
THE IN THE AND BECAUSE THE 10%
TO WILL IT MAINTAINED. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
THESE ISSUES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU ON THAT ACCOUNT THE LINE OF.
ONE TWENTY. ONE TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
WILLIAM MURRAY AND I'M AYE HFS
PROVIDER FROM PLASTER COUNTY
YEAH I DESERVED PROVIDED WILL
CONTINUE TO BE PAID JUST OVER
MINIMUM WAGE UNLESS WE IMPOSE A
0% COMMITTEE ON COUNTY STREET.
THE MARKETING. AB REPORT BY
STATE AUDITOR FOUND OUT JUST
ASK YOUR GIVERS. ONLY 4% OF THE
LIVING WAGE BY. YEAH WE WILL
COUNTY LIVING WAGES OVER TO
DOLLARS AN HOUR WE NOT SEEN A
WAIT. FOR ALL MORE THAN SIX
YEARS I'M IN SUPPORT OF
IMPOSING THE 10% PENALTY I'M
COUNTY RIGHT BILLS. THAT FAILED
TO NEGOTIATE IN GOOD FAITH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOUNG
METAL COME FROM ONE OF ONE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE
NINETEEN. ONE NINETEEN AIRLINE
OF OPENING. AND WE WILL MOVE ON
TO LINE ONE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND THE NUMBER IS EIGHTY
SEND THE LATIN NUMBER WITHOUT
ANY INCIDENTS ON THE ME CA
MAKING CALIFORNIA. IF YOU A PRO
IN ORDER FOR MEDICINE HONOR
YOUR BILL MONEY HE ACTED THANK
IT COULD MA'AM MAY I USE THAT.
YEAH DEFINITELY DOES A LOT
THANK YOU VERY- YOU IT'LL
INCLUDE I'M MONEY ACT ASSEMBLY
MAKING YEAH BUT I THINK IT. BOW
CALIFORNIA MEANT THEY WILL BE
AMPLE MAKE ME THINK AM. READY
I'M WITH SPEND FROM ABOUT MUST
A MONTH HEARING THERE LET BABY
RIGHT SENECAL MORE THINK. YEAH
I THINK THE NUMBER THE PEOPLE
BY ABLE TO CLOSE THE GONNA PUT
THAT. ALMOST CORMORAN YOU KNOW
THE DE. FACTO OUT WILL COME
TAKE THE COURTS OKAY THAT IS SO.
YOU KNOW IT BE MADE THEN IT'LL
THE- NORTH ME THANK YOU DON'T.
WHEN THAT BUT DEMOCRATIC. FORTY
WHAT AT FOUR YEAR WITH THAT
PLAN LAST. NIGHT OF REQUESTS
ARE MADE A- THIRTY FEET THANK
YOU THIS IS SAM. NICHOLSON
COMPARTIR EL ESTADO DE EQUIDAD
PROGRAM UP BY THAT. IT THE
MIDDLE IN NATO THEY LOOK ME TO
THANK YOU DOCTOR COULD PUSH
WITH THE FORTY EIGHT ALL AT THE
LEFT HAND THING AT. THE END
THEY MUST BE PICKED UP YOU KNOW
I MEAN. IT'S PAST NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU AND THAT ARE
COME FROM LINE OF ONE THIRTY
ONE YOUR LIFE IS OPEN. HELLO
MADAM CHAIR I'M SOMETHING.
ASIDE TIME TO OF FOOD BANKS AND
RECORD COUNTY HUNDRED ACTION.
AND CALIFORNIANS AT THE BY I
THINK BEFORE MOM THE ON THE
SIDE BY. SHE TEN YEARS LAST
MONTH A FEW YEARS I THE CRASH
PROCESS MEREKA. THROUGH HER POP
INCOME YEAR. AS YOU STRAW. WITH
HEART RHEUMATOID ART AND LYFT
SIDE OF BY CANCER. SHE WON'T
SEE THAT STORE TO HER BY BUT
THERE ARE OVER MILLION HELLO.
IN HER SHOES AND WHO CAN WE
THANK YOU CRITICAL STATE
AMULETS INCLUSION. THIS IS
GOING TO HELP PAY FOR A TO LIVE
ANOTHER. THAT THE PLAYERS
AGREED ARE STRUGGLING TO PAY
SHELTER SAFELY. IT'S ENOUGH FOR
MEANINGFUL ONE TIME PAYMENT TO
PEOPLE AFTER SINCE THE
GREATNESS BECAUSE- WHICH- ONE
POINT THREE MILLION SENIOR TO
NINETY OF A PL. PEOPLE WERE
STILL IN UNDER CONDITION TO THE
BEFORE THE- STRUGGLING TO
HOUSING FEED THEM SO AND PAY
THEIR BILLS AND TO LIVE WITH
DIGNITY AS THEY MANAGE ON AGE
THEY MANAGE THEIR DISABILITY
FROM AGE. IN TWENTY NINETEEN
THE BUDGET AGREEMENT INCLUDED A
PERMANENT RESTORATION TO THE
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT
BEGINNING IN JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REMIND YOU OF THAT AND EXPECT
TO SEE THE COLA IN THE UPCOMING
BUDGET. WE ALSO NEED TO
EXPEDITE A PLAN FOR THE S. AND
P. GRANT TO BE INCREASED SOME
OF THE PROGRAMS ARE ABOUT
POVERTY LEVEL APOLOGIES IF THE
MASTER PLAN ON EATING. SUPPORT
AND WHEN I NOTE BURKE
TRANSITION NEED. BY THE YOU CAN
BE- THERE. PROGRAM FROM YOU CAN.
WHO LOST CAL. THAT AFTER
SIXTEEN. WE NEED A- IT WITH
HEALTH EN ROUTE. SIGNS FOR.
DURING THE- LIKE HOW OUTAGES
AND WHILE. AND LAST- WE NEED TO
ADDRESS BE. WITH LOTS NEARLY
TWENTY FIVE. OF HOW. WHO
HAPPENED WAY TO COME BACK. WE
URGENT RELIEF TO STOP AND A
PERMANENT. THE PEOPLE DON'T
LOSE THEIR FOOD JUST FROM THE
CASE PAPERWORK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER. PLEASE THANK
YOUNG COME FROM MIND. THIRTY
FOUR YEAR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS KATHY
SAID KNOWING WHAT THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE IN OPPOSITION TO ITEM
ONE FOR THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY
STATED BY MY COLLEAGUE JUSTIN
GARRETT FROM FEEDBACK. WE ALSO
ARE PLEASED TO CO SPONSOR ITEM
THREE RELATED TO THE SHARING
RATIO. WE BELIEVE THAT
MAINTAINING THE CURRENT SHARING
RATIO RATHER THAN LETTING IT
SLIP TO A LARGER COUNTY SHARE
AS CURRENT LAW WOULD PROVIDE
IS. MORE APPROPRIATE AND MORE
LIKELY TO SIX THAT COULD BE
SUCCESSFUL WAY AND ENSURING
THAT COUNTIES CONTINUE TO
BARGAIN FOR HIGHER WAGES AND
BENEFITS. I'M NOT LETTING THE
FLAPS WOULD HAVE A CHILLING
EFFECT ON THAT BARGAINING WE
ALSO AS YOU KNOW ARE PROUD TO
CO SPONSOR ITEMS FOUR AND FIVE
WHICH WE DISCUSSED EARLIER IN
THE HEARING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY. MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
MEDICAL FOR MINE ONE THAT SEVEN
YOUR LINE OF OPEN. HELLO
EVERYBODY- GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS COLONEL MARK I'M A
LICENSED PROVIDER HERE IN
ALBANY- I WANT TO SAY DAD THE
LAST TIME YOU COUNTY REACHED. A
MARK FOR A BARGAINING AGREEMENT
PROVIDES THAT THAT PROVIDED IN
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE STATE
AUDITOR'S REPORT FOUND THAT ON
AVERAGE OVER FOUR HUNDRED I
THINK BET WITH YOU. GO WITHOUT
CARE EACH MONTH IN BUTTE COUNTY
IN PART BECAUSE I HAD PROVIDED
WE GET. HELLO WE'RE STILL HERE.
I OKAY I THINK THAT'S PROVIDERS
WAITING BURKE THE LOWER.
SOUNDED LIKE BUTTE WILL ONLY
CONTINUE TO REFUSE. OFFERING
WAGES AND BENEFITS INCREASE SO
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE TEN
PERCENT. FISCAL PENALTY ON THE
BOTTOM OF THE COUNTY ALSO WE
SUPPORT- THE FABRIC BOB THE
FABRIC CAN'T CUT- SHOULD BE
RESTORED. COMPLETELY THANK YOU.
MCCARTY THANK YOU AND MEGAWIDE
WILL BE ONE FORTY CAROLINA OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRMAN-
MARC CARRERO REPRESENT A LOT
ANGELES BOARD OF PEOPLE IN
COLLEAGUES THE CORE OF GOVERNOR
BUT PROPOSAL FOR AND HOW
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES MINISTRY OF
THE POINT MILLION. THEY GENERAL
GRATEFUL FOR THAT PROCREATION
AND- REGISTER FOR THAT THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
COLOR PLEASE. THANK YOU AND
THAT ARE FROM OF- IN TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU CARE
EGGMAN AND MEMBERS TIME KEVIN
MCALLISTER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF MEALS ON WHEELS SACRAMENTO
AND PRESIDENT OF MEALS ON
WHEELS CALIFORNIA. DURING THE
CALL THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
MEALS ON WHEELS PROGRAM TOPIC
THAT CAN INCREASES IN OPERATING
COSTS BOB THIS IS A PROFOUND
INCREASE THE LEVEL OF FOOD AND
NEEDED IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
CALIFORNIA ESTIMATES SERVING
MORE THAN SEVENTEEN MILLION
MILK ACROSS CALIFORNIA DURING
ITS FIRST YEAR THE PANDEMIC.
THAT NEARLY 75% INCREASE FROM
THE PRIOR YEAR. ALSO THIRTEEN
BUILT ON THOSE PROGRAMS IN THE
STATE HAVE INCREASED THE NUMBER
OF MILITARY FIVE MORE THAN
1100% AND HERE IN SACRAMENTO
WE'RE DELIVERING TWELVE
THOUSAND BILL FOR WEEKS OVER
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED FEET. WE'RE
ALSO CONCERNED WITH A GREAT
PLACE PROGRAMS THE DENTAL
ENDING AN UNMET NEED THAT WILL
REMAIN. OUR CLIENTS HAVE BEEN
SOME OF THE HARDEST HIT BY THE
PANDEMIC AND THE NUTRITIONAL
NEEDS WILL ONLY INCREASE DUE TO
PROLONGED ISOLATION. THE MAILS
AND SOCIAL CONNECTION WE
PROVIDE THEM OR ALL THAT IS
KEEPING THEM FROM HUNGER AND
ISOLATION BUT HE'S REASONS WE
HAVE. REQUESTED A DOUBLING AT
THE STATE DEPARTMENT AND U.
NUTRITION AT A MINIMUM. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
TO ENSURE ADEQUATE FUNDING TO
SUPPORT FOOD ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
PARTICULARLY FOR SENIORS AND
ADULTS WITH DISABILITIES AND
THEIR FAMILIES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU. PHAM NINE OF
ONE. SEVEN YOU LINE OF THE. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M HARDLY
RETIRED CHECK ON THE HAVE TO
SACRAMENTO COUNTY WE'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE AGENTS HAVE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING BUDGET
PROPOSAL PUT FORWARD BY T. BACK
IN OUR OTHER COUNTY PARTNERS.
TO MAINTAIN PRACTICAL TOOLS
THAT ARE ESSENTIAL TO LOCAL
BARGAINING TO REACH AGREEMENT
FOR I JUST LIKE WE DID THE BEST
TO INCREASE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU AND THAT'LL
COME FROM LINE A. ONE THIRTY
SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND- I WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS REGINA
BRINK. AND I AM REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF THE BLIND
AND THE DEPUTY OF- GOVERNMENTAL
AFFAIRS. WE'RE CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF PEOPLE ON SSI
RECEIVING- CONSTANTLY READING
RESTORATION. AND MORE AT 90% OF
THE POVERTY LEVEL AND BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC THAT WAS DIFFICULT
TO LIVE LINE. IS A BENEFIT
AROUND A LITTLE OVER A THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER PERSON TO BUY CHEAP
TO RENT. UTILITIES ALL OF THAT
MEDICAL AND IT'S VERY- ED PAPER
IT'S VERY LOW AND I THINK THAT
RESTORING IT TO AT LEAST. DID
THAT CUTS THAT WERE MADE WHEN
THE BUDGET WAS YOU KNOW LOWER.
BUT BUT NOW THAT THERE IS A
NEED I THINK WE NEED TO RAISE
IT. THE OTHER THING IS-
CALFRESH THERE'S SEVERAL SPEAKS
IS TO REMAIN THERE. SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN GET TRANSITIONAL
FOOD STAMPS AND ALSO SAID. THE
HOUSES THAT LOSE FOOD STAMPS
DUE TO PAPERWORK THIS IS ONE OF
THE BIGGEST BARRIERS FOR PEOPLE
AND- BLIND IS BEING ABLE TO
FILL OUT. PAPERWORK PRINTED
FORMS ONLINE FORMS UP IN ARE
NOT ACCESSIBLE OR NOT AVAILABLE
FOR US AND WE ARE LOSING FOOD
BECAUSE OF IT SO I DON'T THINK
PEOPLE SHOULD SHOULD LOSE FOOD
BENEFITS. THERE'S ALSO BEEN A
LOWER AMOUNT OF PEOPLE APPLYING
FOR SSI AND WE THINK THAT'S DUE
TO INACCESSIBILITY OR WEBSITE.
AND PAPERWORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU THAT'LL COME. OF ONE
TWENTY ONE YEAR ACROSS. YEAH
THAT A CHAIR AND COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS FLORIN COSTA I THEN I
OF FROM RESPECT. WE HAVE BEEN
FIGHTING TO RESTORE SEVENTY PET
I GET THAT HOURS LATER AFTER.
KOBE NINETEEN HAD SHALL THAT I
SAID IN NEEDED NOW THAN EVER.
WHICH IS WHY I SUPPORT
PERMANENTLY RESTORE THE 7% ONCE
AND ALL THANK YOU MUCH THANK
YOU MUCH COLOR PLEASE. THANK
YOU AND COME LINE OF. FOUR
THREE YOUR LINE IS THE ONE
FORTY THREE. HI THIS IS REBECCA
THE NASH ASSOCIATION SOCIAL
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR INCLUDING SFI
RECIPIENTS IN THE GOLDEN STATE
STIMULANTS THIS WILL HELP THEM
PAY FOR ADDITIONAL EXPENSES
THEY EXPERIENCE WHILE THE
SHELTER IN PLACE. I ALSO WANT
TO THANK DR PAN FOR HIS
COMMENTS ON RECOGNIZING THE
STRUGGLES SSI RECIPIENTS
EXPERIENCE AS THEY ARE STILL ON
SUFFERING FROM THE CUT THAT
TOOK PLACE DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION- IN THIS BUDGET. WE
AFTER THE S. AND P. GRANT BE
INCREASED TO BRING TO BRING THE
PROGRAM TO BE ABOVE POVERTY
LEVEL AND WE ALSO EXPECT TO
SEE- THE COLOR RESTORATION
BEGINNING IN JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO- I ALSO WANT TO
COMMENT IN THAT- YES THAT ADULT
PROGRAM SECTION ISSUE ISSUE
FIVE I WANT TO SUPPORT. YOU
EXPAND AND ENHANCE ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES- AND LASTLY
ON THE D. PROGRAM- WE- NEED
URGENTLY TO STOP THIS AND A
PERMANENT FIX BUT PEOPLE DON'T
LOSE THEIR FOOD JEFF FROM
HAVING THEIR- PAPERWORK. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU MEADOW FROM
ONE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MADAM CHAIRMAN MEMBERS YOU CAN
EIGHT BROADBAND ON BEHALF OF.
SHALL PASTE. WE WANT TO SUPPORT
THE BUDGET ITEMS RELATED TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT MASTER
PLAN ON AGING AND PARTICULARLY
THE AGING AND DISABILITY
RESOURCE CONNECTIONS.
PROVISIONS THIS WILL HELP THE
STATE'S IMPLEMENT THE STATE'S
NO WRONG DOOR CONCEPT AND MAKE
IT EASIER FOR SENIORS AND
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES GET
INFORMATION IN CALGARY. ON L.
T. S. S. SUPPORTS AND SERVICES
WE BELIEVE BETTER ENTIRELY ACT
THAT. THE PROGRAMS INCLUDING
PAY. WILL HELP MANY THEM AVOID
PREMATURE INSULATE IN
INSTITUTIONALIZATION. WE WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO SUPPORT THE SSI
RESTORATION IN ORDER TO LIVE
SAFELY IN THE COMMUNITY WHICH
IS A PAGE REQUIREMENT YOU HAVE
TO HAVE A MINIMUM AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES TO PROVIDE UP FOR
YOUR BASIC NEEDS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU LETTER
COME FROM WIND OF ONE FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS A
NOVEL AND I AM A HOME CARE
PROVIDER IN KERN COUNTY I HAVE
BEEN A PROVIDER FOR OVER TWELVE
YEARS. AT THE MOTHER PROVIDER
AND PROUD UCW MEMBER I WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS EMPLOYMENT IN
HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES THIS
IS AN ESSENTIAL PROGRAM AND ITS
WORKERS ARE INSTRUMENTAL IN
KEEPING PEOPLE SAFE HEALTHY AND
INDEPENDENT HOWEVER THE PUBLIC
AUTHORITY. ARE COUNTY DON'T
FEEL LIKE THAT IN TWENTY
NINETEEN OVER HALF OF U. T. W.
HOW MANY WERE DOCKED AT THE
MINIMUM WAGE OF TWELVE DOLLARS
PER HOUR NEGOTIATION FOR EITHER
I'M GOING FOR AYE IN FACT. THE
AVERAGE CONTRACT EXPIRATION
LAND AT THE TIME WHERE THIRTY
EIGHT MONTHS. WITH NO PENALTY
IN PLACE HOW MANY PEOPLE NOT A
FACE ANY CONSEQUENCES FOR NOT
BARGAINING WITH THAT AND
PROVIDED WILL BE STOCKED ACT OR
JUMP THE MINIMUM WAGE FOR MY IF
NOT NEAR. OUR PROVIDERS ARE
FRONTLINE WORKERS AND WE FIRST
USED TO HELP TRONG. THAT ME
DURING THE PAST TEN. PLEASE THE
BOY YOU. BOTH EQUAL TO PAMPER.
OVER CAL I USED THAT NO THE
FUNDS THE COUNTY RECEIVED FROM
THE- OR I EIGHT AT THAT THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU ON THAT ACCOUNT LANA
NINE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS THE-
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT IS KAREN
KEEPER THE COW. SO OF PUBLIC
AFFORD AND HI CAPA ISN'T A CO
SPONSOR OF PROPOSAL THE
PROPOSAL ON. BARGAINING TO MAIN
THAT FUNDING. THAT'S CRITICAL.
TO OUR- PROPER WHICH HAS BEEN.
TREMENDOUS FOR TWO ON IT SHE
NICKEL BARGAINING- CONTRACT
WELL WE ALL OPPOSED PROPOSED-
SHOOT IN THE TEMPLATE FISCAL
PANEL- ALIGNED WITH THE COMMON
FROM THE- STATE SO. OF COUNTIES-
WITH VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
STATE RUN FIGHT. HANNAH ABOUT
THE REPEAL OF THE 7% CONTACT
HAPPENED A CO SPONSOR OF THE
REQUEST TO PERMANENTLY REPEAL
BACK CUT- WE SUPPORT AND CO
SPONSOR- THE PROPOSAL- WITH.
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION ON APR REDUCE YOUR
HOMELESSNESS AND- TO IMPROVE
AND ENHANCE USE OF ELECTRONIC
FORMS WERE IRATE YOURSELF THANK
YOU VERY KINDLY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE HAVE ABOUT EIGHTEEN
CALLERS LEFT WE CAN MAKE IT IF
EVERYONE. TAKES A MINUTE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AGAIN WE HAVE A
HARD SET UP FIVE. WONDER EIGHT
THOUGH. ABOUT A THIRD CENTER
PAN THANK YOU FOR MUCH MY NAME
IS MITCH MATTHEW BUT HEALTH
PART CENTER MANAGED M. S.
PEOPLE THE MY IN. WELL SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY- WE URGE YOU TO
MAIN THE FUNDING FOR THE Y.
TIME- IT WILL DO- WE TIME- THE
END OF THE WEEK. IN NINETEEN OR
TWENTY NINETEEN AND- TO
CONTINUE FUNDING THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND EXPAND THE PROGRAM SO
WE CAN KEEP PEOPLE GOING BACK
INTO A NURSING HOME. AND THE
MAINTAIN THEIR QUALITY OF LIFE
WE'RE COST EFFECTIVE YOU. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
AMERICAN LINEUP ONE OLD FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DENISE LIKER AND I'M AN
MSSP SITE DIRECTOR FROM LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AT INDEPENDENCE
AT HOME. I'D LIKE TO URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT ITEM FOUR ONE SEVEN
OH DEPARTMENT OF AGING PROPOSAL
FOR INVESTMENT ITEM NUMBER ONE
TO CONTINUE THE RATE THE RATE
CONTINUING OF THE MSRP RATE ON
THAT THE PREVIOUS CALLER JUST
BROKE UP AND THAT THAT THE
PROVIDE IN HOME INTENSIVE CARE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES TO SOME OF
OUR MOST. FRAGILE AND FRAIL
OLDER ADULTS WHO OFTEN ARE
ISOLATED ALONE THEIR MEDICARE
HEALTH NOWSHERA COSTS OF THEIR
LIVES ON VERY LITTLE MEANS AND
ELIGIBLE FOR SKILLED NURSING
HOME PLACEMENT TODAY DURING THE
CALL THE PANDEMIC WE HAVE KEPT
THOUSANDS AND PEOPLE SAFE. AND
IN THEIR HOMES AND CODE FREE IN
ORDER FOR THEM TO CONTINUE TO
THRIVE REALISTICALLY IN THE
COMMUNITIES OF THEIR CHOICE.
PLEASE CONSIDER- OUR RATES UP
CONTINUE IN SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THESERVICE
STATE WIDE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TAX COLOR PLEASE.
THANK YOU COME LINE ONE FOUR
FIVE YOU'RE LINUS OPEN. RIGHT
WITH A CH CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF
OF OUR OVER FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND LONG TERM CARE
PROVIDERS I WANT TO FIRST THANK
MADAM CHAIR AND DR CANCER
THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS TODAY. I'M WORTH
ACCORDING THE FOLLOWING ADULT
PROGRAMS THE PROPOSAL ONE TWO
THREE AND FIVE WELL WE
APPRECIATE THE CURRENT
EXTENSION OF THE SUSPENSION OF
THE 7% CUT TO H. SERVICE HOURS
DIFFICULT TO HANG THE CUT OVER
THE RECIPIENTS AND THE
PROVIDERS IN THE OUT YEARS JUST
SIMPLY WRONG. UNDERCUT NEED TO
BE MADE PERMANENT ESPECIALLY IF
THEY TRULY VALUES THE
RECIPIENTS AND HARDWORKING
PROVIDERS ADDITIONALLY WE
SUPPORT A VERY DIFFICULT
PROPOSALS RELATED H. OF THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING THE
COUNTIES NEED TO BE MADE- YOU
COULD BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
UTILIZE THE TOOLS PROVIDED. IN
ORDER TO SELL AGREEMENT
UNFORTUNATELY SOME COUNTIES
EVEN AFTER BEING GIVEN THE
TOOLS HAVE GONE BACK BINDING
AND MEDIATION BILL COME TO
IMPACT AND SHOULD BE ABOUT THE
HIGHER FISCAL PENALTY AND THEN
FINALLY ONE EXPRESSED STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE APS PROPOSAL TO
INVEST IN THE PROGRAM. IN ORDER
TO SUPPORT VICTIMS OF ABUSE- TO
REMAIN SAFE IN THEIR HOMES AND
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
COLOR PLEASE. THANK YOU W. LINE
OR OF THER TWO YEAR LINE OF
OPEN. LINE ONE THIRTY TWO YOU
LINE UP. MOVING ON MODERATOR
WILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH LINE
ONE FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ONE FOUR TWO. HI THERE- MY NAME
IS DAN- CONVERSE REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
IN THE PAST CENTERS AND WE ARE
STATEWIDE NUMBERS PRECIPITATION
MAKING UP ME TO HAVE
CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY AGAIN AND
LIVING CENTERS. AND- WE CALL IT
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL NUMBER
TWO ON THIRTEEN OF THE- I JUST.
REALLY THE DEPARTMENT AGING- TO
INCREASE THEIR SCENES BEYOND
WHAT THE GOVERNMENT DOES AND
BUDGET. IN ORDER. AND MEETING
COULD BE WE HAVE TO USE- THE-
REQUEST THANK YOU FOR TO THINK
YOU VERY MUCH THANKS PLEASE
WITH THE DOG TO THANK. WELCOME
ONE ONE THREE THE LINE OF THE-
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NAME IS ON
CLEAN AND I COULD PROVIDED
FORMER COUNTY I THINK THE FOR
OF THE CAMPUS AT THE TOP END OF
FOR CAN TO BAIL TO BARGE WITH
OUR UNION AND GET PAID. WE ARE
PAID LOW WAGE FOR LIKE THE SITE
LYFT WORK AND IT'S TIME TO THE
TO INVEST IN A JUST AS AN
EXAMPLE OF THE WAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
VERY LOOKS COLOR PLESE. THANK
YOU ON THAT ARE PROBLEM ONE
THIRTY. YOUR LINE IS UP. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE WINNER AND MEN
AND MEMBERS OF THE MY IS EILEEN.
I'M DIRECTOR COUNTRIES THE
HOSPITAL AND IF THE HE CALLED
UNLOCKED COUNTY THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING
INVESTMENT PROPOSAL NUMBER ONE.
IT'S CALLED FOR AND THE FIFTY
RATE PERMANENTLY I'M ADDS
CENTER PAM HAS SO ELOQUENTLY
DESCRIBED LIKE OTHER AYE HHS
PROGRAM MSSP HAS A RATE CUT HE-
HAD. AND IT'S- IT'S A PROGRAM
THAT THAT WE PROVIDED A STRONG
CASE FOR STATE AND FEDERAL COST
SAVING- OF THE PROGRAM- SERVING
OLDER ADULTS OVER- NURSING HOME
CARE. THIS PAST YEAR THE
PENDENNIS TRAGIC IMPACT ON OUR
OLDER ADULTS ESPECIALLY THOSE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY. HAS
ILLUSTRATED THE ESSENTIAL
NATURE OF ON THE COMPUTER
LIFESAVING ALTERNATIVE. FOR
OLDER ADULTS YOUR MIND ONE INTO
MY CARE GIVERS AND THE
TEMPORARY RATE INCREASE AT
TWENTY NINETEEN HELPED TO
STABILIZE THE PROGRAM THE WIDE-
OVERALL IN MY AGENCY WAS BLE
TO FILL VACANCIES NINETEEN
HIGHLY QUALIFIED STAFF. TO
SERVE THEIR SPECIALIZED
POPULATION OF EMERGENCY CLIENT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO STABILIZE
THE PROGRAM AND SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE OUR BUDGET DEFICIT
HELPING TO ENSURE WE CAN.
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THE SERVICE
THAT THE PREVIOUS RATE WAS A
TWELVE YEAR OLD READY ON AND SO
WE JUST ASK THAT YOU. PLEASE
SUPPORT THE RATE THE PERMANENCY
TO ALLOW AND TO BE DIFFICULT
FOUNDED THE FUTURE. ON HELPING
OLDER ADULTS WITH MULTIPLE
CHRONIC CONDITIONS I'M SURE THE
THIRD RECEIVE NEEDED SERVICE AS.
AS THE AT HOME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT CALL PLEASE. AND
COME LINE OF A SEVEN YOUR LONG
IS OPEN. ALL GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS DENNIS COULD AND I'M
THANK YOU. ADVOCACY THANK YOU
VERY I DO FAMILIES OF CENTRAL.
ANIMAL SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
JUST DECIDED THAT. AFTER THE
THEM AS A EIGHT BERMAN I'M AT
THE DEFAULT- KEEPING HOMEBOUND
OLDER ADULTS AND THEIR- AND OUT
OF THE NURSING FACILITIES OVER
THREE. HERE'S SOME OF HOW- OUR
SIDE AND LOOK AT LEAST FIVE
HAVE BEEN TO SUPPORT FOR THE
OLDER DON'T. WILL BE THANK YOU
FOR THEN. WE TO- HE CONTACT
WITH CLIENTS A MONTH BASIS THE
AND VIDEO. WITH THE NEXUS ARE
CLIENTS DELIVERIES ARE. MENTAL
SERVICES. I'LL BE SEVENTY TO
FOR. YOUR TO ARE QUIET YOU
DON'T SCHOOL A. B. FIELD STATE.
FARM HAVE A CURED IN THE- WITH
DELIVER FIFTY TO OUR RYAN ON
THE DISCOUNT GET TO MAKE
OPPOSED. AND PROVIDE TRYING TO
DON'T SHOP IN THE STORE CLIENTS.
THAT PROVIDE TO TOWARD WITH
ABLE TO THE- HI MY NAME IS
KANIKA LOWER AND HI MY AGE THAT
THAT ROGER WHAT YOU GOT HERE
AND I SAID ON YOUR GIFT. BOARD
ALSO. AND IJUST WANTED TO. SAY
THAT I. AM IN SUPPORT OF THE
10% FISCAL PANICKY. FOR
COUNTIES WHO FAILED TO BARGAIN
WITH OUR UNION AND GREAT GREAT
WE ARE ALREADY PAID VERY WELL
WAIT VERY. VERY LIFESAVING WORK
AND I THINK IT'S KIND OF THE
COUNTIES IN RATS IN THE I.
EIGHT THAT THAT PROGRAM CAN PAY
FOR WORKING. I THINK THERE'S
LIKE THIS CHRIS HERE AND IN I
EXPECT THAT PRO. BY MANY-
PEOPLE WHO STAYED AT THE
AIRPORT THE PROGRAM BUT THEN
THESE THINGS ARE BEING BROUGHT
UP TO THE TABLE OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN. AND HEART ELDER
LEAD THAT THEY BALK OUR
POPULATION I THINK YOU GUYS SO
MUCH FOR BEING A PART AT
HEARING ABOUT. AGING BECAUSE
WE'RE ALL GETTING THERE AND
SOMEDAY WE WILL BE THERE
HOPEFULLY NOT NEEDING. A WHOLE
LOTTA HELP BUT IF WE DO I THINK
WE NEED TO SET THE FOUNDATION
NOW SO THAT IT CAN BE BUILT
UPON BY THE NEXT GEERATION.
THESE PEOPLE WENT THROUGH
HOLOCAUST I MEAN EVERYTHING
THAT THEY'VE BEEN THROUGH AND
THE GREAT DEPRESSION AND ALL
THE THINGS CAN BE LEFT ON CARE
FOR AND HIGHLY AND NOT BEING
ABLE TO MEET THE REQUIREMENTS
OF WHAT HUMAN LIFE NEEDS. TO BE
ACCEPTING THANK YOU VERY THANKS
VERY MUCH I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE PHILLY AND I'M PASSIONATE
RUBICON TOMORROW MYSELF. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK MEDICAL
MINE. THIRTY THREE ONE THREE.
I'M SORRY- THANK YOU MADAM TO
COMING MEMBERS ASSIST WEISS BAY
LEGAL AID AND- COMMENTING ON
ITEM ONE ISSUE THREE SSI REST-
THANK YOU FIRST PASS THE GOLDEN
CAME STIMULUS AND FURNITURE
THAT BALBOA. TO ALL COUNTY WERE
MOST IN NEED INCLUDING PEOPLE
ON CAL WORKS AN SSI WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO MEET THEIR BASIC
NEEDS I HOPE THAT YOU WILL ALSO
SUPPORT INCREASED ACCESS P. THE
STATE'S SUPPLEMENT PRECIOUS I
RIP RECIPIENTS THE BRING THE
GRANT UP TO THE POVERTY LEVEL
THE TO INCLUDE A RESTORATION OF
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT SO
THAT SENIORS. AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES IN CALIFORNIA DO
NOT HAVE TO LIVE BELOW THE
POVERTY LEVEL I ALSO HOPE THAT
YOU WILL HELP TO PRESERVE AND
STRENGTHEN THE TRANSITIONAL
NUTRITION BENEFITS PROGRAM-
THAT- SHANTI PRASAD DISCUSSED
EARLIER- TO- INSURER OF.
ADEQUATE NUTRITION BENEFITS FOR
MIXED INCOME HOUSEHOLDS THE
MIGHT OF LOS CALFRESH TO
CALFRESH EXPANSION. FOR SSI
RECIPIENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH COURT. AND THAT'LL
COME FROM LINE A ONE FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
JOHN BALUTAN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF HEALTH PROJECT CENTER I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HERE- I AM DIRECTOR ALSO
OF THE INNOCENCE PM MONTEREY
AND SANTA CRUZ. COUNTY. FIRST-
SAY THAT I WOULD REALLY URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT- PROGRAMS THAT
IDENTIFY MASTER PLAN AN AGING
THAT PARTICULARLY THOSE PROGRAM
TO KEEP PEOPLE HEALTHY SAFE AT
HOME. PROPHETICALLY WITH THE
MESSAGE PEQUEA WORKS TO KEEP
TWELVE FOR EACH YEAR AT HOME
MOM WHO COULD BE PAID FOR. BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. PUT IT
INTO A SKILLED NURSING FACILITY.
BOTH SAYING THAT WE CANNOT GO
BACK TO RATE TO BE BURNED
TWELVE YEARS AGO IN ORDER TO
KEEP LET'S TALK AT HOME. I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO KEEP YOU
KNOW TO MAKE. THE INCREASE IN
RATES WHERE PROPOSAL WE HAVE SO
WE CAN CONTINUE TO DO THE GOOD
WORK WE'RE DOING AND THEN
FRANKLY GOING FORWARD WE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO EXPAND. THE PROGRAM
IT AND NOT WOMEN WHO CAN BE
TALK FOR AND NOT LIMITED
GEOGRAPHICALLY- MY ORGANIZATION
WOULD LOVE TO TAKE THIS PROGRAM
OVER THE SAN BENITO COUNTY IT
ISN'T THERE AND THAT REALLY
ISN'T FAIR THE RESIDENTS THERE.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TAKE
CARE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NO
CALLER. THANK YOU MALCOLM FROM
LINE A ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MADAM CHAIR MY
CARROLLTON WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY THIS AFTERNOON
ON A COUPLE THINGS I WANT TO
BRING YOUR ATTENTION ONE IS WE
COMPLETELY SUPPORT THE COMMENTS
BY THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF FOOD BANKS ON THE FLIP SIDE
GRANT INCREASES. AND THE NEEDS
FOR SIX TO THE TEAM BE PROGRAM-
WE ALSO WANT TO ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE THAT OR IF YOU SHOULD-TAKE THE FOLLOWING WAY- WE
REALLY APPRECIATE- LOW INCOME
OF PUBLIC ASSISTANCE RECIPIENTS
BEING POVIDED THE KIND OF
STATE ASSISTANCE THAT WE
PROVIDE TO LOW WAGE FAMILIES
FOR SOME TIME. SO I THINK THIS
IS A BIG STEP FORWARD AND WE
REALLY STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
IDEA THAT WE SHOULD KEEP AN
OPEN PORTAL. OUR DAILY- SUBJECT-
JUST ONE TO MAKE ONE COM ON THE
UPPER FONG. THIS IS A KEY ISSUE.
TO ALTHOUGH DROPPING CASELOAD.
WE THINK THE MOST SUBSTANTIAL
REASON WHY THE CASE WAS
DROPPING CONTINUES TO BE- BOB-
A DETERMINATION PRACTICES. YES
THE- THE RESOURCE LIMIT IS AN
ISSUE A PROBLEM THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO GET RESOLVED AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL BUT- WE REALLY
NEED TO FIND A WAY TO GET OUR-
FOLKS APPROVED. QUICKLY AND NOT
HAVE TOO MANY PEOPLE GET
DENIED. I THINK THAT THE MAJOR
ISSUE THE COMMITTEE SHOULD BE
AWARE. SO THANK YOU THOSE MIGHT
COME THROUGH TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU MEADOW COME FROM ONE
OF. ONE FIFTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME OF
ASTRAZENECA AM AND I INTERESTS
OF PROVIDERS WITHOUT COUNTY AND
THE EXECUTIVE V. P. OF UEW-
DECEMBER SECOND WAS PUT PLACE
NEARLY AS- AGO. AND IT IS LONG
OVER TO BE RESTORED EVEN WITH
THE TEMPORARY RESTORATION
AGENTS PROVIDERS AND
RECIPIENTS. I'VE HAD THE 7% CUT
THE SERVICE OUR HANGING OVER
THEIR HEADS FOR YEARS NOW. WE
CANNOT CONTINUE TO BALANCE THE
BUDGET ON THE BACK. TAX OF OUR
COMMUNITY MOST VULNERABLE. AGES
THAT HAS SHOWN THAT IT IS
BECOMING MORE AND MORE
IMPORTANT EACH AND EVERY YEAR
AND THAT IS WHY WE HAVE TO
SUPPORT. AND YOU WE ENCOURAGE
YOU TO SUPPORT PERMANENTLY
RESTORING THE 7% PAT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY
YESTERDAY. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU MEADOW COME FROM ONE
OF ONE FIFTY. HELLO MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS MARK
SONNTAG MEANT REPRESENTING THE
SAN FRANCISCO MORAN. NOW WHILE
APPLIED ARE. EFFORTS TO INCLUDE
ACCESS- YES AS P. PERCENT
PARTICIPANTS IN THE GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS PLAN. FIRST WE
HAVE THE ADVOCACY FROM A LOT OF
MY COLLEAGUES- THAT'S WATCHING
IN ALL OUR PARTICIPATING IN
THIS HERE AND NOW. MORE NEEDS
TO BE DONE BECAUSE WE ARE NOT
IN NEED X. A X. ALAS THERE WE
NEED TO DO TWO THINGS- STRENGTH
IN THE TRANSITION OF NUTRITION
BENEFITS AMONG OTHERS WHEN YOU
NEED TO INCREASE THE RESTORED
TO CUSTOMERS ACCESS I. S. S. B.
GRANTS DONE DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION AND GET THEM OVER TO
PROPERTY WARY. AS A PERSON WHO
HAVE FAMILY THAT RECEIVE ACCESS
R. S. S. P. BENEFITS WHO WORKED
WITH HOMELESS SENIORS AND OTHER
PARTICIPANTS RECEIVE THE
BENEFITS. I'M NOT A VITAL THESE
BENEFITS ARE IN LESS MONEY
COULD MEAN A CHOICE BETWEEN
HELLO FRANK. BILLS ARE MEDICINE
NOW THAT'S. A HARD PILL TO
SWALLOW. AND ALSO MAY LEAD THAT
WILL FOLLOW CAL. ONE ARE NOW.
LET'S GET Y. NIKE JUST DO.
BECAUSE WE ARE NO IS WERE. YOUR
NEVER YOU HEAR THE END OF US IN
AGAIN- THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOT COLOR PLEASE. THANK
YOU AMERICAN PROVIDE A. ONE
FIFTY EIGHT. HELLO OF JEREMY
THIS IS BOB NAYLOR I REPRESENT
THE SIX BEDS INK WHICH IS AN
ASSOCIATION OF MORE THAN TWO
THOUSAND RCMP'S IN A. R. S.
SMALL SMALL A- THE- FACILITIES.
I'M CALLING ON TWO ITEMS. SHE
WAS SIX FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES WE SUPPORT
THEIR- BUDGET REQUEST. AN ISSUE
FOR RELATING TO THE CLOSURE OF
A R. S. WE SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR THE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS- TWO ONE
FOR GRANTS TO COUNTIES. FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND
PURCHASE OF. OF BOTH FACILITIES
HAVE THREATENED WITH CLOSURE
BUT WE DO WANT TO POINT OUT TO
AND YOU OBSERVERS OR. QUESTION
WHETHER. THE MAINTENANCE IS THE
FOR THE CALL AND ARE OF.
BECAUSE THE SSI. GRANT IS TOO
LOW IT IS NOT KEPT UP WITH THE
YOU KNOW INCREASED COSTS NOT
EVEN THE INCREASE IN THE
MINIMUM WAGE REQUIREMENT FOR. A
POSSIBILITY WORKERS. MANY
COUNTY SUPPLEMENT- THAT GRANT-
AND WE HELPED ADMINISTRATION
WILL MAKE. SUCH A SUPPLEMENT-
CAN. ON RECEIVING. THE APPLE-
GRANT OTHERS PROPOSED IN THE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU HAVE A COME
FROM LINE SEVENTY SIX THE LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CAPTAIN LILY AND I'M
BUT I EXPECT. H. I. HFS
PROVIDER COLORFUL OR COUNTY.
APRIL OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TO
SPEAK ON- PROPOSAL NUMBER ONE
FISCAL PENALTY. RIGHT PROVIDERS
WILL CONTINUE TO BE PAID JUST
OVER MINIMUM WAGE UNLESS WE
PROPOSE A 10% PENALTY I
COUNTIES REFUSED TO BARGAIN IN
GOOD FAITH A RECENT REPORT BY
THE STATE AUDITOR FOUND THE I.
H. S. THE CARE GIVERS MAKE ONLY
50% OF THE LIVING WAGE THE
WHITE FOR THAT REASON I SUPPORT
THE 10% PENALTY. ON COUNTY
STOCKPILE DEPARTED WITH THAT
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU I'LL COME FROM LINE
OF ONE NINETY. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH WHEN. GO AHEAD YES
HI- MY NAME IS DOES MEN-
PRESCOTT AND- I AM A I JUST AS
PROVIDER RATHER RIVERSIDE
COUNTY- WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO HEAR. US OUT.
AND I WAS CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF- BIG COST OR SHARE. I THINK
WE LOST THE SUPPORT KEEPING THE
CURRENT. 41% SHARE OF CALLS CAN
YOU HEAR ME I CAN'T REALLY DOES
MINIMAL YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
LEFT IN ABOUT FOUR MORE COLORS
ON IT I'M ASK YOU TO CONTACT
THE COMMITTEE LATER NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU AND THAT'LL
BE IT FROM LINE ONE FIFTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MY NAME
IS PETER PAN INTO LINE
REPRESENTING ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK. WE WOULD
LIKE TO RECORD OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR AN EXIT HE GRANT
INCREASE. IN ORDER TO BRING THE
PHOTOGRAPH OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL. FURTHERMORE WE
HAVE TWO REQUESTS REGARDING
TNT. FIRST WE ADVOCATE FOR
EQUITY WITH HOW FRESH
REPLACEMENT FUNDS FOR FOOD LAW
CAN DOCTOR'S POWER OUTAGES AND
LOG FIRES. FINALLY THE
REQUESTED URGENT RELIEF TO
PRESS TOPIC CHURNING PNB
HOUSEHOLDS THE PROMINENT FIX TO
PREVENT IN MEETING A MEMBER TO
LOOK THEIR FOOD SOLELY TO
MISSED PAPERWORK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
MEDICAL FROM LINE ONE SIX
FOURTH ONE OF THE- HI THIS IS
PATTY WATSON- THANK YOU ABOUT
CHAIR COMMITTEE FIND THE
NURSING SUPERVISOR. FOR MSF
SITES HUNTING HOSPITAL SENIOR
KERR NETWORK AND I JUST WANNA
LET MY SUPPORT TO THE RATE
PERMANENT FOR MSSP THAT MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY
EXPRESSED THE BENEFITS OF THIS
PROGRAM THANK YOU I THINK IF
YOU'RE BREVITY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU METAL COME FROM LINE. ONE
THIRTY TWO. GO AHEAD CALLER.
HELLO HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- UNCLEAR RAMJI AND
JUSTICE IN AGING AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ITEM NUMBER TWO TO RESTORE THE
7% CUTS TO IHS US FOR ALL THE
REASONS THAT A PRIEST
PREVIOUSLY BEEN STATED. AND WE
ARE ALSO A CO SPONSOR OF ITEM
NUMBER FIVE TO INCREASE THE
MONEY FOR THE HOME STATE
PROGRAM TO HELP ENSURE YOUR
HOMELESSNESS ENSURE. WE HAVE
ENOUGH ADEQUATE RESOURCES FOR
OLDER JUSTICE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WE HAVE ONE
MINUTE LEF WE HAVE ONE COLOR.
LEFT IN THAT WOULD BE A HARD
STOP. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT SAM THE GUY THAT. ALL
RIGHT WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR- WE THANK EVERYBODY
WHO. ON THE FROM THE
DEPARTMENTS IN LA- WHO PREPARED
AND PRIEST PRESENTED TO US
TODAY. WE THANK THE STAFF HERE-
IN THE BUILDING AS WELL AS OF
ALL THE PREPARATION DID
PREVIOUSLY. AND WE THANK
EVERYBODY WHO CALLED TO
EXPRESSED- THERE THERE FACTS.
ABOUT THE SERVICE OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE SENIORS THANK YOU
ALL VERY MUCH AND THAT
CONCLUDES THIS COMMITTEE.